Das ist es soweit.
Das, und nie wird jemand erfahren, was passiert, bevor du Rekord drückst.
Folge 2.
Das stimmt, außer die Leute, die schon live zugeschaltet haben.
Genau, die aber nichts besser sind, als die den Podcast hören. Kein bisschen, das sind alles Berüchte.
Podcast-Hörer sind die Hörer erster Klasse, weil die können auch auf Pause drücken.
Genau, genauso wie die Live-Hörer, weil die können live hören.
Aber die können nicht auf Pause drücken. Gibt es eigentlich Streaming-Clients, die so buffern, so wie das so ein Fernseh-Client macht?
Du meinst, die einen Livestream buffern können, damit es danach dann weitergeht?
So, hier guck mal, hier meine ITV-Software zum Beispiel, die ich an meinem Mac Mini dran habe. Da ist so ein DVB-T, USB-Stickes, Fernsehen.
Also die so Werbe, da kannst du die Pause wegdingsen und dann...
Ich kann generell einfach auf Space drücken und dann buffert der halt mit Fernsehen immerhin. So, und ich meine, das sollte ja nun für ein Audio-Stream auch kein Problem sein. iTunes kann das natürlich nicht, weil wäre nun echt ein bisschen... Ich meine, iTunes hat ja schon Probleme live zu spielen.
Ruckel, ruckel.
Aber so ein Ding, wenn ich Pause drücke, dass er dann halt einfach puffert und dass ich vorspulen kann. VLC kann das auch nicht, oder?
Ich hab noch nie mit VLC, glaub ich, einen Livestream gehört.
Braucht man, wenn man so WM und Real Audio und OK und so was...
Ich find das ja schon ganz schlimm bei diesen, bei diesen, wie heißt das, UPnP-Servern, die so Microsoft-Standard und sowas, was ja dann VLC und sowas auch alles kann. Nicht mal die können das. Auch da kann man Stream nur anfangen und gucken.
Ja, ist blöd, ne?
Total. Also ich meine, da liegt er, da liegt er auf dem eigenen Rechner. Der Stream, oder auf dem eigenen Rechner, auf dem eigenen Server.
Ich fänd das ja mal ganz gut, ne? Aber auf mich hört ja keiner.
Muss ich gerade Besserungsmails, gute Besserungsmails für Katzen schreiben.
Ich dachte, sie ist gestorben.
Ja, meine ist meine. Ich hatte zwei, jetzt ist es noch einer. Aber für eine Fremdkatze.
Fremdkatze?
Fremdkatze, also nicht meine, das ist nicht meine. Malte, kennt vielleicht auch jemand von Spreeblick.
Ja, der immer so tolle Artikel schreibt.
Der immer so tolle Artikel schreibt. Kann offensichtlich nicht ganz so gut laufen. Hat versehentlich die Katze getreten, die neue. Und jetzt so ein bisschen.
Und ist gerade beim Tierarzt.
Oh weia.
Gute Besserung von hier aus.
Spreeblick scheint kein gutes Omen zu sein.
Hunde da gingen halt extrem lange durch.
Kot-Kenten. Kot-Content. Katzen in Gefahr bei Spreeblick. Wie auch immer. Jetzt erstmal die offizielle Begrüßung. Hallo, willkommen zu Mobile Max. Die Ausgabe Nummer zwölf. Und wir haben uns hier wieder zusammengefunden in der üblichen Besetzung. Ich stelle vor.
Wir haben keinen Wind und Wetter gescheut, hierher zu kommen.
Genau.
Jetzt regnet es gerade ein bisschen.
Dennis hat sich wie so ein Schattenreiter auf sein Moped geschwungen. Er kam hier rein wie der Knight Rider.
So ein bisschen ist auch...
So ein Zilonen-Auge hätte dir noch ganz gut gestanden.
Und ein bisschen was fehlt von Dennis, denn Dennis ist ja aus Zucker. Im Gegensatz zum ganzen Rest. Was?
Dennis ist aus Zucker?
Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, wie der Ansatz enden sollte.
Was sind das für eine Anspielung?
Wir sind doch nicht aus Zucker, was regnet?
Zu meiner Rechten, Max Binde. Hallo, Max.
Ich bin wieder links, genau, Dennis.
Genau, zu meiner Linken, Dennis.
Und Tim ist wie immer verteilt.
Genau, in der Mitte. Ich halte den Podcast zusammen, Leute. So, und wir wollen uns unterhalten über den McIntosh. Und über das iPhone, welches ich jetzt... Mein Eigennummer. Ein Korea ist gefahren nach Italien und hat es erworben und mir gekauft. Sodass ich jetzt stolzer Besitzer nicht nur eines iPhone 3G bin, sondern eines angelockten, vertragsfreien iPhones.
Und was hast du jetzt bezahlt dafür?
Das kostet 500 Tacken.
500? Ach so, das ist die 8 GB Version.
Richtig, 16 GB ist, zumindest war es vor ein paar Wochen, nicht zu haben in Italien. Also das war dermaßen ausverkauft, dass es einfach nirgends wo überhaupt irgendjemand eins gesehen hat. Außer vielleicht den paar, die dann immer so die 4 oder 5, die irgendwo wieder reingereicht wurden und die das dann innerhalb der ersten 10 Sekunden, nachdem der Laden geöffnet hatte, gekauft haben. Aber grundsätzlich keine nennenswerte Verfügbarkeit von 16 GB iPhones und ab und zu hier und da mal halt 8 GB. Und so ein paar Glückliche, die das in so einer Kleinstadt gekauft haben, haben das wieder zurück nach Deutschland getragen. Und dann war ich in der glücklichen Position, da eins, was dann noch so auf Halde mitgekauft wurde, weil sie sich dachten, das wären wir schon los. Dann sind sie dann los geworden. Ja, und dann hab ich da halt meine O2-SIM-Karte reingesteckt und das ging sofort, noch bevor ich das Ding irgendwie an irgendeinen iTunes angeschlossen habe.
Achtung, du musst das nicht mehr aktivieren, oder sowas?
Dann musst du auf die Software von dem Ding eigentlich genau diese Software nehmen und auf ein anderes iPhone übertragen können. Dann hat man auch unlogged, ohne dass man jemals wieder Stress mit iTunes und so weiter hat.
Möchte man meinen.
Möchte man meinen, ja. Sollten die Hacker doch nutzen können.
Kann man denn das problemlos auslesen?
Nee, nicht solange es nicht jailbreakt ist.
Aber jailbreaken lässt es sich doch.
Aber irgendwann haben die Hacker doch bestimmt schon längst getan, oder nicht?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, da steck ich zu wenig in dem Thema, als dass ich das jetzt qualifiziert beantworten könnte.
Weil die 3G-iPhone sind ja immer noch nicht anlockt von den Hackern. Aber gejailbreakt sind die schon. Das heißt, eigentlich bräuchte doch nur jemand, der denen mal so ein Telefon verbreibelt. Dann können sie die Firmware auslesen. Oder auch nicht, keine Ahnung, was die so drauf haben. Und wie die da so rangehen. Aber sollte denen doch beim Hacken eigentlich helfen.
Aber, wozu eigentlich, wenn man ehrlich ist? Weil man kann ja zum Beispiel auch nach Tschechien fahren. Du hast übrigens hier gar keinen Strom, sehe ich gerade.
Ja, der Scheiß-Stecker ist kaputt. Das ist so ein Standardproblem. Und man kann ja, genau, gab es ja von Apple hier diesen Pseudo-Recall, so ein bisschen von Netzteilen, ne?
Wechselt ihr jetzt mit einem Satz das Thema oder was?
Ja, nur ganz kurz.
Und gehen jetzt sofort wieder zurück. Bei Dennis leuchtet das Lämpchen nicht vom Netzteil.
Und wenn der Stecker vom Netzteil irgendwie so bröselig ist und sich verfärbt, kann man ja ein neues sich bestellen bei Apple. Hingeht zum Laden, gibt es ab, kriegt ein neues. Ist aber leider bei mir nicht so. Aber die Lampe ist kaputt. Man muss kurz rausziehen, da ranstecken.
Das hier, guck mal, das Kabel rutscht ja raus.
Ja, gleich hingehen, super.
Das ist, da lass ich's um. Nein, das ist noch nicht so alt.
Na und, gerade deswegen?
Ja klar, natürlich. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich unbedingt ein neues Herz da haben wollte. Thema, Thema.
iPhone, iPhone.
Italien.
Jetzt war für einen kurzen Moment der Stream laut genug. Genau. So und jetzt hab ich's, jetzt hab ich's. Und dann hab ich's benutzt und ich bin sehr kritisch und distanziert an das Thema rangegangen.
Das hat man bei dir irgendwie ein bisschen bemerkt.
Ich hatte vor allem, ich bin sehr vorsichtig vorgegangen, sehr Schritt für Schritt und ich hab eine unglaubliche, das geht bestimmt schief, Grundeinstellung gehabt. Und ich bin nicht enttäuscht worden.
Es ist schiefgegangen?
Nein. Nein? Also ich bin nicht von Apple enttäuscht worden.
Aber vom iPhone?
Nein.
Von deiner Grundeinstellung.
Wie was willst du uns jetzt sagen?
iPhone ist komplett super, kauft euch sofort ein. Selbst Tim ist begeistert.
Nein, ich hab dann einfach meine Erfahrungen hier schön mit protokolliert und mir zahlreiche interessante Fehler notiert, die dieses Gerät hat. Grundsätzlich kann ich sagen, ich finde, dass das Gerät sich ganz hervorragend bedienen lässt. Das macht total Sinn. Es ist noch sehr buggy. Es stürzt immer wieder mal was ab. Mir ist das ganze Gerät mehrfach abgestürzt. Mir stürzen immer mal wieder Programme ab. Mir stürzt Safari bei bestimmten Webseiten ab. Interessanterweise stürzt es schneller ab, wenn man Porn lädt. Also auf so Porn-Webseiten hab ich das Ding innerhalb von fünf Sekunden gekillt bekommen. Keine Ahnung warum, aber war so. Und dann bin ich halt auch in diese bekannten Fehler reingelaufen. So dieses, dass man irgendwann gar keine Programme mehr starten kann. Das sozusagen alle Set-Party-Ups wegdingsten. Allerdings konnte ich auch alle Probleme durch Neubuten beheben.
Oh, die 202 hast du drauf.
Loswerden erst mal. Ich bin mit 202 gestartet.
Das war schon drauf.
Oder?
Das muss man nachdenken.
Das ist ja schon relativ neu, solange ist es ja noch nicht.
Nein, Entschuldigung. Es kam mit der 201 und ich hab dann gleich zu Beginn das auf 202 geupdatet. Was auch alles irgendwie ging.
Genau, dass kein Unlock verschwunden, kein gar nichts. Du musstest es irgendwie nicht anmelden. Du hast es einfach geupdatet und es war weiterhin benutzbar so wie vorher.
Genau, das war so, wo ich hier wirklich so saß und mir dachte, ob das wohl mal klappt. Weil da dachte ich mir schon so, ok, jetzt machst du als erstes dieses 202-Update, hast du es noch nicht mal richtig ausprobiert und danach ist es wahrscheinlich komplett in ein Telekom-Phone überführt worden, weil es merkt, dass es mal in Deutschland eingebucht war oder irgendwas grausames.
Und kann man dann auch in der Verpackung sehen, dass es eine Unlocked-Version ist oder auch nicht?
Davon steht da nichts. Du kannst es nur daran sehen, dass die Bedienungsanleitung in Italienisch kommt, die mir herzlich wenig hilft.
Mikrofon, Kabel, Konnektoren, Dock, Alimentatoren.
Ich war am Wochenende in Tschechien und hab mir kein iPhone gekauft, das mich jetzt eindeutig disqualifiziert als wahren Apple-Jünger.
Viel schlimmer als noch, dass du mir keins mitgebracht hast.
Okay, wir sind bei Availability. Die News ist, in Tschechien gibt es offensichtlich erstens iPhones ohne SIM-Log, und zwar bei allen Providern.
Sieht so aus.
Der es drei gibt, Vodafone ist da, O2 ist da und Telekom.
Was haben die Tschechen, was wir nicht haben? Warum dürfen die sowas machen und wir nicht?
In Italien, soweit ich informiert bin, ist der Grund schlicht und ergreifend der, dass sowas wie SimLog da noch nie eine Chance hatte. Also das ist da einfach, auf dem italienischen Markt gibt es dieses Konzept nicht, da spielen die Leute nicht mit. Und deswegen haben die Provider wahrscheinlich gleich gesagt, das machen wir nicht. Keine Ahnung, warum ausgerechnet Italien so kompetitiv ist.
Da scheint sich so die Intelligenz, die beim Wählen von Parteien fehlt, scheint sich da durchzuschlagen, auf das Wählen des richtigen Vertrages.
Na, die regeln wahrscheinlich Competition einfach auf Mafia-Ebene. Von daher, keine Ahnung.
Man kann Telefon einfach so schlecht klauen, wenn...
Gut, so, dann bin ich davon ausgegangen. Ich hatte mir vor zwei Wochen diese neuen Webseiten angeschaut, mit jemandem, der Tscheche spricht, und da war das ein bisschen unklar. Und wir haben irgendwie so recht keinen Hinweis darauf gefunden, dass es auch Prepaid gibt, aber du meintest jetzt, oder du hast was im Forum gefunden, wo Leute tatsächlich behaupten, es gibt Prepaid iPhones ohne Vertrag in Tschechien.
Auf der O2-Seite, auf der tschechischen, steht unten so ein kleiner Hinweis drin, iPhone-Verkaufspreis, also für das Gerät, und dann steht 8 GB Version kostet so und so viel Kronen, und die 16 GB kostet so und so viel Kronen.
Und umgerechnet 483 Euro für das 8 GB und 563 oder 68 Euro.
484 habe ich für die eine und ja, irgendwie so 580 für die andere.
Genau, also sogar noch ein bisschen billiger als die italienischen.
Dennis rechnet gerade nach, ob sein Tank noch voll ist.
Tschechien hat natürlich den Vorteil für uns, dass es nicht so weit weg ist.
Italien.
Also für uns in Berlin.
Für uns ist das ganz großartig eigentlich. Wie gesagt, ich war ja am Wochenende da. Ich hab's leider nicht geschafft. Ich war mit Freunden da und wir waren in den Bergen. Wir waren am Bummklettern. Nur so, es tut mir wirklich ganz furchtbar leid. Und ich wollte jetzt nicht hier von Stadt zu Stadt die Scheuchen in der Wagen hoffen, möglicherweise irgendwo ein iPhone zu kriegen. Ach so, stimmt. Ist diese Woche wieder Wochenende? Gut, das schreib ich mir mal im Kalender. Warte mal, ich krieg hier gerade von jemanden... Per Twitter kriege ich gerade rein. Ich war gestern in Tschechien. O2 nur mit Vertrag wurden zwei Läden weggeschickt. T-Mobile und Vodafone haben nur 8 GB Geräte. Aber immerhin...
Das heißt, man muss hier so einen Native rein schicken? Das weiß ich nicht. Ne, weggeschickt ist das andere. Dann sagen sie, wir wollen ja keinen verkaufen.
Sagst du nicht gerade, gibt es nur mit Vertrag...
Ich war gestern in Tschechien. O2 nur mit Vertrag wurden zwei Läden weggeschickt. Tim Mobile und Vodafone haben nur 8 GB Geräte. Das heißt, dann nehme ich mal an, dass es die da ohne, auf jeden Fall ohne Vertrag gibt.
Aber warum kostet das dann so viel?
Genau, das haut ja nicht hin.
Warum geben die so einen hohen Preis an für ein iPhone, wenn es...
Vor allem, wenn da gar nichts zu den Vertragsbedingungen steht.
Das kann auch sein, dass sie die einfach weggeschicken, weil sie nicht genug haben und das nur erstmal... Und dann geht weg. Keine Ahnung. Naja, wie auch immer.
Aber mal ehrlich, wenn es jetzt die da gibt und in Italien kann es nicht so lange dauern. Also bei Ebay werden die natürlich auf jeden Fall schon... Gibt es ja Reseller. Und wenn es noch mehr Länder und noch näher irgendwie diese Phones unlockt gibt, dann müsste auch der Ebay-Preis sinken. Und dann kostet es bei Ebay vielleicht 50 Euro teurer als in Italien, dafür musst du aber nicht runterfahren. So gesehen sollte sich das Problem eigentlich demnächst lösen.
Aber Prag ist schön, lohnt sich mal hinzufahren.
Man muss ja gar nicht bis nach Prag. So, soll ich jetzt mal von meinen iPhone-Erfahrungen...
Ach so, ja stimmt, du hast ja ein neues iPhone.
Genau, ich wollte ja mal anfangen, aber...
Erzähl doch mal, wie das so ist, wenn man Tim mit dem iPhone hat.
So, ich hab mir hier so ein bisschen... Ich hab die noch nicht so richtig sortiert, meine Notizen. Deswegen fang ich einfach mal irgendwo an. Erstens, als ich das Ding eingeschaltet habe, hat Google Maps sofort Deutschland angezeigt. Also nicht in Deutschland.
Aber das gesamte Deutschland.
Das gesamte Deutschland. Da frag ich mich natürlich, warum ein italienisches iPhone... Also er hat wahrscheinlich einfach gesehen... .ist eigentlich eingebucht in ein deutsches Netz.
Simkarte vielleicht, deutsche Simkarte.
Nehm ich an. So, fand ich schon mal ganz interessant. Also solche Dinge wertet er sofort aus.
Ich hab das übrigens noch mal geprüft, auch wenn es jetzt nicht ein Themenwechsel ist, aber so ein ganz bisschen. Und zwar ist es wirklich so, dass der Locate-Button in der Maps-Applikation, wenn du den drückst, dann geht er nur dorthin, wo er meint, wo du gerade bist, also wo der blaue Kreis ist. Aber die Infos holt er sich auch, wenn das nicht aktiv ist. Verstanden? Na ich jetzt meine Maps-Applikation vom iPhone öffne. Und das nicht aktiv ist, dass er rausfinden soll, wo er ist oder dass er es anzeigt, weil es ist nämlich nur die Anzeige. Es ist nicht das Rausfinden, weil er rausfinden tut er das immer. Und er würde den Kreis auch dorthin meinen, wo du bist, auch wenn du es gerade nicht in Anzeige hast. Also man muss nicht drücken, dass er diese Information holt. Der macht das immer. Nur wenn du draufdrückst, dann zoomt er auch hin.
Interessant.
Weil jetzt könnte ich jetzt hier auspacken, hab es nicht aktiv, könnte zu dir scrollen, so von Hand und dann würde da der blaue Kreis kommen, obwohl ich es nicht aktiviert habe. Ich hab es extra nochmal ausgetaucht. Bei dir ist es halt der leuchtende Punkt, weil GPS und so bei mir kommt das ja nicht.
Also GPS habe ich ziemlich extensiv ausprobiert. Grundsätzlich hat das gut geklappt. Ich hatte einmal den Fall, dass es sich nicht aktivieren lassen wollte, überhaupt die ganze Location, aber das war wahrscheinlich wieder grundsätzlich so ein Hänger. Ausschalten, neu booten, Problem war weg. Dann habe ich es viel im Auto getestet. Und ich habe den Eindruck, dass es so ein bisschen nachhängt. Also das ist, dass so ein GPS im Auto...
Das habe ich auch irgendwo gelesen.
Das war auch in den Kommentaren, glaube ich. Es ist nicht so richtig auf den Punkt. Es ist super akkurat. Also wenn man ihm ein bisschen Zeit gibt und er so 4-5 mal Refinement macht und noch einen Satelliten mehr sieht, ist es wirklich auf den Meter genau, würde ich sagen. Also zumindest habe ich das in mehr als einem Fall gehabt, dass er mich wirklich verdammt gut lokalisiert hat.
Aber eine Satelliten-Anzeige gibt es ja genau gar nicht. Sieht genau so aus wie bei mir, nur dass bei dir eine GPS-Unterstützung ist. Dabei sagt er nicht, wie viel Satelliten oder Qualität oder sonst wo und das alles sieht man genau gar nichts von.
Weiß ich auch gar nicht, ob man überhaupt eine Möglichkeit hat, in diese Informationen ranzukommen mit irgendeinem South-Party-Detail. Wird mich nicht wundern, wenn nicht.
Naja, die Applikation selbst ist ja von Apple, nicht von Google, oder?
Jaja, klar, natürlich das GPS, müssen sie ja selber betreiben. Klar, könnten sie, aber tun sie halt nicht, weil das ist eine Information, die ja eigentlich nicht, interessiert ja eigentlich nicht. Wobei das mit diesem Nachhängen, könnte ich mir ganz gut vorstellen, dass das eine reine Software-Optimierungsgeschichte ist. Dass das im Prinzip so schnell ist, wie auch ein normales Navi, dass, also ich hab das so im Hinblick auf, wie wäre das jetzt mit einem Navi, würde das ausreichen? Ich könnte immer rechtzeitig sagen, dass ich jetzt rechts abbiegen soll. Im Prinzip ist es natürlich so, dass wahrscheinlich die Navis und TomTom oder so genau das gleiche Ergebnis im Prinzip haben, also auch keine andere Echtzeitmessung kriegen, aber immer so eine Prediction machen. Ich bewege mich mit der und der Geschwindigkeit in die Richtung, also bin ich in fünf Sekunden da und von daher schon sagen können, so jetzt musst du abbiegen. Ich schätze mal, dass solche Optimierungen drin sind. Und diese ganzen Gerüchte im Bezug auf das 2.1-Update des iPhones, die ja schon länger kursieren, da war ja auch davon die Rede, dass es Optimierungen gibt in Bezug auf GPS-Lokalisierung und vor allem auch Richtungsanzeige bei GPS-Messungen, dass sie im Prinzip ihre Software refine und solche Sachen möglich machen. Warum jetzt TomTom, obwohl sie ja mal gesagt haben, dass sie schon eine iPhone-Applikation haben, warum sie diese noch nicht rausgebracht haben oder zumindest angekündigt haben, dass sie das tun, ist mir ein bisschen schleierhaft. Entweder ist es wirklich so, dass Apple den, wie gesagt hat, auf dem kurzen Dienstwege, braucht er gar nicht erst einstellen, machen wir eh nicht online.
Machen wir selber vor allem.
Machen wir selber. Keine Ahnung. Andererseits, mal ehrlich, glaubst du ernsthaft, dass Apple sich den Schuh anzieht, so ein richtiges Navi-System zu bauen?
Na ja, vielleicht haben sie ja ein Deal mit irgendeinem anderen, Bude.
Ja, mit wem denn? Mit Google?
Garmin? TomTom, irgendein neuer Drittersteller, der sich einen Namen machen will. Weißt du, umso unbekannt, umso einen besseren Deal kann noch Apple machen. Aber Geld verdienen wollen die auf jeden Fall. Also die sagen TomTom nicht ab, weil sie nichts machen, sondern weil sie schon einen Grund haben.
Ja, aber warum sollte sich Apple diesen Schuh anziehen? Also warum sollten sie Auto-Navigation anbieten? Warum? Wegen der Einblendung der Lokalisierungsdaten und der Werbung. Google zeigen, wo Restaurant ist und das? Das machen sie ja im Prinzip jetzt schon mit Google. Na, du kannst ja irgendwo sein und dann suchst du nach Restaurant und dann kriegst du das ja. Von daher wäre das schon so ein Argument, was ich gelten lassen würde. Andererseits ist auch so Auto, Navigation...
Das wissen übrigens auch viele nicht, dass man in der Suche bei dem Maps-Ding, das kannst du McDonalds eingeben und dann pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, komm lauter fahren, wo McDonalds ist. Die meisten denken, man kann nur Straßennamen eingeben, ist aber gar nicht so. Man kann da auch eingeben...
Das war doch schon in dem ersten Werbevideo fürs iPhone so.
Das funktioniert sogar ziemlich gut mit dem Starbucks da.
Können doch ganz viele, die dann immer gucken und das gar nicht kennen. Wollte ich mal so gesagt haben.
Also grundsätzlich, Lokalisierung, GPS, prima. Ich hab dann auch dieses Tool ausprobiert, GPS Tracker, was es im Upstore kostenlos gibt. Das ist sozusagen das Frontend für instamapper.com. Was einfach so eine ganz simple Webseite ist, wo du dir einen Account machst und dann sagst du halt, die sagen, unser Dienst ist frei und wird immer frei bleiben. Und wir machen nichts mit euren Daten. Das kann man jetzt glauben oder nicht. Tatsache ist, es kostet erstmal nichts. Und dann startest du einfach dieses GPS-Tracker. Und das nimmt halt die GPS-Koordinate und du kannst konfigurieren, wie häufig er aktualisieren soll. Und dann gehst du los oder fährst du los und dann schickt er einfach die ganze Zeit online deinen Track ins Internet.
Kann er das auch offline machen? Also kann er sich das auch zusammenspeichern und dann zum Beispiel nur einmal pro Stunde gesammelt hochschicken?
Tja, das wär, glaub ich, ein ganz wünschenswertes Feature, damit man das auch benutzen kann, wo es kein Netz gibt.
Zum Beispiel oder Stromspat halt.
Aber das tut dieses Tool in der Version nicht. Und ich hab es an einer Stelle eingeschaltet, wo er schon gesagt hat, er schickt jetzt los. Aber er hat dann tatsächlich in der Route, die ich später dann in so einem Google Maps Widget dann auf instamapper.com mir angeschaut habe, erst einen Kilometer später wirklich eingezeichnet.
Bist du mit dem Auto unterwegs gewesen oder zu Fuß? Also so 20 Sekunden, 30 Sekunden?
Na, nee, war ein paar Ampeln dazwischen.
Okay. Also schon ein paar Minuten.
Schon ein bisschen mehr, ja.
Aber das Programm muss die ganze Zeit im Vordergrund und anbleiben. Das heißt, wenn du auch schon ein Autolok hast, dann geht das ja schon aus, oder?
Aber ich hab einen Anruf bekommen zwischendurch, aber er hat nicht aufgehört zu tracken. Ich hab den auch gleich abgelehnt, aber...
Also mit diesem nur ein Programm laufen lassen, das ist einfach Müll.
Aber immerhin schon mal gut, dass die Programme nicht dadurch terminiert werden, dass ein Anruf reinkommt.
Wieso ist das klar?
Dass die Anruf-Applikation in den Vordergrund kommt und dann müssten die ja der Logik, dass nur eins läuft, folgend in den Hintergrund gehen. GPS-Lokalisierung funktioniert super, bis auf einmal, wo das iPhone mich einfach partout in die Barentssee verbannen wollte. Also er hat mir einen GPS-Fix angezeigt, war aber nicht davon abzubringen, dass ich irgendwo zwischen Alaska und Russland war. Und da das so nah an der Datumsgrenze war, sah mir das schon sehr nach einem Bug aus. Ich hatte auch irgendwann mal was gelesen darüber, dass es irgendeinen Vorzeichenfehler gab.
Der Vorzeichenfehler, der ist, wenn man die Bilder in iPhoto rüberholt, dann...
Das ist eher, was in den Exif-Daten abgelegt wird.
Da gibt es negative Breitengrade und das sollte eigentlich nicht negativ sein, sondern als Ost angegeben werden und so weiter.
Genau, aber das war es irgendwie, das passte so nicht dazu. Also das war irgendwas Obskures, das ging dann irgendwie auch wieder weg. Dabei ist mir noch was anderes aufgefallen, und zwar habe ich nämlich nach... Hat mir jemand erzählt, dass er jetzt auswandert, und zwar nach Naui.
Nee, nach...
Moment, ich hab's mir notiert hier.
Er ist...
Ich hab's mir notiert. Ja, hier hab ich's mir notiert.
Nach Niue.
N-I-U-E. Das ist so ziemlich der einzige Ort, von dem ich gehört habe, der bei Google Maps zwar suchbar ist und findbar ist, aber wo dann nichts gezeigt wird, weil das ist so eine kleine Insel, und da ist drum herum nix. Wasser. Ja, da ist Wasser. Aber die nächste Nennenswert, das ist so im Südpazifik. Und zwar ist das an der Datumsgrenze, und dann ist mir auf einmal aufgefallen, dass die Google Maps Anwendung von Apple eine Sache nicht kann. Du kannst nicht über die Datumsgrenze scrollen. Was für ein Quatsch. Nein, du stehst links, du stehst an der Datumsgrenze an. Wenn du in Australien nach Osten gehst, die Welt ist doch eine Scheibe. Die Welt ist eine Scheibe.
Und wir wissen es dank Apple.
Die Welt ist eine Scheibe. Bei Apple zumindest ist die Welt eine Scheibe. Und das ist echt doof, oder? Das geht doch gar nicht. Also bei Google Maps geht das doch auch im Kreis. Du kannst da so rauszoomen, dass du die Welt fünfmal siehst.
Stimmt, das geht da.
Das geht da problemlos. Und die Ideen sind da irgendwie nicht gekommen. Was mich ein bisschen wundert, weil ich meine, Amerikaner, die haben immerhin noch Hawaii als Bundesstaat. Ich meine, so im Pazifik sollten sie ja mal so ein bisschen vertraut sein, dass sie das mit den Umlauten immer nicht hinkriegen im ersten Schuss. Daran hab ich mich ja schon gewöhnt. Aber Datumsgrenze, ich bitte dich. Jetzt, wo sie so stolz sind, dass sie da Alaska so schön nah an den USA, an Russland dran haben und das ja allein schon das dort Wohnen schon außenpolitische Kompetenz nach sich zieht.
Oh, jetzt sind wir ja bei voll dem Thema.
Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall Lokalisierung prima. So, dann hab ich mir Gedanken gemacht, wie denn das mit dem APN ist. Weil ich hab so angefangen rumzusurfen, O2. Und ich hatte Internet und ich hatte Internet und ich hatte Internet, aber ich hab nur irgendwo ein APN eingegeben. Und ich dachte mir so, oh feier, APN. Da gab's doch den einen und wenn man den nimmt, dann wird's teuer und dann gab's den anderen und nur wenn ich den nehme, wird's billig. Aber es ging einfach so. Dann hab ich nämlich gerätselt und dann hat mich ein Leser, Hörer darauf aufmerksam gemacht, nachdem ich das kurz geblockt hatte, dass O2 vor kurzem das geändert hat. Sie haben jetzt einen Default-Hotspot, einen Default-APN. Man muss jetzt den APN nicht mehr eingeben, sondern es gibt jetzt einfach nur noch Netz.
Und der ist auch billig.
Es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass das Netz dem Telefon sagt, welchen das verwenden soll. So eine Art APN-DACP.
Haben sie gemerkt, dass es alles Schwachsinn ist?
Ja, ja. Ich glaube, die Telcos kommen jetzt drauf, dass es doch vielleicht gar nicht so eine Scheiß-Idee ist, wenn man den Leuten einfach mal den Zugang zum Internet einfach einfach macht. Ja, ordentliche Tarife, dann benutzen die das und dann haben sie was davon.
Ich glaube, bis das durchsickert, vergeb noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Es tut sich aber was. Wie auch immer. Ich habe den APN trotzdem konfigurieren können. Wir haben gesagt, dass bei Telefonen, die jetzt gelockt sind, Telekom, man den APN nicht einstellen kann.
Hier haben wir eine Konfigurationsdatei drauf, pro Provider und auf deiner SIM-Karte ist irgendwie so eine, ich habe die Kürzel vergessen, aber so eine Art Identifikationsnummer und danach wird dieses Profil ausgewählt und dann wird halt bei Deutschland das Telekom-Profil ausgewählt und da ist alles schon fest eingetragen, auch Service-Nummern und so. Die haben teilweise Erweiterungen in diesen, wenn du in Einstellungen-Network gehst, dann kriegst du auch so teilweise Service-Nummern angezeigt. Die sind alle in diesem Profil drin. Und wenn du halt das Telekom hast, kriegst du hier Telekom-Service-Nummern. Wenn du irgendwelche anderen Provider hast, kriegst du irgendwelche anderen Service-Nummern und auch hier für das, wie heißt das hier, die Anrufbeantworterzeug. Voice-Mail. Voice-Mail, da sind auch so Einstellungen drin und so wie lange die gehalten werden und so weiter und so fort und welche Nummer dafür gewählt werden und so was.
Interessant, ja, ich habe nämlich auch gehört, dass O2 sozusagen hier nicht dabei ist, das heißt, er kennt eigentlich das Netz nicht.
Also das ist nicht O2 Deutschland nicht, weil O2 Ireland zum Beispiel war immer drauf.
Ja klar, weil da wird es ja auch offiziell.
Genau, da habe ich mir nicht kopiert und ein bisschen umgeändert, weil ich habe mir nämlich mein eigenes O2 Deutschland...
Gut, dazu muss ich aber ein Jailbreak machen, um das sozusagen hinzuzufügen. Bei mir äußert sich das so, dass wenn ich einen Anruf mache, dass er mir dann immer so einen Call Forwarding Activated anzeigt, was lustig ist, weil erstens habe ich keinen Call Forwarding eingestellt, das heißt, das ist ein Fehler, also er macht es falsch und zweitens sollte er es sozusagen mir auch nicht anzeigen, weil es mir dann egal ist.
Das verschwindet aber nach zwei, drei Sekunden.
Das mit dem Call Forwarding ist aber eine ganz, das ist eine ganz merkwürdige Sache, das stimmt, das ist.
Hast du auch schon mal gehört?
Weil in der Zeit kannst du ja auch nicht auf Speaker drücken, richtig?
Ja, ich hab das auch.
Also da kommen ja so sechs Felder für Speaker und Numpad, damit man DTMF-Töne eingeben kann und lauter so andere Sachen und on hold und Conference und so. Und solange dieses, was hast du gesagt, was da steht?
Call for Warning.
Call for Warning, solange kann man die halt nicht drücken. Ist ein bisschen blöd, aber der verschwindet noch ein paar Sekunden, geht ja wieder weg.
Da gibt es von zendofsky.de, gibt es in Sydia, ein Jailbreak wirst du ja hoffentlich noch machen, oder? Tim.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ernsthaft? Also wenn du ein Jailbreak gemacht hast, gibt es bei Sydia ein Repository von Zendofsky, heißt er glaube ich. Der hat so deutsche Einstellungen, da kann man zum Beispiel auch, dass die Telefonnummern für Deutschland vernünftig formatiert werden und so was. Und dann auch so eine kleine Späße, dass da oben dann so ein kleines Icon ist. Und da gibt es dann auch ein Package, mit dem man dieses Core-Forwarding deaktivieren kann, bei O2 zum Beispiel. Aber auch bei den anderen. Also der hat für alle Provider so kleine Icons und so was, die man sich da schön dazu laden kann. Also die Icons habe ich nicht installiert.
Ja, habe ich auch gesehen, für ganz Europa sind da die Profiles für die Provider drin.
Genau. Und das ist eigentlich, also wie gesagt, die Icons ist eine Geschmackssache, aber dieses Core-Forwarding ist auf jeden Fall das nicht zu haben, ist eine tolle Sache.
Aber was für ein Icon eigentlich, wo soll denn das kommen?
Na das kommt dann da, wo jetzt o2.de steht.
Ach, da kommt dann ein Bild anstatt des Textes?
Stattdessen kommt da so ein Bild. Und da gibt es das eben mit T plus und T-Mobile und für alle.
Ja, habe ich letztes Jahr auch gesehen, wollte ich installieren, aber dann habe ich es irgendwie doch vergessen.
Und ja, das braucht man jetzt nicht, aber wie gesagt, das mit dem Core-Forwarding, das nervt dir wirklich wie Sau.
Ja, das ist halt die totale Abzocke der Provider, weil du rufst irgendwie bei jemandem an, da geht irgendeine Mailbox ran, damit du dem denen sagen kannst, irgendwie per SMS später, dass du angerufen hast. Und für alle armen Schweine von heute, die irgendwie so Verträge haben, wo man die Minute voll bezahlen müssen, die, die die Minute voll bezahlen müssen, die sind dann richtig arm dran. Ich habe ja Gott sei Dank sowas nicht, aber mir geht das ganz schön auf den Keks, weil du erreichst keinen außer so eine blöde Boxenmuster für bezahlen. Was soll denn das?
Ja, geht eine ganze Minute von deinem Kontingent runter, vor allem für diese Gründe.
Bei mir nicht, ich habe nur noch einen Telekom-Vertrag heutzutage.
Standard-iPhone-Telekom-Vertrag, das ist genau die Falle.
Also Jungs, schön alles abschalten, weil es geht mal so nicht.
Das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum ich keinen Telekom-Vertrag haben wollte.
Die volle Minute? Ich kriege hier gerade mitgeteilt von Aaron, dass der uns über Edge hört mit dem Radio-App auf dem iPhone. Über Edge funktioniert der Stream.
Der Edge ist 20k, ist schon ein bisschen...
28kbit.
Hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass das klappt.
Also ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung, dass Edge voll toll ist.
Edge ist super. Ich hatte jetzt auch... Ich war in der Pampa am Wochenende, da gab es dann wieder schwache O2-Deckung und hab dann auch T-Mobile bekommen und dann Edge. Auch heute in der U-Bahn übrigens. Ich hab dann im Tunnel, im Upstore was runtergeladen. Großartiges Living the Future Moment wieder. Also das Roaming klappt ganz gut. Ich dachte ja, das Roaming in den Städten wäre jetzt ausgeschaltet von O2 zu T-Mobile.
Ich glaube aber wirklich nur in der U-Bahn.
Nur in der U-Bahn.
Ja, woanders hab ich es bisher noch nicht gesehen. Was bei mir eben das Lustige ist, da ich ja bisher noch kein 3G habe, dass bei mir in der U-Bahn ausschließlich, also dass ich in der U-Bahn schnelleres Internet habe auf dem iPhone als draußen. Das heißt, ich muss mich eigentlich immer in die U-Bahn setzen.
Ja, iPhone weiter. Was hatte ich noch? Ja, dann Empfangsqualität. Das ist ja so ein Thema. Also so gefühlt ist es ein bisschen schlechter als mit meinem Nokia. Gefühlt sage ich insofern, als dass ich zum Beispiel bei mir in der Küche teilweise kein Netz hatte und ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, dass ich mit meinem Nokia da schon mal kein Netz hatte. Weiß man natürlich auch immer nicht so genau, weil man muss ja mal hingucken auf sein Telefon. Das iPhone habe ich natürlich jetzt etwas genauer beäugt, weil das benutzt man ja dann überall, nicht? Kannst du dir vorstellen, wie ich letzte Woche rumgerannt bin irgendwie die ganze Zeit mit dem Teil vor dem Auge und so. Keiner konnte mehr mit mir hier nennenswert kommunizieren.
Wie oft bist du auch so gestolpert?
Hat dich angerufen.
Mein Haupt, mein Lieblingswort war, hä?
Ja, aber mit der Empfangskollektiv kann ich bestätigen, weil ich wohne halt relativ mittig. Und ich finde, das ist auch leicht schlechter als vorher mit so einem Standard Nokia, was aber auch schon ein paar Jahre alt ist. Also ich hatte so ein 63CNI, so das Standard-Telefon irgendwie und ich habe das Gefühl, der Empfang ist jetzt leicht schlechter. Und ich messe das nicht an den Balken, weil die sind natürlich total der Blödsinn, da kann jeder Balken hinmalen, wie er will, sondern wirklich wie ich so, wie weit ich ans Fenster oder in meinen Wintergarten latschen muss, um irgendwie noch telefonieren zu können. Und ich finde, das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen schlechter als vorher. Aber ich hab ja auch Metallrahmen, nicht so wie du, ne? So schicke Plastischeiße, wo schön alles durchkommt, wenn das denn wirklich was ausmachen sollte.
Tja, weiß ich auch nicht. Die Usability von dem Teil ist besser, als ich dachte. Also es ist ja vor allem der Lautsprecher, der wirklich laut ist. Lautstärke-Tasten ist etwas, was ich auch bei meinem iPod immer vermisst habe. Also, dass man wirklich eine Volume-Control als richtige Tasten hat, das ist wirklich, wirklich wichtig.
Gerade während des Telefonats.
Weil Software-Interface mit Touch und so weiter, kannst du einfach sogar in der Hosentasche das Ding machen. Ich hab hier mir ein großartiges Produkt von Griffin. Also, erstmal die normalen Standard-Headsets sind für mich nicht zu vertragen. Ich hasse Kopfhörer, die ich in meinen Ohr stecke. Die halten nicht, die Nerven fallen raus.
Nein.
Und dann habe ich mir Kopfhörer gekauft. Neue, die ich früher schon mal hatte, so ähnliche. Von Sony kann ich sehr empfehlen. Das Modell heißt, wie so schreiben sie denn das bitte ich nicht auf, die Dinger drauf habe ich in meinem Blog geschrieben, irgendwie MD, irgendwas, MDR, CDP, 66, FUBAR, wie auch immer, diese typischen Bügelteile, die man halt so aufs, hinter das Ohr klemmt. Das mag ich sehr gerne, weil dann liegt das so frei und liegt einfach auf und drückt nicht. Und mit zwei Knöpfen dran und, gucken kann ich das hier, hört man das?
Zum Aufziehen.
Man kann einfach, das Kabel wird aufgerollt im Kopfhörer selber. Das heißt, man kann die Dinge, wenn man sie nicht braucht, das Kabel komplett im Kopfhörer versenken und hat diesen ganzen Kuddelmuddel nicht. Was mir immer schon eine Minute raubt, wenn ich erstmal den Kopfhörer wieder aus der Tasche ziehe, dann erstmal damit beschäftigt bin, das Kabel zu entwirren. Da ist ein relativ kurzes Kabel dran. Dazu habe ich mir von Griffin das Produkt Smart Talk gekauft. Das ist so ein halben Meter langes Textilkabel mit einem korrekten Stecker, mit einer Headset-Taste und Mikrofon dran. Das heißt, das macht aus jedem normalen Kopfhörer ein Headset. Ich kann also hier jeden beliebigen Kopfhörer anschließen. 20 Euro.
20 Euro, das ist natürlich schon Geld.
Wo ist jetzt der Vorteil?
Na, das macht aus jedem Kopfhörer ein Headset.
Da ist ein Mikrofon drinne?
Da ist ein Mikrofon drin und diese Annahmetaste. Und mit dieser Taste kann ich erstens Start-Stop von, wenn ich Musik oder Podcasts höre und natürlich auch einen Ruf annehmen, was extrem praktisch ist.
Genauso wie das Kabel, was dabei ist, wo ja auch schon man den Button so drücken kann. Genau.
Lautstärke wäre hier noch super, wenn das irgendwie mit Integrit wäre, aber ich glaube, das ist nicht vorgesehen von Apple.
Ich kenn keinen, der das hat, insofern.
Aber ich kann dann in meine Tasche greifen, man kann diese Lautstärke-Knöpfe ganz gut fühlen.
Das geht echt super.
Und das ist eine korrekte Lösung. Dann die Taste hier oben, auch zum Schalt-Bildschirm-Abspar, Strom, aber spielt trotzdem noch Musik ab. Super. Alles macht einen super soliden Eindruck. Alle Tasten, alles ist einfach solide. Ist ein bisschen glitschig, das Teil. Aber vielleicht muss ich da noch mal so einen Schlüpfer drauf machen.
Du hast ja draufgesabbert. Aber schön rund und nicht so wie das alte.
Und ja, also das Griffin Smart Talk kann ich echt empfehlen. Überhaupt, ich war auf der IFA und bin beim Griffin stand vorbei und hab mit denen mal ein bisschen geredet und war mal wieder beeindruckt, wie freundlich und wie kompetent die alle waren. Also wirklich unglaublich. Und hab neulich auch mal, hab mir dann so einen Katalog von denen mitgenommen und mal durchgeblättert, was die alles machen. Da fällt mir ja komplett hinten über. Also wie viele unglaubliche Accessories, die die mittlerweile haben, die echt Sinn machen. Also insbesondere so Auto, Ladeadapter, in allen Formen und Farben, Taschen, Schnickes. Und der Knaller ist Gryphon, macht jetzt sogar Apps. Wie? Gryphon hat Software im Upstore, Spiele.
Ach so, aber...
Gryphon, der Zubehörartikler.
Naja, aber ein bisschen Erfahrung haben die auch schon lange, weil die haben nämlich zum Beispiel mal dieses Radio, dieses USB-Radio gehabt für, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, iShark, oder ich weiß nicht wie das hieß, das sah so ein bisschen aus wie so eine High-Flift-Schleuse.
Also als Hardware-Produkt.
Genau, aber da braucht man ja auch Software dazu.
Ach so, ja gut, aber ich meine Treiber und jetzt Software für ein iPod, die mit der Hardware nichts zu tun haben, das sind so hier so Slot-Maschinen und so ein Kram. Also das ist nichts, was mit irgendeinem ihrer Produkte zu tun hätte.
Naja, vielleicht hat er da...
Selten Markt.
Ja, offensichtlich. Die wollen da auch verdienen. Aber zum Upstore kommen wir noch. Also wie gesagt, vom Handling her bin ich super zufrieden. Ich hab erstmal mit meinem USB-Autoadapter keinen Erfolg gehabt. Der hat einfach mit 400mAh zu wenig Power. Das supergeile iPhone-Netzteil hier, dieses Mini-Teil. Unglaublich, wie klein sie das bekommen haben. Das ist auch echt spitze, weil das einfach so wenig Platz nimmt. Da kommt eine Ampere raus. Ich hab das Gefühl, wenn ich über das Netzteil lade, geht das einfach doch signifikant schneller als am Rechner, wo ja nominell auch nur 500mAh rauskommen. Also, mit dem Netzteil laden empfiehlt sich sehr, wenn man schnell laden will. Ich find, am Rechner dauert's wirklich, wirklich richtig, richtig, richtig scheiße lange.
Das dauert eine ganze Weile.
Aber man muss es ja sowieso lange dran haben.
Das Backup vor allem.
Wie viel Backup? Wie groß ist denn dein Backup? Also was ist denn alles drin? Weil bei mir geht es ratzfatz zehn Sekunden.
Keine Ahnung, was der Backupt.
Da ist doch eh nie was drauf, oder?
Genau.
Also ich meine, die Applications zu Backupen ist ja nun Quatsch, weil die sind ja sowieso im iTunes.
Die Applications sind im Backup definitiv dabei.
Aber warum sollte er denn nochmal...
Ich sag immer nee, wenn er mich nach meinen Ups fragt.
Wie, wenn er dich nach deinen Ups fragt?
Wer fragt dich nach deinen Ups?
iTunes fragt, dass ich ja Programme auf meinem iPhone hätte, die nicht auf meinem Rechner sind, weil ich lag die immer mit dem Phone selbst runter. Und dann fragt er, ob er die auch rübersinken soll, damit die nicht verloren gehen, wenn mein iPhone irgendwie weg ist. Und dann sag ich immer einfach nö, weil ich hab die ja nicht gekauft, sondern sind ja die kostenlosen. Und dann macht er die nicht. Wenn die wechseln, lad ich die halt neu runter.
Der fragt dich, wie kann man das denn einschalten?
Ich sag ihm nochmal ja, soll er auf beiden haben, ist doch super. Aber ich hab kein Problem mit. Das geht doch nur wirklich schnell. Aber ja, das Backup dort hat einen gewissen Zeitpunkt relativ lange. Das stimmt schon.
Dieses Horror-Movie im Netz hast du sicherlich gesehen, irgendwo auf YouTube, wo einer acht Stunden auf seinen Backup gewartet hat.
Also bei Johnny ist das auch so. Der hat auch irgendwie eine Stunde oder anderthalb darauf gewartet.
Acht Stunden.
Acht. In der Zeit hat man das Telefon ungefähr fünfmal.
Da hat man sich ja ein neues bestellt und geliefert bekommen.
Also was meine Erfahrung ist, ich hab durch Zufall, und zwar, ich mein, mein iPhone muss ja mal jailbreaken und unlocken mit jeder neuen Firmware-Version und immer auf das neue Ownage-Tool warten. Und irgendwann nach diesem ganzen Update- und Restore-Prozess hat er dann gemeint, also er hat das Backup eingespielt auf dem Telefon. Es waren alle Daten wieder gesynkt. Das Telefon war wieder in dem Zuspann, in dem es vorher war. Und dann muss es ja immer nochmal neu starten. Und nach diesem Neustart hat er dann gesagt, ich hab hier ein neues iPhone gefunden. Willst du das als neues anlegen oder aus dem Backup wieder herstellen? Da war ich natürlich erst mal relativ verzweifelt. Und hab dann irgendwann in Foren gelesen, dass man sagen soll, melde das an als neues iPhone, was ich dann auch tapfer gemacht habe. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass alle meine Daten drauf waren, dass er danach natürlich einmal neu backupen musste, aber dass seitdem das Backup deutlich schneller geht.
Das hab ich nicht verstanden. Wodurch geht das Backup schneller?
Das Backup geht dadurch schneller, dass ich ihm gesagt habe, ich weiß aber nicht, wie man den Prozess forcieren kann, also über den er zwingen kann. iTunes hat gedacht, ich hätte ein neues iPhone, obwohl ich gerade ein Backup drauf gespielt hatte. Und daraufhin hab ich ihm gesagt, okay, melde das als neues iPhone an, und daraufhin ging das Backup schnell. Quasi ein fresh start mit meinen alten Daten drauf.
Also manchmal, ich weiß auch nicht, also manchmal war's fix, manchmal war's ewig unklar. Ich hab mir mit Secrets, mit dieser Präferenz-Database für die Systemeinstellungen, da ist dann auch die Option, dass man das Auto-Backup von iTunes abschalten kann. Ich hab's auch ausgeschaltet. Denn ich will immer mal wieder schnell was reinsinken. Da bin ich sehr dran gewöhnt, dass ich, so als ich, krieg eine neue Telefonnummer von irgendjemanden, neue Mobilnummer, die hab ich irgendwie in meinem Adressbuch und ich weiß, ich will die sofort auf meinem Telefon haben. Und dann hab ich mal eben über Bluetooth einen neuen Sync gemacht, egal wo das Telefon war. Und jetzt muss ich halt das iPhone erst mal ranstecken.
Das ist total der Scheiß.
Das ist wirklich schlecht. Also es sollte die Möglichkeit geben, Sync gegen auch über Bluetooth oder WLAN zu machen.
Also das wär tatsächlich ein Schlepppunkt.
Ja, vor allem mit dem Remote-Programm. Ich kann meinen iTunes fernsteuern damit, ja. Aber Synken geht nicht, was soll denn das?
Aber es gibt einen Trick und zwar ist das, wenn du einen iTunes so einstellst, dass er sich nicht automatisch synchronisiert, sobald du das iPhone anschließt, kann man wohl, hab ich noch nie ausprobiert, aber kann man wohl einfach über iSync Synken und dann Synkt er auch wirklich nur. Dann Synkt er auch nur die Adressen.
Per Bluetooth.
Nicht per Bluetooth, sondern über das USB-Kabel. Also man stellt...
Das iPhone mit iSync.
Genau.
Ist mir ganz neu.
Ist mir auch neu.
Unsere Live-Hörer können jetzt mal ein bisschen was tun. Und können uns gleich mal austesten. Muss dann ja alles selber machen.
Tja.
So weiter. Ich such das nochmal raus. Die Hörer sollen das mal probieren hier.
Aufgabenverteilung hier?
Klar.
Na gut.
Irgendwie ging das, ich such das nochmal raus.
Unser Streaming-Server macht Ärger übrigens. Also da gibt es gerade schwere Hickups. Also das ist der Vorteil des Podcast-Hörers. Der kriegt einfach alles mit. Da ruckelt nichts, da bricht nichts ab. Da gibt es einfach die klare High Quality.
Das ist halt die wirklich wahre erste Klasse.
Genau, die wahre erste Klasse.
Schön wär's.
So, ich fahre mal fort. Also Sünden und Backup. Also mit diesem Backup ist so eine Sache. Ich hab überlegt woran es liegt, dass es so dauert. Und dann dachte ich mir so, naja, irgendwie Flash-Speicher ist vielleicht nicht so schnell wie die Festplatte, hatte er vorher.
Aber nicht so langsam.
Aber acht Stunden, das kann irgendwie nicht sein. Also ich hab keine rechte Erklärung, warum das so lange dauert. Was lange dauert, was ja auch lange dauert, auffällig lange dauert, ist, wenn man über iTunes ein Programm kauft oder lädt. Ja, ich hab das jetzt mal sehr extensiv getestet. Dann dauert das Laden natürlich nicht lange, weil die Programme sind klein. Und wenn ich das dann sünke, dann dauert das Installieren lange. Also beim Sünken, wenn ich ein Programm das erste Mal raufschiebe, dauert das Installieren lange. Auch wenn ich im Upstore was kaufe. Ist das Laden schnell vorbei, aber das Installieren dauert lange.
Aber auch nicht so wirklich lange. 5 bis 10 Sekunden.
Das hängt immer von der größten Programms ab.
Das hängt von der größten Programms ab. Meine Theorie, warum das so ist... Doch, weil es ist doch so. Der Musikverkauf in iTunes, das ist ja schon vor einiger Zeit mal festgestellt worden. Der Download geht über Akamai. Das heißt, wenn du Musik X kaufst, dann geht das Ding ohne DRM ins iTunes. Und das iTunes fügt erst das DRM hinzu. Und wahrscheinlich ist das auch bei den Ups so. Die App kommt sozusagen unverschlüsselt ins iTunes. Und dieser Installationsprozess, also wahrscheinlich findet die Verschlüsselung im iPhone statt. Und beim Sinken ist sozusagen auch dieser Installationsprozess mit drin. Und das iPhone verschlüsselt das Ding erst in dem Moment, wo es wirklich ausführbar ins Dateisystem geschrieben wird.
Ich würde eher vermuten, dass es schon vorher, also dass das iTunes das DRM drum macht und das iPhone das dann wieder auspacken muss.
Du kannst es ja auf dem iPhone kaufen.
Ja, und dann macht das das iPhone das. Das muss das iPhone machen, das iTunes kann das nicht machen.
Das ist ja das, was die Hörer an uns so mögen.
Deswegen dauert es ja auch lange beim Sinken.
Ich meine, es ist nicht dokumentiert darüber. Dann könnte man einfach sagen, könnte man den iTunes gehen, könnte da eine IPSW oder wie die heißt, rausnehmen, eine IPA-Datei rausnehmen, könnte die auch in ein anderes iTunes kopieren. Na diese, die Dateien, diese App-Dateien. Die IPA. Wenn du so ein Programm, so ein iPhone-Programm... APP meinst du? Wenn du das hier, so wenn ich das jetzt sage, ich gehe jetzt hier in iTunes, in meinen Programmebereich, zum Beispiel auf IAM, sag dann, zeig mir das im Finder an. Und dann zeig da mir doch die entsprechende IPA-Datei. Was wahrscheinlich so viel heißt wie iPhone-Application. Ja, das hat er wahrscheinlich ein paar Mal runtergeladen. Keine Ahnung warum. Hier, Aurora Find hat er auch unendlich viel runtergeladen. Und wenn die Datei nicht verschlüsselt wäre, dann könnte ich die jetzt nehmen und zu dir rüber kopieren und du hättest das gleiche Programm wie ich, wenn das erst im Gerät sein würde. Das wäre dann albern.
Das stimmt. Hast du das schon mal ausprobiert?
Es geht mit absoluter Sicherheit nicht.
Weil Super Monkey Boy gibt es nämlich bei Pirate Bay.
Ja, aber um das zu installieren, muss man ja richtig arbeiten. Also da musst du ja auch auf dem Gerät was hacken. Nee, da reicht ein Jailbreak nicht.
Also ich muss da nichts weiter machen.
Wie hast du es denn installiert?
Raufgeschoben.
Als IPA? Oder per SSH? Nee, es gibt ja mittlerweile, gibt es ja in einigen Stellen gehackte IPA-Dateien, die man dann direkt mit iTunes rüber spielen kann. Was man dafür allerdings braucht, ist, man muss dann eine entsprechende Dylip auf dem iPhone ändern. Die den Sicherheitscheck machen. Und dann kann man keine Programme mehr über den App Store runterladen. Also das ist ziemlich nervig insofern. Ich hab das mal ausprobiert, hab das gemacht, hab beschlossen, nee, ich kaufe mir die Programme doch in Zukunft wieder, weil macht so einfach keinen wirklichen Sinn. Und insofern überprüft er auf jeden Fall, also kommt er auf jeden Fall beim iPhone, was verschlüsselt das an?
Vielleicht haben sie auch unterschiedliche Methoden, die Programme darauf zu kriegen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass dieses Verschlüsselungszeug der Grund ist, warum er so langsam ist. Und auch nicht der Grund, warum das beim Backup so langsam ist.
Also bei der ersten Installation muss er auf jeden Fall die ZIP-Datei auspacken. Dieses IPA ist ja auch ein ZIP-Format. Und wenn das 25 MB sind oder 20 MB, das können ja Programme mal problemlos groß sein, wie wir gerade gesehen haben bei diesem Aurora-Feind. Und wenn man das auf einem iPhone auspackt mit so einem langsamen IPA am Prozessor, dann kann das schon mal eine ganze Weile dauern. Gehe ich jetzt oder behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal so. Behaupte ich nicht nur, sondern ich so.
So, dein nächster Punkt.
Ja, der nächste Punkt. Was mich richtig genervt hat und eigentlich auch immer noch nervt, ist die Rechtschreibung. Also wenn man was eingibt, dann kommt einem halt einfach dieses Teil da irgendwie. Und die Vorschläge, die aus diesem Ding rauskommen, sind ja wirklich unfassbar. Also der schlägt mir Worte vor, die gibt's nicht.
Das ist teilweise unglaublich, oder?
Richtig viel und richtiger Quatsch.
Also bei mir ist es gerade, wenn ich betrunken bin, tippe ich gerne mal eine SMS. Und er erkennt, ich tippe irgendwas vor mich hin, und er erkennt noch die schlimmsten Sachen und macht mir das richtige Wort daraus, sodass ich mich richtig freue, wie gut das funktioniert. Und dann aus dem letzten Wort, was ich richtig tippe, kompletten Bullshit zu machen.
Also meinst, man kann das iPhone eigentlich nur im volltrunkenen Zustand zuverlässig bedienen?
Aber der lernt ja auch dazu, oder?
Noch besser.
Ja.
Es wird besser.
Und da bin ich jetzt...
Wobei der lernt nur sehr, sehr, sehr langsam, oder? Also ich hab mich neulich sehr gefreut, als er mal plötzlich nach einem halben Jahr statt AMS ständig SMS getippt hat.
Ja, das ist komisch und vor allem, er kennt ja auch nur eine Sprache. Wenn ich die Sprache umschalte, dann bute er das Teil nochmal komplett durch. Also diese gleichzeitige Verfügbarkeit mehrerer Rechtschreibbibliotheken geht wohl irgendwie nicht auf dem iPhone. Denn ich will natürlich das Ding bilingual betreiben. Das geht euch sicherlich genauso. Heutzutage spricht man Englisch und man hat die ganze Zeit englische Wörter. Und ich möchte natürlich, dass er aus beiden Rechtschreibbibliotheken sich da bedient. Ich weiß nicht. Also es wird besser, aber es nervt. Und es wäre schon sinnvoll, wenn man das abschalten könnte. Oder wenn man zumindest die Ausnahmen editieren könnte. Oder nur diesen Kack, also diese wirklichen vollkommen bekloppten Indivü. Ja, du gibst einige einen Indivü-Leville-Bäh.
Quatsch.
Also wirklich richtiger Blödsinn. Und ich hab keine Ahnung, was sie da geritten hat, sowas zu machen.
Ich glaub, die haben einfach ganz, ganz, ganz furchtbar schlechte Wörterbücher eingekauft.
Ja, und auch so, was weiß ich, wenn ich eine URL eingebe, eine E-Mail-Adresse eingebe. Dann mach ich tim.ccc.de, dann macht er immer es groß.
Ach, ccc groß.
Ja, immerhin.
Aus de macht er immer es.
Ja, genau, aus de macht er es. Ich meine, geht's noch? Es gibt einfach Felder, da hat es einfach nichts zu suchen. Das müssen sie irgendwie drehen.
Wobei, es gibt Programme, die haben dann auch eine andere Tastatur, wenn meine E-Mail-Adresse eingibt, und die korrigieren das dann nicht automatisch. Das scheint immer vom Programm abhängig zu sein.
Oder, wenn es zumindest eine Taste gäbe, die ich drücken könnte, um sozusagen, also wenn ich Space drücke, dann übernimmt er ja das, was er mir vorgeschlagen hat.
Ich hätte gerne eine Taste, die ich drücke, wo es nicht übernimmt.
Dass er das eben genauso nimmt, wie du oder Min.
Ne, dem das draufdützt. Ich hätte das auch gerne umgedreht, auf den Vorschlag.
Dass ich oben klicken muss, wenn ich es haben will. Nicht, dass er es automatisch nimmt.
Genau, genau.
Ach so rum.
Umdrehen. Ich tippe einfach, ich drücke Space, und dann nimmt er das, was er vorgeschlagen hat. Das sehe ich ja gar nicht, weil ich gucke ja auf die Tastatur. So muss ich immer auf die Tastatur und auf das, was er mir vorschlägt, schauen. Und draufgucken, ist das jetzt das, was ich will? Und dann stelle ich danach immer wieder Space, dann hat er es wieder übernommen, gehe ich wieder hin. Das muss andersrum sein. Er darf mir das vorschlagen und er darf mir auch gerne mehrere Sachen vorschlagen. Das vermisse ich auch. Auf dem Mac habe ich ja mehrere Vorschläge. Und so geht es nicht. Das ist entweder eine andere Taste, mit der man das übernehmen kann. Irgendeine, keine Ahnung, was das sein könnte.
Wenn man es gejailbragt hat, kann man es abschalten.
Sollen Sie noch eine Taste dazu erfinden? Wenn es gejailbragt ist, ja gut. Das wäre sicherlich einer der wenigen Gründe, warum man jailbragt durchführen sollte.
Na und für Core-Forwarding.
Und zwar kann man es abschalten über eine Reference-Einstellung, die auch schon unterstützt wird.
Aber man kann es so benutzen, wie es gedacht ist, damit ich erst mal sehe, wie es ist. Ja, es mag da verschiedene Gründe geben. Das werde ich auch sicherlich irgendwann tun, aber jetzt mach ich es erst mal ganz bewusst so. Ja, dann was mich richtig nervt, ist, und wo ich auch keinerlei Verständnis für habe, die Nicknames, die ich auf meinem Nokia immer vermisst habe, werden gesüngt, aber man kann generell nicht nach anderen Sachen außer den primären Namen suchen. Das ist so abenteuerlich. Ein Kontakt kann ja eine Firmenbezeichnung haben und einen Namen. Und du kannst ja im Adressbuch, lustigerweise nicht auf dem iPhone, sagen, das ist jetzt eine Firma. Und dann taucht das ja hier, hurra, auch als Firma auf. Auf meinem Nokia war das dann immer nur eine Person. Ich wusste immer nicht, welche Firma das ist. Jetzt ist es aber andersrum. Jetzt habe ich zwar die Firma, aber ich kann nicht mehr nach der Person suchen, die da drin ist, weil ich dann eben nur nach dem Firmennamen suchen kann. Also man kann immer nur nach dem primären Identifier suchen, aber nach nichts anderem. Nee, wenn ich das als Firma habe, nicht. Also wenn ich jetzt im Adressbuch einen neuen Kontakt anlege und sage, Firma XY, Dennis Ahrens. Und ich mache dieses Company-Hegchen an, dann erscheint das hier als Company-Name. Und wenn ich dann nach Dennis Ahrens suche, kommt das Ding nicht hoch.
Echt?
Ja, so ist das.
Und man kann nicht nach Nicknames suchen, und ich möchte natürlich auch nach allem anderen suchen. Ich will nach Straßen suchen, nach Orten suchen, ich will einfach nach allem suchen.
Da muss man als echt von seinen Hacker-Kumpels irgendwie immer noch deren originalen Namen so im Kopf haben. Das ist doch gar nicht so einfach.
Ich kenne einfach viele Leute nicht bei ihrem Namen. Ich kenne einfach viele Leute nur bei ihrem Nickname. Und da sitze ich da, mein Gott, wie hieß denn der nochmal?
Wie hieß der nochmal Captain Crunch?
Ob das nun jetzt das Traumbeispiel war, weiß ich nicht, aber...
Ich hab die Nummer auch nicht. Nur mal so zum Beispiel.
Nee, die wollen wir auch nicht haben.
Also das ist wirklich doof.
Aber ich hab da noch einen Tipp. Das müsste auch nochmal überprüft werden. Ich hab selber noch mal noch zu faul, das zu überprüfen. Man kann wohl ein Stück schneller suchen, oder ein bisschen eindeutiger. Wenn man zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal, 10 Leute hat, die Schmidt heißen und man sucht aber einen Thomas Schmidt, dann kann man in der Suche T. Schmidt eingeben. Und zwar so richtig ohne Leerzeichen. T, S und so weiter. Und dann findet er den sofort.
Tatsächlich.
Also man kann sozusagen die ersten beiden, also den Anfangsbuchstaben, der beiden des Nachnamens und des Vornamens eingeben und dann werden die wohl sofort gefunden. Das müsste man aber auch erstmal testen. Habe ich gelesen, sah aber zuverlässig aus. Habe ich nur nicht probiert.
Was ja auch noch mal ein Versuch wert wäre vielleicht, es gibt ja von Google diese Suchapplikation, mit der man suchen kann, logisch. Und dieses Google-Mobile-App. Und damit kann man das Netz durchsuchen. Aber damit kann man auch den eigenen Rechner durchsuchen, das eigene iPhone durchsuchen, das Adressbuch. Und das wäre mal ein Versuch wert, was da eigentlich bei rauskommt, wenn man da zum Beispiel Nachnamen schläft.
Meine Meinung kennt er ja.
Dazu kommen wir noch. Dazu kommen wir noch.
Wenn ich mein eigenes Telefon durchsuche, was kann denn daran Google evil sein?
Die schicken das hoch, Mann.
Ja, garantiert.
Aber hallo.
Nein, die schicken nicht mein Adressbuch hoch.
Nein, Adressbuch nicht, aber irgendwas schicken die hoch.
Ach, wieso sollten die das denn tun?
Das wäre ein Business, Mann.
Ist der ein Business?
Naja, was mir ganz gut gefiel, was ich sehr interessant fand, ist, dass das iPhone trotz dieser Beschränkungen mit einer Applikation im Vordergrund und wenn man wieder auf Home geht, dann ist die beendet, doch eine ganze Menge Sachen parallel gehen. Also das Ding ist schon ein Multitasking-Gerät, das merkt man.
Das ist schon richtig.
Zum Beispiel kann ich ja was im Upstore kaufen und während das Ding noch runterlädt und installiert, kann ich andere Programme benutzen. Oder auch wenn ich das Teil synke, dann sagt er zwar, springt dann hier gleich in den Bildschirm, ich synke, aber ich kann das Ding ja dann mit einem Swoosh wieder anlocken und kann andere Programme benutzen, während der Synk weitergeht.
Das ist ein Candle in dem Augenblick, muss man genau lesen.
Ah ne, doch richtig. Warte mal, ich verwechsel gerade. Was ging denn da weiter?
Das ist nämlich total bescheuert. Während er gerade so ein stundenlanges Backup macht, wenn man da versehentlich einen Anruf bekommt, dann hat man ein Problem. Ach ne, der Anruf unterbricht das Backup.
Auch das noch. Vielleicht dauert es immer acht Stunden, weil da zwischendurch jemand anruft.
Das ist wirklich eine ganz, ganz furchtbare Sache.
Oder eine SMS kriegt.
Eine SMS unterbricht es, glaube ich nicht. Die erscheint einfach bloß. Mensch Dennis, erzähl doch keinen Blödsinn. Du wirst doch eh nie angerufen. Ich doch.
Seid ihr sicher, dass der Sync immer unterbrochen wird?
Da kommt auf jeden Fall ein Cancel, wenn du den Schieber da machst. Also da bin ich mir ganz sicher.
Also wenn man den Schieber macht, kommt ein Cancel. Und wenn ein Anruf kommt, auch wird er unterbrochen.
Okay, das muss ich mir nochmal anschauen.
Also kann sein, dass erst die Annahme des Anrufs das Cancel das Ganze. Aber da bin ich mir wirklich absolut sicher.
Na ja, was überhaupt nicht funktioniert, ist diese automatische Helligkeitseinstellung.
Funktioniert bei mir super.
Habe ich auch gelesen, dass das früher besser funktioniert haben soll. Aber bei dir auf dem alten iPhone funktioniert es gut.
Ja, also es ist immer total hell, wenn ich es noch nicht eingeschaltet habe. Dann gebe ich meinen Passcode ein, dann ist es immer noch hell, und dann kommt er in das sogenannte Springboard, heißt das Ding ja, und dann wird es ein Stück dunkler, je nachdem wo ich gerade bin.
Na so ein bisschen heller, ein bisschen dunkler wird es, aber einfach nicht nennenswert.
Ich kann es richtig, ich mach das so.
Also wenn ich das nachts im Dunkeln einschalte, dann erwarte ich, dass er auf die niedrigste Helligkeitsstufe geht. Aber er geht nicht auf die niedrigste Helligkeitsstufe, sondern er geht relativ zu der von mir manuell eingestellten Helligkeitsstufe irgendwie in so ein Plus-Minus-Zehn-Prozent-Bereich hin und her. Was nie ausreichend ist. Sodass ich dann immer wieder manuell, das hat schon dazu geführt, dass ich mir die Präferenz hier unten in die Hauptseile gelegt habe, damit ich die immer schnell im Zugriff habe.
Also das fand ich nicht so toll.
Was, Stabilität habe ich ja schon gesagt, die ist mager, da muss noch dran gearbeitet werden. Diese Remote-Anwendung, die ist toll. Die ist toller als das iPod-Interface.
Das habe ich auch schon mal gehört. Was findest du daran toller?
Na, der zeigt da mehr Cover Art an und überhaupt, das ganze User-Interface ist einfach viel sagender als das von der... Na, wenn ich hier meinen Rechner fernsteuere mit Remote, dann zeigt er mir für alles Cover Art an.
Aber ein Feature fehlt noch. Dass das iPhone die Musik aus dem iTunes auch noch abspielen kann. Das wär der ultramäßige Hammer.
Wenn was?
Wenn das iPhone mit dem Remote nicht an iTunes steuern könnte, sondern das Anzeigen der Songs tut es ja schon, wenn es diesen Song auch noch holen würde und selber abspielen könnte. Dann könnte ich nachts meinen Rechner hinstellen, iTunes laufen lassen und in meinem Bett mit meinem iPhone, schön mit Kopfhörern, Musikern und kann meinen Laptop da irgendwo sonst wo stehen lassen.
Da gibt es aber dieses Simplify-Media-Programm.
Ja, hab ich noch runtergeladen.
Das ist total horrible. Erstens musste ich bei denen anmelden, zweitens sind die Programme so schlecht zusammengeschustert und gecoded. Also da ist irgendwie...
Gut, da muss halt einfach nur mal einer die APD-Protokolle...
Ja, ich hab da schon so ein bisschen losgebrannt, da bisher war ich noch zu faul, es zu ändern zu machen. Ich kann meine DAP-Dinger schon anzeigen, aber ich kann sie noch nicht abspielen.
Kannst mir mal einen Link schicken, wenn du so weit hast.
Also, guck mal. Ich hab jetzt hier mal diese Remote. Hier die Playlisten zum Beispiel. Also das ist jetzt über die Remote und da zeigt er mir dann für jede Playlist auch noch so ein Icon an. Die Smart-Playlist und so weiter. Ich kann das gleich machen, wenn ich das gleiche hier jetzt im iPod-Interface starte. Dann sieht das halt so aus. Ohne Icons und so weiter. Und Alben...
Wobei, da gibt es ja auch keine Smart-Playlist insofern.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab jetzt wahrscheinlich nur ein Album drauf. Dann zeigt er mir hier bei Alben die einzelnen Titel an.
Sofort dann und nicht mehr das Album als Zwischenschritt genauer. Da kommt man auch immer voll durcheinander. Denk mal, sind das viele Alben und dann merkst du, ach nee, das ist schon... Das ist verkürzten Schritt, aber da kommt man halt durcheinander. Aber muss man immer erstmal gucken, wo man nun ist.
Das ist vollkommen bekloppt.
Ist auf dem iPod übrigens auch so.
Ja, das ist auf dem iPod genauso.
Auf jeden Fall, da kann sich noch deutlich was verbessern. So, und jetzt kommt das Schlimmste. Der Podcast-Support auf dem iPhone ist mies. Also, es gibt da verschiedene Sachen, die mich stören. Das größte Problem ist, man kann einfach auf diesen Scheißteilen nicht ordentlich spulen. Was wirklich die Killer-Anwendung vom normalen iPod-Wheel ist, dass man da gefühlvoll vor- und zurückspulen kann. Und mit der Geschwindigkeit, wie du das Rad drehst, am Rad drehst, kannst du einfach mal eben mal ein paar Sekunden, ein paar Minuten oder halt auch mal eben schwuppt schnell eine halbe Stunde zurück.
Das stimmt, da hast du absolut recht.
Hier ist es so blöd. Erstens, er zeigt einem, anders als der iPod, auch nicht an, wo er gerade ist. Also wenn irgendwas spielt.
Doch, ganz einfach klicken.
Ich kann klicken, aber ich muss klicken. Das ist das Problem. So, jetzt läuft hier was. Und ich mach hier mal irgendwie... Sound mal aus. Dann sehe ich das hier. Und nichts zeigt an, wo er ist. Beim normalen iPod ist das genau das, was er mir anzeigt. Das heißt, ich sehe immer sofort, wo ich bin.
Schick Cover Art.
Ja, scheiß auf die Cover Art. Ich meine, da ändert sich nichts an dieser Cover Art. Ich kann diese zwei Stunden lang auf dieses Bits-und-so-Logo drauf gucken. Aber ich weiß nicht, wo ich bin. Das heißt, ich bin gezwungen, hier drauf zu klicken. Dann kommt das irgendwie an. Super klein, da oben so eine Minilinie, die noch mal so die Hälfte des vertikalen Screens, also halb so breit wie der Bildschirm an seiner schmalsten Stelle ist. Und da soll ich jetzt zwei Stunden lang Podcasts rumscrollen, dann muss ich da mit dem Finger irgendwie auf dieses Ding drauf. Ich sehe gar nicht, ob ich es jetzt richtig getroffen habe oder ob ich daneben liege. Ja, anders als bei der Tastatur gibt es hier jetzt nicht noch so ein Panel, was da rauskommt. Wenn ich auf die Tastatur drücke auf A, dann kommt da drüber A. Hier müsste ich draufklicken und da müsste da drüber die Zeit stehen, mit der ich hin und her scrubbe. Gut, zeigt er mir da vorne an, aber das ist auch wieder sehr klein. Es ist hakelig. Ja, ich kann dann auch nicht... Man verliert das leicht. Und vor allem, ich springe halt dann immer gleich so in 10-Minuten-Schritten. Mal eben 30 Sekunden zurückspulen, was einfach so ein Klassiker ist, weil ich hör irgendwas, dann rauscht die Straßenbahn an mir vorbei, hab ich's halt nicht gehört. Naja, gut. Dann hilft eh nichts mehr. Dann hilft mir auch das Spulen nicht.
Aber das ist ehrlich gesagt was, was ich auch auf den Desktop...
Das find ich beknackt...
.dass ich auch auf dem Desktoprechner vermisse. Man guckt ja auch jetzt öfter mal, also z.B. wenn man in DVD guckt, oder wenn man sich irgendwo einen Film runterlädt oder im iTunes-Store irgendwas kauft, oder weiß ja Teufel was, hat man ja genau das gleiche Problem. Man hat ja diesen, man hat einen 2-Stunden-Film und will eigentlich nur mal 7, 8 Sekunden oder 30 Sekunden zurückspulen. Aber man hat nur diesen kleinen, schmalen Balken unten drinnen, in QuickTime, in VLC, in Whatever.
In QuickTime ist ja doch Fenster breit, das ist schon okay. Aber beim neuen DVD-Player ist es doch auch unterhalb von dem DVD-Player über die gesamte Fensterbreite inzwischen mit der neuesten Version.
Aber nicht im Fullscreen-Modus. Im Fullscreen-Modus sind das, sagen wir mal, so 400, 500 Pixel. Und mal eben 7 Sekunden. Also mein Video-Recorder, mein Alter, hatte so eine Taste, mit der ich 7 Sekunden zurückspulen konnte. Das war ein relativ idealer Wert.
Aber da kann man noch mit Abfüllen und den Cursor-Tasten spulen. Vierfach, achtfach, 16fach, 32fach.
Ich will nicht, ich will einen Taste vorkamen.
Du willst aber eine Taste haben, sagen einfach springen einen definierten Amount zurück.
Genau, ich möchte, ich möchte einen Interface haben, mit dem ich für den nächsten Film gucke und wenn ich ein paar Sekunden verpasst habe, das mal eben schnell zurückspulen kann.
Also für Podcasts wäre das auf jeden Fall eine sehr sinnvolle Sache. Also auch so 10 Sekunden, einmal drauf drücken, 10 Sekunden, nochmal 10 Sekunden, sowas wäre völlig in Ordnung.
Und zwar eben nicht spulen, wie zu Tape-Zeiten.
Oder halt so ein Scrubber. Also so ein Ding, so ein User-Interface-Control, wenn ich jetzt hier in der Mitte drauf klicke.
Das finde ich übrigens eine hübsche Idee, einfach mal das Klick-Wähl auf dem iPhone nachzuimplementieren.
Nee, das würde nicht funktionieren. Weil du kannst das hier nicht fühlen auf dem Bildschirm. Da müsstest du die ganze Zeit drauf gucken, ob du wirklich deinen Finger jetzt richtig im Kreis bewegst. Nein, pass auf, ich sag dir, was helfen würde. In der Mitte, ich drücke hier drauf, wo er mir hier oben das Ding hier einblendet, will ich einfach so einen Kontroll haben, den ich in der Mitte packe. Und umso mehr ich den nach hinten schiebe, umso schneller er spult er zurück. So dass ich einfach...
Wie so ein Analog-Joystick, ja?
Genau, wie so ein Analog-Joystick. Wenn ich nur so ein ganz bisschen in die Richtung gehe, dann geht er ganz langsam zurück. Und umso mehr ich den nach links schiebe, umso schneller spult er rückwärts. Das gleiche nach vorne. Und jetzt, was ich auch noch will, ist, dass er bitte nicht springt, sondern dass er schneller abspielt, wie das QuickTime kann und auch tut. Dass ich, wenn ich das Ding auf... mach mal zweimal so schnell nach vorne, dass er die Tonhöhe anpasst und dass er einfach nicht...... macht, sondern dass er einfach schneller abspielt, aber die Tonhöhe beibehält.
Geht das? Das ging früher auf dem iPod auch, oder?
Beim iPod geht das nur bei Audiobooks. Das heißt, du musstest sozusagen eine Datei explizit mit M4... Was ist das dann?
Umbenennen.
Damit die als Audiobook erkannt wird und dann hast du ein globales Setting, wie schnell du die einstellst. Das ist auch beknackt. Das willst du einfach dynamisch haben. Okay, gut, in vordefinierten Schritten. Ich lass mich auf alles ein. Hauptsache, es gibt so ein Feature. Weil ich will Dinge schneller hören können. Ich will einen Podcast schneller hören. Ich mach das ja hier auch. Wenn ich einen Podcast komplett abhöre, dann kann ich die bis zu zweieinhalb Mal so schnell hören. Das ist jetzt extrem. Aber also anderthalb geht immer. Und das geht mit QuickTime wunderbar. Da machst du irgendwie Apple Car und dann kannst du da den Slider so und so schnell einstellen. Und dann ist es halt schneller. Und du weißt, wie...
Man ist schneller fertig.
Ja, ich meine hier unsere Gesprächsrunde, da muss man nur wirklich nicht so viel Zeit drauf verwenden.
Das kann man in achtfacher Geschwindigkeit hören.
Das will ich aber auch.
Das kriegt man immer noch alles mit.
Aber auch meinen.
Ich meine, wir könnten jetzt als Service für unsere Hörer... Informationen werden jetzt einfach viel schneller abgespielt.
Dann merkt man, dass wir gar keine Ahnung haben.
Ja, super.
Dann können wir das alles viel schneller überspielen.
Die Leute, die unseren Podcast doppelt hören, die können diese Stelle jetzt nicht mehr hören.
Na, da haben wir dann aber unsere...
Aber das Lustige ist, dass wir die Stimme trotzdem hören und tiefer wird. Meine wahrscheinlich auch.
Siehst du mal, das wäre besser, wenn der Computer das macht. Das ist nichts für Menschen. Für uns ist das anstrengend. Der Computer könnte uns Arbeit abnehmen. Und vor allem kann uns die Büchse Zeit sparen. Man kann so einen 2-Stunden-Podcast auch in einer 1,5 Stunde hören. Und dieses Gerät muss toll sein. Und es muss guten Podcast-Support haben. Und den hat es nicht. Und das war noch nicht mal alles. Ich bin echt stinkig. Apple hat eine Menge von Podcasts. Die kriegen so viel kostenlosen Content, den sie über ihr beklopptes iTunes unter das Volk bringen. Und die Leute kaufen sich diese iPods. Dann haben sie auch dafür Sorge zu tragen, dass das ordentlich abspielt. Hier ist das nächste.
Lyrics.
Geht's noch? Alles zentriert. Wenn man hier draufklickt und die Podcast-Lyrics, wo der Inhalt drin ist, dann behandeln sie das wie so ein fucking Songtext und zentrieren einfach alles. Das haben sie bei dem iPod nicht gemacht. Das kann man doch selber zentrieren, wenn man das unbedingt will. Nein, sie müssen es alles zentrieren. Das kann doch kein Mensch lesen. Warum? Kann man nur singen, wenn es zentriert ist? Das ist doch wirklich... Das verstehe ich aber nicht.
Ich glaube, wir haben gerade den Titel für die Sendung gefunden.
Aber der ist doch schon...
Die Welt ist eine Scheibe.
Singen, wenn es zentriert ist. Singen, wenn es zentriert ist. Ich würde nur singen, wenn es zentriert ist.
Wie auch immer. So, jetzt wird es noch schlimmer. Ich bin immer noch bei diesem Spulen.
Mach mal hin, iPhone wird langsam langweilig.
Wir machen so lange Musik. Ich hab mir jetzt so viel Mühe gegeben, hier wirklich ein ausführliches Review zu machen. So, das nächste. Jetzt habe ich das iPhone vertikal. Ich klicke hier in die Mitte, während was läuft, und dann kriege ich da oben meine Wo Bin Ich? Jetzt kippe ich das Ding um.
Damit fehlt das Ganze.
Jetzt gibt es dieses Interface nicht mehr. Jetzt ist alles anders. Jetzt kriege ich hier Coverflow.
Sei froh, dass du es seitwärts bedienen kannst, weil man kann ja kaum irgendwas umdrehen.
Sei froh, ich kann es nicht bedienen. Das User-Interface macht was vollkommen anderes. Das ist nicht dasselbe im Quer, sondern jetzt habe ich noch nicht meine Chance. Und weißt du, wo das ein echtes Problem ist? Wenn ich das nachts höre.
Im Bett, wo du seitwärts liegst.
Und ich seitwärts liege.
Und ich werde sowieso wahnsinnig. Weil auch wenn ich mir ein Video angucken will, ich liege quer.
Das ist aber sowieso. Was ich ja ganz lustig finde, wenn man ein Foto macht und man hat die Kamera das Foto irgendwie so gemacht, dass er das falsch rum rotiert eingespeichert hat, dann hat man das falsch rum auf dem Display. Dann denkt man, klar, drehe ich das Telefon einfach um, um es mir richtig anzugucken? Nee, das iPhone ist schlauer als ich.
Und was macht der Patch? Ja, kann man das...
Aber in Safari ist das ja auch...
Ich möchte gerne eine Geste haben zum Umdrehen. Ich möchte explizit sagen, jetzt bitte quer und dann soll er so bleiben. Generell. Ich will diese Automatik abschalten können.
Weil man will halt nachts seitwärts im Bett liegen.
Genau, man will nachts seitwärts im Bett liegen, dann halte ich das Teil halt quasi senkrecht. Ja, und dann dreht er mir halt das scheiß Video. Geht's noch? Ja, und vor allem, ich hab noch nicht mal eine Chance. Ich muss das jetzt immer so, was weiß ich, auf 20 Grad halten. Dass es gerade so eben umgeshakt ist, aber nicht wieder zurückgeht. Das ist nicht entspannend. Das ist nicht toll. Apple! Diese Leute produzieren dieses Gerät. Ich werd verrückt. Und sie benutzen es nicht im Bett.
Was haben die denn für ein Produkt-Testing?
Was machen die im Bett?
Was machen die nicht im Bett?
Im Bett!
Das ist wirklich furchtbar. Das Interface ändert sich im Landscape-Modus. Dann kann man überhaupt nicht mehr vor und zurück spulen. Und das geht nicht. Dann kann man Video-Podcasts, wo einem das Bild nicht interessiert, nicht mehr Audio-Only abhören. Das war beim iPod auch Standard.
Wenn ich über Audio-Podcasts da reingehe... Das geht beim... Wie denn? Ich hab's nur beim alten gemacht. Also bei der alten Firmware war das so, dass wenn man... Da musste man Video-Podcasts, musste man über Video angucken, weil ansonsten hatte man sie immer ohne Ton.
Genau.
Wenn man sie bei Podcasts angeguckt hat, hatte man sie ohne Ton. Hatte man sie ohne Bild. Und jetzt ist es so... Jetzt hast du immer Bild.
Das heißt, du musst das die ganze Zeit angucken und kannst nicht andere Applikationen benutzen.
Du kannst einfach... Guck mal, du kannst... Wenn du das lockst, das Ganze, in dem Modus...
Ich hab das nicht gesehen.
Ich hab jetzt hier... Ah stimmt, ich hab's gar nicht zu dir gehalten.
Okay, da spielt jetzt irgendwas ab.
Jetzt lock ich's. Geh ich in Lock-Modus. Und wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, wenn ich jetzt Pause mache...
Jetzt hört er auf, es abzuspielen, das Video.
Wenn ich jetzt... Kann ich einfach wieder auf Play drücken und jetzt macht er weiter. Ah, okay. Das ist ja dieses, wenn ich im Lock-Modus bin und dieses doppelt auf das Home-Button, dann hab ich ja die iPod-Controls und damit kann ich dann weiterspielen.
Genau, und jetzt kommt nämlich der nächste Bug, der mich auch total verrückt macht.
Dass du in dem Modus nicht spielen kannst.
Genau. Und zwar mit demselben User-Interface. Da ist Pfeile zurück mit Strich und Pfeile nach vorne mit Strich und Play in der Mitte. Genauso wie in dem iPod-Interface. Aber während ich im iPod-Interface einfach diese Pfeile gedrückt halten kann und er spult vor, Ach, das geht da nicht, das hab ich noch nie probiert. geht das in dem anderen nicht. Das heißt, vorspulen, wenn das Ding gelockt ist. Also, das weiß ich, du läufst durch die Gegend, hast das iPhone in der Tasche, hörst den Podcast und dann kommt so der Teil, ach, jetzt geht's ums Spiel, interessiert mich nicht. Dann machst du irgendwie Doppelklick, ohne das jetzt zu anlocken, holst dir halt dieses Overlay-User-Interface und da kannst du halt nur draufklicken und er springt dann zum nächsten Track, womit dein ganzer Podcast abgebrochen ist und du entriegeln ins iPod-Interface, noch mal den Podcast suchen, nein, ich hab den noch nicht gehört, reingehen, weißt du, ach, ich kann nur mit dem Kopf schippen.
Guck mal, wie man bei meiner App drehen kann. Dann kann ich mir hier ein Dokument angucken und dann kann ich sagen, hier guck doch auch mal.
Ach, du kannst das sogar komplett auf den Kopf drehen?
Das geht auch nicht durchgehend, ne?
Komplett auf den Kopf geht eigentlich so ziemlich nur irgendwo, oder?
Ich glaub nicht, ich hab noch nichts gesehen.
Dann ist auch noch das Problem, dass viele Spiele, das ist auch noch so eine Qualitätskontrolle, alle Spiele auf dem iPod, alle Games, hatten durchgehend das Feature, dass wenn ich schon was höre, wenn ich einen Podcast höre und ein Spiel starte, dass das Spiel keinen Ton ausgibt. Das ist bei allen, ich glaube, eine Ausnahme gab es.
Nee, das ist nicht bei allen Spielen so.
Bei allen, die ich hatte, war das so.
Das ist, bei tuaf.com hatten die, glaube ich, sogar mal eine Liste zusammengestellt mit Spielen, wo man die eigene Musik hören kann, während man das Spiel spielt. Das haben leider nicht alle Spiele, aber es werden...
Doch auf dem iPod hatten das alle.
Ach, auf dem iPod hatten das alle, okay.
Auf dem iPod hatten das alle. Was alle nicht richtig gemacht haben, ist, manche haben die Lautstärkeanpassungen falsch gemacht. Die haben dann einfach die Lautstärke hochgerissen und dann hörst du es auf einmal laut. Aber das war eher ein Bug. Aber alle haben sozusagen honoriert, was du gerade gehört hast. Und auf dem iPhone müssen die Anwender, die Entwickler, das alle nochmal einbauen. Es gab jetzt für verschiedene Tools Updates, wo sie das nachträglich eingebaut haben. Aber das ist so eine Sache, wo ich mir auch wünschen würde, dass Apple da eigentlich mehr den Finger drauf hat. Aber diese App Store Qualitätskontrolle scheint es nicht zu geben.
Sie scheint mehr auf andere Dinge zu achten.
Das ist ein Gerücht, ja, ich glaube auch. Die gucken eher, ob das Icon schick ist oder was weiß ich, was sie da machen. Auf jeden Fall tun sie nicht das Richtige. So, und das Schlimmste, und jetzt bin ich auch mit meinem Podcast Rand bald zu Ende. Nee, dann bin ich schon zu Ende.
Podcast Rand oder iPhone Rand?
Dass ich mit dem iPhone Podcast Support Rand. Dass ich mir hier mehrere Podcasts komplett durchgehört hatte. Und dann hab ich irgendwie gesyncht und festgestellt, dass die alle immer noch Unrails sind. Irgendjemand meinte zu mir, das läge dann da dran, dass wenn diese iPod-App irgendwie crasht oder sonst irgendwas crasht, dass das dann verloren geht.
Also das Problem hatte ich bisher noch nie.
Da ist irgendwas total fishy. Oder ist auch so, wenn ich die Liste der Podcasts, die ich zur Auswahl habe, und ich sehe auch den, der da gerade spielt, und ich bleibe in dieser Liste und dann ist der zu Ende gehört, dann verschwindet dieser blaue Punkt nicht vor meinen Augen, wie das beim iPod war, sondern...
Erst, wenn du wieder in die Liste reingehst?
Ich scroll ein bisschen hoch, und dann ist er weg. Ach, ganz fishy.
Redraw-Bug quasi.
Da geht Ihnen auf jeden Fall irgendwas in die Hose. Das ist alles nicht so de diable von AI. So, Overlay iPod Interface verhält sich anders, habe ich hier noch notiert, das habe ich gerade gesagt.
Genau, aber das mir auch gar nicht aufgeführt.
Das gefühlvolle Vor- und Zurückspulen muss einfach rein. Und Abspielgeschwindigkeit generell einstellen muss auch rein.
Aber wäre das nicht, ich weiß nicht, kann man denn per...
Zumindest für Podcasts. Bei Musik können Sie das ja meinetwegen ausschalten, aber bei Podcasts geht das nicht. So, jetzt komme ich langsam zum Ende.
Jetzt bist du langsam warm. Ach nee, zum Ende.
Ich bin auch warm. Ich habe noch einiges. Akkulaufzeit.
Naja, da hast du ja... Die ist wahrscheinlich ganz furchtbar, nehme ich mal an. Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das damit rumläuft, ist ja klar.
Also es ist zu wenig. Grundsätzlich. Also ich habe jetzt noch nicht so einen Tag gehabt, wo ich wirklich nur telefoniert und rumgerannt bin, sondern man benutzt immer irgendwas. Aber wenn man halt irgendwas benutzt...
Dafür ist ja da, dass man es benutzt.
Genau. Das ist zu wenig. Also wenn man Glück hat, hältst du einen Tag. Aber wenn man wirklich mal den Browser häufiger benutzt, dann hält das Ding nicht einen Tag. Ich glaube auch, dass Sie da noch einiges machen können.
Also da ist, glaube ich, das erste iPhone noch ein bisschen besser. Es hält länger durch. Also wenn ich Pushmail einschalte, dann ist die Batterielaufzeit auch wirklich ganz, ganz furchtbar. Aber sobald ich das abschalte, ist es eigentlich, so hältst du eineinhalb Tage bis fast zwei durch. Das ist schon relativ okay.
Also da müssen Sie auf jeden Fall nochmal ran. Ich wundere mich, dass das für so viele Leute kein Problem zu sein scheint. Also ich hab da wenig drüber gelesen. Vielleicht ist es so, wenn man erst mal die erste Begeisterung abgelegt hat und das Ding in normalen Benutzungen hat, dass es dann geht. Aber mit 3G verbrauchst du halt nochmal mehr Strom.
Wenn man es benutzt.
Wie soll ich das nicht benutzen? Das ist einfach da.
Das ist einfach zu cool.
Was soll ich machen? Soll ich es abschalten?
Ja.
Dann braust du es langsam.
Dann hast du es ja auch schon wieder benutzt, wenn du am Brausen bist. Ich meine, wenn du irgendwann das halt nur noch in der Tasche hast und nur benutzt, wenn du einen Call kriegst oder anrufst, dann hältst du es.
Ja, aber das ist auch dafür da, dass man surft.
Ja, aber dann ist es auch klar, dass es leer ist.
Nee, aber da hab ich es mir doch gekauft, dass ich hin und wieder durch surfen kann, ohne dass es Probleme gibt.
Ja, aber es ist doch klar, dass wenn er sein Telefon seit einer Woche hat, dass er natürlich für jeden Scheiß lieber erst mal an sein iPhone rennt, als an seinen Rechner und das minimiert sich.
Ich will auch nicht, dass es Röpö, Röpö, Röpö, Röpö, Röpö macht, wenn ich Podcasts aufnehme. Aber das ist noch das Minimalste.
Ja, aber das belegt sich.
Also beruhigt dich. Also mein Rekord ist viereinhalb Tage mit dem iPhone.
Echt? Das ist die ich, glaub ich, nee.
Ist mir aber auch schon... Also jetzt bin ich ja wieder so bei zwei, drei. Ich hab aber ein Newsflash, ja?
Newsflash?
Ich hab gerade hier so ein bisschen rumgespielt, weil es ist so langweilig über iPhone langsam hier. Und beim Züdi-Installer, wenn man sein iPhone gejailbragt hat, wird jetzt Werbung eingeblendet.
Was? Wo?
Ja, hier. Die machen hier so ein Mini-Icon von einem Kinofilm und sagen, wann der dann losläuft. Morgen übrigens.
Bei ihren Packages?
Ja.
Ja, das machen ein paar.
Na ja, ist aber neu. Da fragt man sich, wo die ihr Geld herkriegen und da kriegen die ihr Geld her.
Damit werden sie nicht viel verdient, fürchtig.
Also was sagt der Dennis dazu?
Das ist aber die Packager, die das machen. Das ist gar nicht Züdia selbst.
Das ist könnten, naja doch, das Package ist aber von den Züdia-Typen.
Wollen wir denn das iPhone-Thema jetzt schon komplett begraben?
Ich hab ja noch ne Menge.
Na mach mal bitte nur die ganz wichtigen dollen Sachen.
Das ist alles wichtig, das betracht mich.
Okay, dann such dir noch zwei aus.
Na, Applikationen wäre sozusagen noch mein Fokus. Weil da haben wir noch nicht so viel darüber geredet bisher, oder?
Da sind wir schon.
Nö, ihr habt nicht so viel über Programme geredet. Du hast nur immer nur erzählt, dass du immer noch nichts runtergeladen hast aus dem Upstore, weil deine Kreditkarte nicht an Start kresst. Hat sich das mittlerweile aufgebessert?
Ja, ich hab mir jetzt hier, wie heißt das, haben wir doch alle schon gehabt? Click and Buy. Click and Buy. Das hab ich auch letzten Playboy-Werbung bekommen.
Ach echt?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ja, aber ich weiß auch, warum meine Kreditkarte weg ist.
Also man muss auf jeden Fall schon ganz gut gucken, dass man so die Programme findet, die wirklich was bringen. Und gerade so im freien Markt, da ist ja wirklich eine ganze Menge Trash am Start.
Das ist unglaublich viel.
Also hier dieses, wie heißt das? Blinkenlight.
Na hier ist so Banner Free heißt das Programm.
So eine Laufschrift.
Habe ich vorhin irgendwie beim Fips in seinem Video-Podcast entdeckt. Toller Tipp. Kennt ihr den eigentlich?
Dennis stand da, gerade hast du es gesehen?
Und jetzt steht er ist.
Ach so. Na? Nein, cool steht da, Mann.
Das steht cool mit anderen Buchstaben, glaube ich.
Nein. Also für unsere Hörer, das steht cool. Aber wir haben jetzt im Club, weißt du was, wir haben im Club, eine Anzeigen-Tafel, die immer in den Flughäfen hingen, so ein bisschen älter, hat 71.000 und ein paar zerquetschte LEDs, 20 mal 56 Zeichen, wo jedes Zeichen 8 mal 8 LEDs hat.
Das ist ganz cool. Wobei noch schicker würde ich erfinden, wenn man so ein richtiges...
Wollten die auch erst kaufen, haben sich dann aber für was anderes entschieden. Gibt es aber auch bei Ebay. Also man kann jetzt riesen, schickere Anzeigen-Tafeln kaufen.
Kostet wahrscheinlich ein kleines Vermögen.
Ich dachte ihr hättet so eine Klacker-Klacker-Tafel da.
Nee, wollten sie erst, aber dann haben sie sich diese anderen geholt.
Na ja, sehr sinnvoll. Wobei ich die Klacker-Klacker-Tafeln ja auch geil finde.
Das wäre ein bisschen nervig, weil wir wollen natürlich unseren aktuellen Song, den wir gerade hören, abspielen, wenn es dabei mal Klacker-Klacker macht, weil es ein bisschen schon auf den Keks geht. Die kommen auf jeden Fall auf den Kongress, die werden dann dahingegangen. Software sind wir schon am Schreiben, wir können schon Fenster und so.
Also ich höre gerade, dass Western World meint, dass in iTunes gibt es Probleme mit dem Stream, aber in Reallplayer soll alles super laufen. Also nochmal ein Grund den Reallplayer nochmal zu installieren.
Oder iTunes zu deinstallieren. Na ich dachte wir reden mal ein bisschen über iPhone-Applikationen, die wir toll finden.
Also eine tolle iPhone-Applikation, die ich ganz großartig finde, ist leider ein bisschen teuer, ist Sinks.
Ja, habe ich mir auch geschoppt.
Das gibt es, das ist eine To-Do-Liste, kostet irgendwie 8 Euro das iTunes-Programm und geradezu fast unverschämte, ich glaube 30 oder 40 Euro, wird die Desktop-Applikation dazu kosten. Aber da kann man wunderbar seine To-Do-Listen mitführen und das synchronisiert, tada, über WLAN. Und zwar einfach nur, Sinks habe ich den ganzen Tag auf dem Mac im Hintergrund laufen. Und sobald ich Sinks starte und ich bin mit einem WLAN verbunden und er findet meine Sinks-Installation auf dem Desktop, synchronisieren die. Das finde ich ein sehr, sehr schickes Programm.
Aber es geht immer nur, wenn man das Sinks-Programm startet auf dem iPhone.
Ja, das muss man leider machen.
Das ist völlig bekloppt. Das ist überhaupt nicht automatisch. Das hat auch schon dazu geführt, dass ich das nicht benutze. Dann muss man das ja immer starten. Das ist ja eh doof. Es läuft halt nichts im Hintergrund. Von daher wäre es viel cooler, wenn Apple die Möglichkeit bieten würde, für Programme auf dem iPhone, sich mit ihren Schwesterprogrammen auf dem Desktop über iSync zu sinken.
Ja, aber die Möglichkeit gibt es nun mal nicht. Und darum ist das eigentlich die beste Möglichkeit, die ich mir im Augenblick vorstelle.
Wir müssen da echt was machen bei Apple, das gibt es nicht. Naja, dieses immer ranstecken und so, es geht mir auf den Keks. Also wenn ich nur schnell laden will, dann will ich nicht sinken. Und wenn ich sinken will, will ich zum Beispiel gerade nicht laden. Ich will nicht, ich muss nur so 5 Minuten kurz anladen.
Ja, vor allem, man will es ja schnell laden und steckt es dann ans Netzteil und nicht an den Rechner, damit das schnell lädt. Ja, zum Beispiel. Und man will aber dann trotzdem sinken. Das ist ein echtes Problem. Und dieses, okay, über W-Laden sünkt es, und das ist irgendwie schon mal ganz okay.
Also das ist die beste Sünkeln-Lösung, die ich bisher gesehen habe bei einem iPhone-App. Ich sag nicht, dass man das nicht besser machen kann, aber fürs Bessern müsste Engel halt ran.
Na gut, aber dann brauchst du halt auch ein W-Laden zu Hause, um das überhaupt zu machen, wenn du halt jetzt keine W-Laden hast.
Na ja, okay, das wird aber jeder haben.
Weiß ich nicht. Ist ja auch nochmal so ein Security-Aspekt. Keine Ahnung, also ich finde, da muss nachgebessert werden. Es muss einfach Syncing für alle Programme möglich sein.
Klar, da sind wir uns ja einig, aber solange das nun mal nicht der Fall ist, verhalte ich das für die beste Lösung. Da bin ich von SYNC relativ begeistert, sehr begeistert.
Was auch sehr schade ist, dass so was wie SYNC keine Möglichkeit hat, meinem iPhone zu sagen, also es müsste, wenn da so ein Task ist, der noch im Heute ist, warum hat da dieses Icon nicht so eine Nummer, so wie mein NetNews-Wire, also warum zeigt er nicht an, dass da noch zwei Sachen offen sind, weil so starte ich das immer nicht. Ich vergesse immer, dass da was ist. Und ein Programm, was meine To-Do-Liste pflegt, was nicht in der Lage ist, mir zu sagen, dass da noch was zu tun ist, macht denn das der Kalender eigentlich mit To-Do-Items?
Aber bei SYNC kann man das einschalten, dass er das macht.
Oh, man kann das einschalten? Wo ist denn das Setup, im Programm oder in dem?
In Einstellungen.
Ah, das ist noch dieses andere Drama, dass die Einstellungen manchmal im Programm sind und manchmal in den Einstellungen.
Na, ich glaube, die sollten eigentlich immer in den Einstellungen sein. Das macht halt wahrscheinlich bloß nicht jeder.
SYNC, Icon-Plakette. Ah, alles klar.
Ich hatte da nämlich schon was.
Was noch ein bisschen nervt, ist, dass wenn man ein Programm updated, dass man gleich von Apple nochmal eine Rechnung dafür kriegt.
Ja, man kriegt aber eine Rechnung, der drin steht, dass sie nicht kostet.
Stimmt, SYNC hat das Feature. Ich hab's bloß nicht eingeschaltet. Ich frage mich, warum das konfigurierbar ist. Das will man doch immer haben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das immer haben will, aber...
Doch. Ich meine, das ist das Ding, mit dem man To-Do-Listen macht. Das muss eine Möglichkeit geben. Wie ist das bei dem Kalender? Wenn ich im Kalender noch ein To-Do habe, macht er das dann?
Ich glaube nicht, weiß es aber nicht, um ehrlich zu sein.
Du benutzt das auch nicht, ne?
To-Dos im Kalender nutze ich gar nicht.
Ich hab hier ein To-Do und der sinkt die gar nicht. Kann das sein?
Wie gesagt, ich weiß es nicht, weil kein To-Do ist im Kalender.
Nein, der Kalender macht nur Kalender.
Der Kalender macht nur Kalender?
Wo macht denn das iPhone To-Dos?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, um ehrlich zu sein.
Gar nicht, oder was?
Ich hab für To-Dos im iPhone, hab ich Sinks. Jetzt haben wir aber langsam, guckt, so macht man Schleichwerbung. Dennis. Für Sinks. Was ist gerade mal für 7,95?
Wie hieß es?
Ich hab das in meiner Super-To-Do-Liste drinstehen.
Gleich der nächste Negativpunkt. To-Dos werden überhaupt nicht gesyncht. Das geht ja gar nicht.
Schlechter als Apple.
Unser Stream ist schon wieder weg. Es ist wirklich grauenhaft, aber an meiner Seite liegt es.
Wahrscheinlich schreist du zu laut, da kriegt er das Greenlight.
Connection-Timeout, Retrying, keine Ahnung, was hier los ist.
Was ich für ein Problem habe, ist dieses Remote. Es fällt mir gerade auf, dass das öfters mal einfach jetzt zum Beispiel findet das meine Bibliothek nicht. Meine iTunes-Bibliothek. Ich hab keine Ahnung warum. Wahrscheinlich weil ich hier auf dem iPhone über deine Xpress, also auf jeden Fall über einen anderen WLAN-Hotspot drinne bin. Und darum findet da jetzt die Bibliothek nicht.
Was heißt, er findet die nicht?
Bist du denn im selben WLAN?
Nee, ich bin nicht im selben WLAN, aber SYNX hat eben gerade problemlos... Ah, jetzt geht's doch wieder. SYNX hat eben gerade problemlos synchronisiert und Remote hat manchmal Probleme.
Ja, das ist mir auch noch ein ziemliches Rätsel, weil das ist dasselbe Shared Network. Ich hab hier zwar zwei WLANs, aber die gehen eigentlich auf dieselbe Collision Domain und von daher sollte auch Bonjour da eigentlich problemlos durchreifen.
Jetzt macht das auch gerade. Eben gerade hat er das die ganze Zeit über nicht gemacht.
Tja, so, was ist denn deine Lieblingsapplikation, Dennis?
Ich hab grad keine drauf.
Du hast keine Applikation. Du hast ein iPhone und du benutzt es nur als Telefon. Das ist ja echt unglaublich.
Und als Adressbuch. Und als Kalender. Und das ist schon voll viel. Ich hab mich gebessert. Ich hatte ein Reihen 60 CNI bis Februar. Das heißt schon was.
Aber das interessiert dich nicht. Es gibt hier wirklich hervorragende praktische Anwendungen.
Ich hab ein paar durchbohr. Dieses Simplify Media hab ich probiert. Das ist totaler Müll. Und auch so ein paar andere. Ich hab auch dieses, äh, mehr ist das Ding? Pal-Ringo. Ja, das ist irgendwie so ein Chat-Dings übernimmt, aber die haben auch ihren eigenen Service. Das sind immer so eine Proxy-Service. Das ist total für einen Arschhaut, die gleich wieder gelöscht. Und das geht überhaupt gar nicht. Und mein Lieblings-App ist immer noch das Mandelbrot-Programm. Also, das funktioniert, der macht Updates, das wird schneller und sieht schick aus.
Aber ein Mandelbrot-Programm braucht man relativ selten.
Du sitzt halt stundenlang vor deinem iPhone und guckst dir Mandelbrotmengen an.
Also, was ich ganz groß...
Und es ist umsonst, ich hab halt kein Bock. Geld? Also, ich meine, die umsonst sind wirklich schlecht. Und ich hab ein bisschen die Ahnung, dass diese Software, die irgendwie so ein paar Dollar kostet...
Nicht alle...
.dass die auch schlecht ist.
Es gibt auch gute Preise.
Und ich bin da immer ein bisschen konservativ. Ich warte, bis andere kommen und sagen, es ist total voll toll und erst dann kauf ich mir irgendwas.
Also, was ich ganz groß hab...
Sag mal deine Lieblingsprogramme, Max. Bei Dennis wird das nix.
Doch, aber Remote ist total toll. Und ich warte nur noch drauf, bis sie auch noch selber Musik abspielen können. Aber es ist total die Hammer-Applikation. Für mich ein Killer-Feature.
Okay, du benutzt Remote.
Also, was ich toll finde, aber ehrlich gesagt noch nie genutzt habe, ist Data Case. Damit kann man Daten auf dem iPhone abspeichern. Und zwar kann man auf die per WLAN zugreifen, per HTTP, per FTP, per AFP. Und ich könnte das jetzt zum Beispiel starten. Und dann würdet ihr im Finder ein zusätzliches mein iPhone irgendwie sehen und könntet da Daten drauf spielen und Daten runterholen und mir mal zwischendurch was draufspeichern.
Was für Daten?
Beliebige. Also das ist hier zum Beispiel... Das ist ein reiner Fallstore.
Wie heißt denn dein Phone? Was muss ich sehen?
Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. Ich hab das jetzt schon. So, gib ja einfach mal die IP ein und dann kannst du darauf zugreifen. Dann kann ich das bestätigen und dann geht das alles. Das ist ziemlich nett. Das dämliche ist natürlich nur, wie das Programm laufen muss, wenn man zwischendurch irgendwas anderes machen will.
Das müssen wir fixen, das geht einfach mal nicht. Diese ganzen LG-Po-Tools, die so ein bisschen, also eigentlich fast nichts machen, aber schon doch irgendwie dauerhaft laufen müssen. Das kann nicht sein, dass die nicht, das geht nicht.
Was ich dauerhaft laufen muss?
Naja, wie so ein Sync-Service zum Beispiel. Wenn du dein eigenes Sync-Service machst, musst du einfach dauerhaft laufen. Diese GPS-Tracker, den will man einfach im Hintergrund, dass der laufen kann. Die sollen das irgendwie machen, dass wenn, irgendwie, dass man einstellen kann oder vielleicht der Developer schon selbst, dass er sagen kann, mein Programm braucht definitiv nur 2% CPU-Power. Ihr könntet den total runter bremsen, macht ja nichts. Dann werden das Ding mal ein paar Sekunden lang nicht reagiert auf Interaction, weißt schon. Und ansonsten wird es abgeschossen oder gefriest oder irgendwie so. Oder dass es von mir aus nur, ja weiß nicht, dass es gestoppt wird und nur einmal die Minute CPU-Zeit bekommt. So könnte man es ja auch noch machen. Dann passiert auch nichts. Es geht ja in Unix. Aber dass es gar nicht geht, was soll denn das? Und auch Memory kann man doch begrenzen.
Ich glaube, sie werden sich das sehr genau anschauen, was sie sich da erlauben können und was nicht. Und sie gehen da erstmal sehr konservativ ran.
Ja, dann müssen sie eine bessere Lösung finden.
Bei den Verkaufszahlen können sie sich das derzeit auch leisten. Ich meine, ihr Hauptproblem ist, genug Geräte zu produzieren.
Was ich...
Na, nicht mehr, oder?
Na ja, warten wir ab, bis sie erstmal anfangen, in China und Russland zu verkaufen.
Also die... Wie viel bis Ende des Monats? Zehn Millionen 3G-Iphones verkauft?
Russland läuft schon?
Oder kommt jetzt die Tage?
Nee, ich glaube die Tage.
Also da sind nur noch mehr Provider dazugekommen. Aber China, ich sag dir, das wird teuer.
Was...
noch ein tolles Programm ist Shazam natürlich. Das ist so ein Musikerkennungsprogramm.
Das funktioniert sehr gut.
Shazam funktioniert sehr gut im Gegensatz zu Doremi, was überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Aber mal ehrlich, wie häufig hast du so das Problem, dass du Musik erkennen musst?
Alle drei Abende, wenn ich in einer Kneipe sitze.
Ist nicht dein Ernst?
Ich hab das schon hundertmal benutzt. Ich höre Musik und ich kenne keine Musik.
Hast du eine geile Sammlung? Ich bin nämlich der Musikkoordinator.
Du bist der Musikkoordinator. Hört ihr jetzt jemand von der Musikindustrie? Hört ihr gut zu hören.
Und Shazam, welcher Song war das? Nee, aber ich arbeite ja nicht nur für die MPAA, sondern ich arbeite natürlich auch für die REAA.
Und darum kannst du das jetzt auch machen. Also Shazam ist wirklich ein ganz tolles Programm, um Musik zu erkennen. Ist auch manchmal ein tolles Programm. Manchmal sitzt man ja in einer Kneipe und weiß gar nicht, hey, das hab ich zu Hause irgendwo, aber ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es heißt. Würde ich gerne mal wieder hören, das Album. Hält man Shazam kurz hin. Funktioniert auch mit Umgebungsgeräuschen. Wirklich hab ich es bisher nur bei wirklich sehr kuriosen Sachen gehabt, dass es das Musik nicht erkannt hätte. Und das kostet noch nicht mal was für uns.
Noch irgendwelche Empfehlungen?
Pal-Ringo? Natürlich.
Das hab ich ja schon schlecht gemacht gerade.
Das ist super. Das ist total scheiße. Was?
Du gibst irgendwie dein Passwort an einen anderen Server ab, oder was? Seh ich dein Ernst?
Evernote ist ein Programm, das gibt's auch auf dem Mac. Wird, synchronisiert sich auch hervorragend, erlängst da wirklich übers Web.
Da muss man so einen Account erstmal machen, ne?
Da braucht man so einen Account für.
Deswegen wird das noch nicht ausprobiert.
Damit kann man, leider ist die Kamera im iPhone natürlich dafür viel zu schlecht. Aber man kann Dokumente abfotografieren und kann auch Screenshots machen auf dem Mac. Und die werden dann synchronisiert mit dem Server und werden da einer Handschriftenerkennung unterzogen. Also eine OCR-Software haben die am Laufen, die relativ gut funktioniert und kann damit dann fotografierte, gescannte, gefaxte, gescreenshotete Bilder schön verpacken.
Aber die Kamera im iPhone ist doch überhaupt nicht für Nahbetrieb gemacht. Die ist doch so ab einem halben Meter in die Unendlichkeit oder so.
Dann natürlich hier noch das Fahrinfo, das hatten wir ja schon mal. Dieses, mit dem ich in Berlin Fahrpläne rauskriege.
Das wollte ich auch erwähnen, das Teil. Das ist wirklich der Knaller und vor allem mit GPS ist das der Knaller.
Also es ist auch ohne GPS ziemlich gut. Also es funktioniert auch mit der Zelleninfo. Genau.
Das haben wir schon erwähnt. Aber kann man ruhig noch mal sagen. Also das Ding guckt halt, wo bist du und schlägt einem dann gleich die Haltestelle in der Umgebung vor. Wäre natürlich super, wenn er auch eine Karte noch mit anzeigen könnte.
Das geht aber nicht, weil die Programme noch nicht auf die AP zugreifen können vernünftig. Oder gar nicht auf die Google Maps ab.
Nicht Google Maps oder auf die Inter. Also eigentlich müssten sie so Maps anbieten, zum Einblenden für Programme, so wie sie WebKit haben. Ja, das kann man als WebKit nehmen.
Du könntest theoretisch über WebKit wahrscheinlich irgendwie aus dem Daten nachladen. Ich hab das mal darüber, was mit jemandem darüber gesprochen. Das ist gar nicht das Problem, dass es dafür keine AP gibt. Sondern Google hat einfach nicht die Rechte für die Karten, die weiterzugeben, so tief, dass die von Drittanbietern Programme genutzt werden dürfen.
Das machen sie doch auf den ganzen Webseiten heutzutage.
Ich nehme an, da haben sie irgendwie einen Vertragsdinschip-Bumpel, dass das Web ist. Und dass es offiziell kein Programm ist.
Kannst du es ja bei Web machen.
Funktioniert. Google Maps in Safari, glaube ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall ist das wohl leider gar keine...
Was? Google Maps in Safari? Natürlich funktioniert das in Safari.
In Safari auf dem iPhone.
Na warum soll das denn nicht funktionieren?
Na wenn du einen Google Maps Link aufmachst in Safari auf dem iPhone, dann schaltet er um auf die Maps-Applikation.
Okay, es gibt da so ein komisches Hijacking von dem iPhone.
Genau. Also man könnte...
Stimmt, das ist doof.
Also man könnte wahrscheinlich hier mit Open Maps oder wie sie alle heißen arbeiten, Open Street Maps, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, aber es gibt von Apple keine offizielle Art wie dafür.
Das muss auf jeden Fall noch gelöst werden, aber sie könnten auch was anderes machen bei dem Fahrinfo, weil sie bieten ja selber als Karte nur den... diesen abstrakten Fahrplan an, was natürlich ein bisschen bekloppt ist. Also das hilft nun wirklich gar nichts, da auf Karte zu drücken und dann kriegst du da, weiß auch noch nicht mal, wo du bist. Sie brauchen ja sozusagen nur die Linienführung abstrakt in ihrer tatsächlichen Ausprägung mit GPS-Koordinaten. Also sie müssen sozusagen nur mal die richtigen Linien tracen. Das kann man machen, da setzt man sich einfach in eine Straßenbahn und fährt das Ding mit GPS-Trekker ab. Dann hat man das und merkt sich, wo die Haltestellen sind und diese Informationen kann man ja schnell sammeln. Also wir sollten mal mit diesem Entwickler in Verbindung treten. Finde ich. Wer ist denn das überhaupt? Wer macht denn das?
Über eine Ecke kenne ich den.
Also wenn du zuhörst, melde dich.
Bitte melde dich. Was ich noch viel für wichtig halte, ich finde das User-Interface von dem Programm leider alles andere als perfekt.
Ich finde es okay.
Ich habe mich dran gewöhnt.
Was ist denn dein Haupt-Kritikpunkt?
Ach guck mal, es gibt sogar einen Netzplan, den habe ich bisher noch gar nicht gesehen.
Das ist der abstrakte Netzplan, wo du nicht wirklich eine GPS-Koordinate...
Aber dass er den überhaupt nutzen kann...
Das ist ja nur ein logischer Plan und kein geografischer.
Genau, und man bräuchte halt so einen richtigen Netzplan. Was sowieso mal ganz gut wäre, weil bei der BVG gibt es einfach keine... Es gibt kein Dokument, wo einfach mal alle Linien drin sind. Das wird die zum Mäuse melken.
Ja, doch die ganz Großen in der U-Bahn.
Ja, aber entweder ist da S-Bahn und U-Bahn drauf.
Ja, und keine Busse.
Doch, die sind auch drauf.
Nein, aber die ganz Großen gedruckten, diese riesen...
Ach so, die Teile.
Wo aber richtig so geografisch drauf ist.
Ja, aber das ist Copyright bei diesem komischen Verlag, der die macht.
Die kann man auch kaufen.
Ja, genau. Kaufen kannst du die.
Digitalisieren, kacheln und rennen ins iPhone.
Das ist, glaube ich, nicht die Nutzungsbedingung, die erlaubt ist.
Ist doch egal. Ich meine, warum nicht einfach mit GPS-Tracker die Linien sammeln?
Ob es mir denen erklärt hat, was ein Telefon ist und dann ein iPhone, bis dahin...
Ein iPhone kennt jeder.
Ein iPhone kennt jeder. Schön wär's.
Witzige Applikation, die ich noch finde.
Warte mal, Farinfo heißt das Teil. Das ist ein blöder Name übrigens. Das sollte irgendwie Farplan Berlin oder so sein.
Galcon finde ich noch ganz großartig.
Warte mal, ich wollte jetzt mal kurz gucken, wer das ist. Ich bin schon dabei.
Und dabei kannst du mich mal zuhören. MetaQuark, ach den kennt man noch sogar.
Wer ist denn das?
Ich glaube, der ist ein großer... Der ist, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, ist der Sprengläser regelmäßiger.
Da gibt's keine Webseite.
Und der macht... Nee, der macht Upfresh, genau.
metaquark.de Ja, ach da kommt Upfresh her.
Und der hat hier so dreieinhalb Programme.
Upfresh ist auch ein deutsches Produkt, ich bin überrascht. Okay, alles klar. Beautiful Mac Software. Na dann wissen wir ja mal, wo wir anklopfen. Weil das Ding ist wirklich, das ist eine totale Killer-Applikation mit diesem U-Bahn. Also man kann einfach endlich... Funktioniert das so, wie man sich das immer vorgestellt hat. Vorhin, ich wollte los, bin heute mit der U-Bahn gefahren, beziehungsweise ich musste alle beteiligten Verkehrssysteme benutzen. Straßenbahn, U-Bahn, S-Bahn. Und ich konnte einfach sagen, ich will jetzt losfahren, nahegelegene Haltestellen. Zack, konnte hier die nächste Haltestelle, die ich benutze, einfach so anklicken, wo ich sonst immer 40 Zeichen eintippen muss bei www.bvg.de und wahnsinnig werde.
Und immer nur gerade die, die man auch kennt.
Und selbst wenn man es richtig eintippt, fragt er mich dann nach dem ersten Klick nochmal, meinst du wirklich die?
S-Bahn, oben, unten oder die Haltestelle? Oranienburgatur, welches meinst du von den folgenden 10?
Genau, zum Mäuse melken, wahnsinnig werden, wirklich diese Jungs von der BVG, es geht gar nicht. Und hier geht das einfach. Und dann in 0, nichts und wo willst du hin? Da drei Buchstaben eingegeben, da hatte ich schon den Vorschlag, zack, boom, fertig, grafische Darstellungen vor allem. Diese grafische Darstellung ist super. Und er merkt sich das auch, ich kann das Programm beenden und wieder starten und hab das einfach so lange, bis ich es explizit lösche, ja.
Die grafische Darstellung finde ich nur so halb super, aber wenn man drauf tippt, kriegt man auch eine genaue Information. Genau, und dann hab ich ewig lang nicht kapiert, aber...
Genau, und dann hat man das aber auch wirklich genauso, wie man das haben will, hier mit Logos und Icons und Pipapo. Also es ist wirklich toll. Ich wünschte, dass jede Stadt in Deutschland das hätte. Gibt's leider nur für Berlin. Tut mir leid, alle. Nicht Berlin Einwohner.
Zieht endlich um.
Die ihr zuhört. Immer noch. Obwohl wir schon...
Oh Gott, sind wir so lange dabei.
Richtig lange Aufnehmen. Das wird ein langer Podcast heute.
Ich glaub, das wird ein langer Podcast. So viele Programme hab ich jetzt aber gar nicht mehr. Also Evernote ist auf jeden Fall...
Oh nee, komm nicht das.
Nicht so alber Kram.
Super alber Kram.
Nee, richtig sinnvolles Zeug.
Also ich erzähl's nochmal, was Ipint ist. Das ist so ein kleines Werbeprogramm. Und da kann man so Pseudowier trinken mit.
Das ist ganz üblich.
Ich find das üblich. Genau, das probiert man einmal aus. Und dann benutzt man das nie wieder.
Und dann kann man, wenn man betrunken in der Kneipe... Doch, das kann man, doch, das kann man schon.
Wenn man betrunken... Sagen wir Max, wie viele Tage der Woche sitzt du eigentlich betrunken in der Kneipe?
Das hängt darauf...
Du machst das nur, damit du deinen iPhone problemlos benutzen kannst und dich nicht mehr vertippst.
Also mein Schnellsucher-Tipp von Freunden, der funktioniert überhaupt gar nicht.
Welcher?
Der mit dem T...
Einen Staben von Vordernamen angeben und dann den restlichen Damen das... Da hat er noch Scheiß erzählt. Ich nehme alles zurück.
Da warst du betrunken.
Nee, ich nicht. Magst du übrigens. Aber...
Gut.
Also ich glaube, du warst vorhin auch...
Bist du durch? Darf ich mal was vorschlagen?
Ja klar, du hast doch gefragt, wer...
Du darfst jetzt auch mal was sagen.
Ja, ich dachte, ich halte mal ein bisschen das Maul.
Das ist Prinz...
Prinzipiell durchaus zu begrüßen, aber heute darf ich, wolltest du sagen. Na gut.
Wenn wir Podcast machen, darfst du.
Also was benutze ich häufig? In diesen anderthalb Wochen, die ich jetzt mal ein iPhone benutze. Ich benutze Twitterriffig. Viel und gerne.
Find ich nicht.
Zum Twittern? Will ich Twitter kaufen?
Da kannste aber auch mal meinen Twitter-Klang nutzen.
Das seh ich doch, hier ist gar nichts los bei dir.
So, so. Also heute hab ich bestimmt schon irgendwie 10 Tweets rausgehauen.
Ja, aber ich hab auch manchmal das Gefühl, das Ding funktioniert nicht so richtig. Kann das sein?
Nee, guck mal.
Ich meine, du kannst eine Liste gucken. Hier ist von Timme, ist finished und ich hab den drin, da ist er. Der letzte ist, woher Google Chrome has crashed, restart now. Das ist der letzte, den ich von dir hab.
Ist es der letzte?
Ja, geh doch einfach mal auf Twitter.
Ich hab hier Twitter, 10 Stunden ago. Oder ist es morgens um 10?
Ja, das ist ja auch der letzte.
Aber er holt sich immer...
Ja, ok, dann sind da noch zwei und drei. Na ok, da sind noch ein paar. Dann passiert wieder stundenlang nix.
Da hast du geschlafen, du Drecksau.
Entschuldigung, ich hab halt auch mal was getan. Ich war halt mal produktiv.
Dann gibt's Leute, die beschweren sich, dass sie mir wohl Privatnachrichten schicken und da würde nichts ankommen.
Twitter hatten wir schon mal durch. Das ist verbesserungswürdig, das wissen wir alle. Also Twitter-Refik, ich kann's empfehlen. Ich weiß, manche Leute benutzen gerne Twinkle. Das hab ich noch nicht so ausprobiert. Das hat aber nette Features mit dieser Lokalisierung.
Vielleicht followst du den einfach nicht.
Aber Twitter ist mir jetzt erstmal auch nicht so wichtig. Was ich durchgehend benutze, ist NetNewsWire auf dem iPhone. Das ist eine ganz hervorragende Ergänzung. Super, super, super. Da kann man echt entspannt News lesen.
Ich bin echt ein großer Freund von NetNewsWire, aber es synchronisiert einfach viel zu lange. Und ich hab wunderbar was gehört über diesen, wenn ich den Google-Reader benutzen würde, hätte ich das schon gehört. Ich weiß leider nicht, wie es heißt.
Das synchronisiert zu lange?
Das dauert eine ganze Weile, bis das mit Synchronisieren fertig ist.
Über den NewsGator-Account?
Über den NewsGator-Account.
Das geht doch ratzefatze. Vor allem, du musst ja auf nichts warten, du kannst ja hier schon lesen, während er noch im Hintergrund rumsyncht.
Ich hab's vor 5 Sekunden gestartet, SYNKE, SYNKE, SYNKE, SYNKE, SYNKE, SYNKE, SYNKE, SYNKE, SYNKING.
Ich find's langsam langweilig.
Na mach doch nix. Lass es doch SYNKEN.
Dann geht doch.
Was findest du langweilig? Dass wir über iPhone reden.
Nein, aber iPhone-Apps. Stundenlang.
Wiederholt immer wieder.
Na wieso? Ich wiederhol mich nicht.
Und die Leute können nicht mal was sehen.
So, was find ich noch super? Ich finde Circulator ganz praktisch. Man möchte häufiger sich was leihen oder verleihen, um das auch häufiger benutzen zu können. Und ich geh jetzt wirklich nicht hier durch jedes Programm, was ich installiert habe. Oh, so einiges.
100?
Keine Ahnung, aber ich hab hier so... 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Das waren schon ein paar Seiten, als ich das gerade kurz hatte. Das ist auch schon ganz schwer.
Ich hab hier so 6 Seiten.
Wie viel passt drauf auf eine Seite?
Die nicht alle ganz voll sind. Also vielleicht 5 Seiten. Und davon ist eine Seite...
16 gehen auf eine Seite.
Das sind Webseiten-Bookmarks.
16 mal 5 sind 80.
Das sind auch Sachen, die ich ausprobiere. Da sind ja auch serienmäßig schon einige installiert. Ich wollte jetzt nur kurz auf die Sachen, die mich wirklich ziehen, die ich praktisch finde. Und da muss ich jetzt noch erwähnen, den Tuner, mit dem man einfach Radio hören kann. Das heißt, wenn so ein Livestream ist und man hat nur iPhone, dann geht das. Da kann man irgendwie einen URL eingeben, merkt er sich dann auch. Da hat man dann irgendwie einen Bookmark und dann kann man einfach...
Kann man das irgendwo mit synchronisieren oder sowas? Weil diese URLs einzutippen, das ist immer ganz, ganz furchtbar. Gerade auf dem iPhone, oder?
Na ja, das macht man halt einmal.
Und dann hast du's.
Hab da irgendwie meinen Deutschlandfunk drin und könnte auch die URL jetzt vom Mobile Max Live-Podcaster eintragen und dann machst du das halt einmal.
Leiterleben, wie es zusammenbricht.
Ja, okay.
Finde ich jetzt nicht so schlimm. Dann hab ich mir noch ein paar Konverter installiert. Die benutze ich noch nicht so häufig, aber das wird sich bald erinnern. Konverter halt.
Achso, das ist so Meter in Inch und Beherrung.
Currency, genau, Inch und solche Problematiken. Dann hab ich mir noch ein paar Spiele ausprobiert, um einfach mal zu gucken, wie das so ist, mit dem iPhone zu spielen. Und naja, wer hätte es gedacht? Also was ich am geilsten finde bisher, was einem wirklich ein bisschen gefangen hält, aber das ist natürlich jeder andere, ist dieses Newtonica. Ja, wurde im iPhone-Block empfohlen. Und das ist einfach bemerkenswert simpel. Das lädt hier gerade ganz fleißig. Und das hat auch ziemlich abgefahrenen Sound hier. Du hast hier einfach so eine Kugel in der Mitte, und dann kommen immer so Teile angeflogen, die sind entweder rot oder blau, und dann musst du die Kugel bewegen. Sieht ein bisschen amerikanisch aus, weil das hier alles so blau, weiß, rot und mit Sternchen und so. Und du musst halt quasi diese Kugel in der Mitte immer so drehen, dass diese Partikel, die da angeflogen kommen, auf die entsprechende Farbe aufschlagen, sonst ballern sie halt hier irgendwie dagegen. Und das geht am Anfang noch schön langsam, und danach kommt dann halt immer mehr, und dann wirst du echt panisch. Und irgendwann hast du es dann halt auch verkackt. Und dann fliegen sie irgendwie nicht mehr richtig. Aber siehst du, die spiegeln sich vorher in dieser Kugel so ein bisschen, und das ist alles sehr fein. Also das ist so eine richtig schöne Zeitvertreibnummer. Wenn man an der Bushaltestelle steht und mal so ein bisschen seinen Hirn aufschalten möchte.
Was ich ganz hübsch finde, ist Galcon heißt das. Das ist so ein, kostet auch ein bisschen was, so ein Spiel, wo man fremde Planeten erobern muss. Man muss dann einfach, man hat einen Gegner, und gegen den, der probiert dann einen fertig zu machen, indem er Raumschiffe hinschickt, und man muss Planeten erobern. Unglaublich simples Spielprinzip, und macht tierischen Spaß. Hab ich mal einen kompletten Abend durchgespielt mit der Mac-Demo-Version, die es auch gibt. Die gibt es für Windows und für Linux und für Mac. Aber es gibt auch eine sehr schöne iPhone-Version, die ich mir jetzt geleistet hab, bevor ich nach Tschechien gefahren bin und nicht einmal gespielt habe natürlich. Aber ich hab's gestern in der S-Bahn gespielt, macht echt Laune. Schönes Spiel, ein Spiel ist immer relativ kurz, dauert so vielleicht zwei, drei Minuten, wenn es hochkommt. Also auch schön, um es in der S-Bahn zu spielen. Ach und Chopper hab ich mir gekauft. Das ist so ein Spiel, wo man so einen Hubschrauber fliegen kann.
Du schießt gerne, ja?
Ich schieß gerne.
Du bist so ein bisschen militaristisch. Auch wenn du nicht gerade betrunken in der Kneipe sitzt.
Manchmal auch beides. Am besten betrunken schießen.
Ich denke wir können das iPhone-Thema jetzt abschließen. Es sei denn, Dennis möchte noch was dazu beitragen.
Warte mal, warte mal. Ich mach jetzt mal eine super Überleitung. Aber guck mal, hier bei dem iPhone der ersten Generation am Rand, das ist doch Chrome, oder?
Da fällt mir was ein, wo du das grad sagst. Siehst du?
Ja!
Ist da nicht grad ein neuer Browser rausgekommen?
Stimmt, Tim. Jetzt wo du es sagst...
Echt?
Den hab ich immer vorbereitet.
Dennis, hast du davon schon gehört?
Hab ich.
Wie hieß die Firma noch gleich?
Die waren noch nett, oder?
Sind die eigentlich evil?
Auf jeden Fall.
Echt?
Ich kann ja auch schon gleich den Grund nennen. Also es geht ja um den Chrome-Webbrowser von Google. Genau. Und die sind deswegen evil, weil was wird's für diesen Browser nie geben?
Adblocking.
Die Company verdient ihr Geld mit Ads. Da wird's keinen Adblocker für geben.
Das kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen, dass es das sehr wohl geben wird, weil das Ding ist einfach mal unter BSD-Lizenz komplett in Open Source. Liegt das vor und ist einfach derzeit der freiste Browser, den es gibt. Es gibt nichts Freieres.
Firefox ist dagegen eingeschlossen als System.
Wieso?
Weil Firefox ist GPL.
Wir sind jetzt übrigens, kurze Bemerkungen der Redaktion für unsere Zuhörer, wir sind jetzt bei der Diskussion.
Wir lachen für die Leute, die noch nicht früher zugehört haben. Es gab da mal eine Ausgabe, da haben wir uns etwas zu lange über das Thema unterhalten. Aber den Streit bräuchten wir jetzt nicht wieder vom Zaun. Passen wir mal kurz die Fakten zusammen. Also, Google hat einen neuen Browser rausgebracht. Er ist komplett Open Source. Die Open Source Version heißt Chromium. Also Chromium ist sozusagen der Code. Chrome ist der kompilte, von Google in Binary Form, zunächst mal nur für Windows, distributierte Browser. Das ist so ein bisschen wie bei Firefox, dass irgendwie nur ein Bild von Mozilla da Firefox heißen und wenn...
Und nur das Icon haben, das Firefox Icon, das ist nämlich nicht Open Source.
Genau, deswegen heißt er, wie heißt er da irgendwie?
Eiswiesel, glaube ich.
Eiswiesel, genau. Das ist eine ähnliche Konstruktion, aber immerhin, der Google-Browser kommt mit einigen neuen interessanten Ideen und vor allem, er kommt halt in BSD-Lizenz und das ist das erste Mal, was ich weiß, dass ein Browser vollständig, der auch cross-Plattform sein soll, BSD-Lizenz hat, oder?
Also ich hab da noch nie drauf geachtet, insofern...
Was hat denn das WebKit nochmal? Ach so, das WebKit ist ja nur eine Engine und kein Browser.
Genau. Und Chrome benutzt WebKit, so wie sie das ja auch schon bei Android eingesetzt haben. Das überrascht jetzt nicht sehr, dass sie da auf die gleiche Engine setzen.
Und die Gründe sind auch, wie die Jungs gesagt haben, weil sie der sehr pflegbare Code ist, also die Developer konnten den sehr schnell einbauen, umsetzen und erweitern.
Und sie haben es ja auch schon bei Android eingesetzt.
Kann gut sein, dass WebKit demnächst sozusagen seinen Status als zweitmeist benutzte Engine, dass es leihern darf.
Langsam wird es für die Mozilla. Einbüßt?
Welchen Platz haben sie denn? Drei.
Hinter IE und Firefox.
Firefox ist derzeit so bei 17% oder so. Und Safari ist, glaube ich, so bei 4-5. Und das iPhone macht nochmal so ein halbes Prozent aus. Und so summiert sich das irgendwie alles.
Das ist mittlerweile eigentlich so, das ist mittlerweile eine ganze Menge geworden, was da so auf WebKit aufsitzt.
Alles setzt auf WebKit aus, außer dem Internet Explorer und Firefox.
Na und Opera.
Und Opera.
Klar.
Die aber auch in der Ferne liefen sind und auch laufen werden.
Aber es ist ja immer ganz spannend so bei den ganzen Plattformen. Also zum Beispiel, finde ich das ja, also iPhone, klar, setzt auf WebKit auf. Symbian setzt auch auf WebKit auf mittlerweile. Android auch. Das heißt eigentlich alle...
OpenMoco auch.
OpenMoco auch. Gut, hört euch jetzt nicht als super wichtige Plattform. Aber alle wichtigen Plattformen außer Windows Mobile setzen eigentlich auf WebKit.
Richtig.
RIM auch nicht. Also hier BlackBerry, wobei BlackBerry, kann man das als Web Engine bezeichnen, was die da drin haben.
Ja, aber das benutzt ja auch niemand.
Das kann man ja zum Surfen einfach nicht benutzen. Da ist WebKit unglaublich stark. Auf den Spielkonsolen sieht es natürlich noch ein bisschen anders aus. Ich glaube, die PS3 hat aber auch WebKit, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Das weiß ich nicht, die Wii benutzt Opera.
Die Wii benutzt Opera und genau, das stimmt. Und WebKit macht sich offensichtlich relativ gut.
Meiner Meinung nach wird WebKit der Goldstandard. Also ich meine das iPhone...
Das scheint, hat eine gute Chance dahin auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das iPhone ist jetzt bei 0,5 Prozent. Ich meine, Ende des Jahres bei so viel verkauften iPhones ist davon auszugehen, dass mehr Leute mit dem iPhone ins Web gehen als mit Linux.
Ist nicht schon so?
Nee, ist noch nicht so.
Aber das ist so. Linux hat halt irgendwie so 1, irgendwas Prozent und das iPhone hat peaked jetzt so auf knapp unter 0,5.
Ich finde schon.
Na ja, es hat halt nicht die Verbreitung auf dem Desktop. Von daher, woher soll es kommen?
Ich hab grad gelesen, F-Stream ist ein Programm, mit dem man streamen kann live und was man hauseband hat.
Auch jetzt nicht immer wieder was anderes reinschmeißen. Dem kann doch keiner folgen. Merkt ihr das und bringt das später nochmal an. WebKit ist jetzt, was würd ich jetzt sagen? Ja, wird der Goldstandard und vor allem, es wird halt auch wirklich zahlenmäßig weiter zulegen. Und dieser Google Chrome, ich meine, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, welche Verbreitung er finden wird, aber ich glaube, das könnte ganz schön knallen. Weil dadurch, dass es halt auch ein Open Source Ding ist, ist das natürlich auch für viele Distributionen sehr interessant. Wobei er wird erstmal nur auf x86 laufen.
Wenn der Source komplett frei ist, dann kannst du eigentlich nicht so lange dauern, bis für andere Plattformen eine ordentliche Version rauskommt.
Doch, kann es und wird es auch. Und zwar aus folgendem Grund. Eines der Features, eines der wichtigsten Features bei Google Chrome und bei Chromium ist, dass jeder Tab in einem eigenen Prozess läuft. Und nicht nur das, sondern sie haben auch noch eine selbstgestrickte VM-artige Prozessmanagement-Geschichte da reingebaut, so eine Art Jail. Sie nennen es halt eine Sandbox. Das bedeutet, dass der Code da drin nur auf CPU und Memory zugreifen kann, aber sonst keine Systemressourcen, also nicht direkt aufs Fallsystem zugreifen kann usw. Sondern das geht dann alles indirekt über so einen Management-Prozess.
Und das wäre auf anderen Plattformen nicht möglich?
Das ist Highly X86 spezifisch und das hält sie derzeit sogar davon ab, auf 64-Bits zu gehen, ohne weiteres. Weil das eben alles für 32-Bit-X86 gemacht ist. Ich hab mir heute mal die FAQ durchgelesen, auf Google zu dem Thema. Und sie gehen davon aus, dass sie noch eine ganze Weile lang brauchen werden, bis sie das überhaupt auf X86-64-Bit hinkriegen, weil sie auch auf vielen Subsystemabhängigkeiten haben, die alle auch erstmal... Wir haben noch mal diesen Schritt noch machen müssen. Das ist also nicht von heute auf morgen zu machen. Und von daher sind sie sehr prozessorabhängig. Also nur weil es Open Source ist, wirst du das also noch nicht bald auf anderen Plattformen sehen. Dazu kommt, dass ihr Modell auch sehr an Windows angepasst ist. Also sie sprechen da von einem Hardcoding auf die Gegebenheiten des OS und Prozessor in der Kombination, sodass auch ihre Version für Macintosh und Linux noch eine Weile dauern wird. Sie meinen, man sollte mit Monaten rechnen und nicht mit Tagen. Also wir werden eine Mac-Version von dem Chrome irgendwann sehen, aber das kann gut sein, dass das in diesem Jahr nicht mehr stattfindet.
Aber es ist trotzdem ein extrem fälliger Schritt, wie ich finde. Also ich finde diesen Ansatz, den Google erfährt, extrem interessant und extrem fällig, weil wir leben ja immer mehr, der Web-Browser wird ja immer mehr zum Programm.
Welchen Ansatz meinst du denn jetzt?
Dieser Ansatz, dass jeder Tab sein eigener Prozess ist.
Na gut, das ist ein reines Security-Feature.
Das ist kein reines Security-Feature, dadurch kann ich natürlich auch, kann ich schön Prozesse auf mehrere Prozessoren verteilen. Das könnte man auch mit Thread-Szenen kriegen, aber so wie es im Augenblick ist, dass zum Beispiel ein JavaScript in einem Tab im Wesentlichen einen kompletten Rechner blockieren kann, wenn es dich dämlich anstellt, dein gesamten Browser.
Wieso? Das ist eine Frage, ob man ordentlich ist. Sie müssen auch Multistrading machen, weil sonst können Sie auf mehreren Cores nicht die Performance nutzen. Multistrading brauchen Sie eh, um die Performance des Rechners zu realisieren. Ein Prozess ist ja nur ein Abschluss, entkoppelt sozusagen die Subsysteme auch über den Speicher. Was Sie ja versuchen, mit dieser Sandbox zu erreichen.
Was passiert, wenn mir ein Thread abstürzt? Dann stürzt das gesamte Programm mit, oder? Also ich meine, der Thread kann ja auf den Speicher des gesamten Programms zugreifen. Sicher.
Nein, Browser hat nicht abzustürzen.
Ja, aber das musst du irgendwie erreichen.
Aber das haben wir doch geschrieben, dass wir das entkoppelt haben, oder nicht?
Aber es gibt auch schon Berichte, wo der ganze Chrome abdügelt. Also ein Fehler im Programm ist ein Fehler im Programm.
Natürlich.
Sie schränken es ein, gar keine Frage. Sie schränken es ein, aber grundsätzlich sollte man sowieso seinen Code so schreiben, dass er nicht abstürzt?
Natürlich sollte man das so schreiben, aber ich meine, es ist relativ unrealistisch davon auszugehen, dass ein Browser niemals abstürzt. Und insbesondere, wenn man zum Beispiel Net Newswire nutzt, wo sich ja, ah Gott, jetzt zeige ich den Namen von dem Autor und schon wieder vergessen ist das in dem Fall, Brad Simmons. Brad Simmons irgendwann mal schön darüber aufgeregt hat, dass er ständig Fehlerberichte kriegt für Net Newswire und dann nur festzustellen, dass es eigentlich mal wieder Flash war, was abgestürzt ist. Klar. Innerhalb von Net Newswire und damit die gesamten Browser, das gesamte Net Newswire an die Knie gerissen hat. Dafür kann Brad Simmons aber natürlich nichts.
Das ist richtig.
Und wenn sowas dann als eigener Prozess läuft, stürzt Flash ab. Wir wüssten, hey, Flash, blöde Sau, stürzt nicht ab, könnten uns ein Adobe wenden, würden nicht über Net Newswire meckern. Das ist schon durchaus ein ganz großer Vorteil.
Insbesondere auf die Plugins bezogen könnte das ein interessanter Ansatz sein. Und ich finde es auch eine spannende Sache, du hast ja gesagt, das hätte auch was mit Performance zu tun und ich sag dir, das ist für die Sicherheit relevant, aber das ist nicht für die Performance an sich erst mal relevant.
Ja, aber im Augenblick wird es offensichtlich noch nicht wirklich durchgehend getan. Also ich meine, man hat ja das Problem, dass wenn zum Beispiel ein YouTube-Video in einem Tab abspielt und man zu viele Seiten offen hat, dass das YouTube-Video anfängt zu stottern, obwohl der Prozessor eigentlich noch nicht wirklich so weit ausgelastet ist. Wenn man das vernünftig macht, mit mehr Prozessoren im Idealfall oder eben in der kleinen Multi-Thread sollte es da nicht hakeln.
Es ist so ein ganz billiges Multi-Threading, was sie sich damit erkaufen. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Vorteil. Du hast irgendwie acht Tabs und du hast auf jeden Fall schon mal acht Threads auf jeden Fall am Start.
Genau.
Klar, aber sie müssen halt auch ihr Sicherheitsmodell, sie müssen da irgendwie zwischen den Prozessen hin und her kommunizieren. Also es kann auch sehr wohl sein, dass sie dadurch neue Flaschenhälse bekommen, wo sie das erstmal wieder rausoptimieren müssen. Das muss man sehen. Was ich ganz interessant fand, ist, dass sie ihre eigene JavaScript-Implementierung realisiert haben.
Da gibt es schon Benchmarks. Da können wir nachher mit verlinken.
Was besagen die Benchmarks?
Dass das von Chrome, also von Google ziemlich flott ist, hält sich ungefähr die Waage mit dem Squirrel-Fish von WebKit.
Hält sich die Waage? Ich hab irgendwas gehört von...
Das ist ein bisschen schneller an einem Benchmark und es ist aber ein bisschen langsamer an einem anderen. Aber es gibt einen Benchmark, aber der ist von Google selbst. Der benutzt viel Recursion. Und da ist der Code von Google wohl um ein vielfaches schneller als der Rest. Aber es ist halt auch ein Benchmark von denen. Also es könnte sein, dass es sehr doll Marketing angepasst ist und da kann man ja mal fälschen. Da weiß ich nicht, was man davon halten soll.
Also auf jeden Fall interessant, es wird zwei unabhängig voneinander entwickelte JavaScript-Engines geben, die in WebKit laufen, die beide schnell sind und zwar sehr viel schneller als...
Also JavaScript-Engines ist gerade... Also der eigentliche Krieg ist nicht mehr der Browser-Markt, sondern der JavaScript-Engine-Markt.
Eine spannende Verstellung, die ich auch gemacht habe.
Was heißt Krieg? Letzten Endes ist egal.
Klar, das belebt das Geschäft.
Ja, aber keine, wo man jetzt Monopole dazu befürchten hat, weil das ja beliebig austauschbar ist. Das ist sehr gut, denke ich auch. Also da eine weitere Alternative zu haben, zumal sie sicherlich glücklich werden, wenn die Leute das nehmen und auch woanders einbauen.
Das werden wir sicher bald sagen.
Auch bei Mozilla gibt es ja auch eine neue. Wie heißt die jetzt? Die müsste da in der Liste mit aufmachen. Spiderman, nee Trace Monkey ist die neue.
Trace Monkey und die von Google Chrome heißt V8, also V8.
Was ist mit Trace Monkey?
Trace Monkey ist jetzt von Firefox 3.1. Trace Monkey ist, mal gucken hier. Das ist kein Trace Monkey, oder? Auch doch, Firefox 3.1. Ohne Tracing. Ganz bisschen langsamer als der Squirrelfish. Squirrelfish könnten wir jetzt auch mal Safari 4.0 nennen, weil da gibt es ja jetzt auch die gesiedelte Version von Apple in der letzten Woche irgendwie.
Für Entwickler bisher nur.
Für Entwickler, genau. Hab ich noch keine News weiter. Aber hier gibt es einen Typen, der hat das anscheinend getestet und da ist der in einem Test, und zwar diesem Sunspider-Test, der wiederum aber von den Webkit-Jungs ist. Also es ist alles ein bisschen kompliziert, die machen ihre Tests halt selber. Da ist der Chrome der schnellste, ganz knapp gefolgt von dem Safari 4.0 mit Squirrelfish, dann gefolgt von Firefox 3.1, also dieser Trace Monkey, und dann weiter abgeschlagen ist ein älterer Firefox 3 und dann der aktuelle Safari ist ein bisschen abgeschlagen und ganz hinten kommt dann Opera Internet Explorer 8 und ganz langsam ist Internet Explorer 7.
Wobei man sagen muss hier, Firefox 3.1 ist ohne Tracing. Ich glaube, das ist noch Trace Monkey abgeschaltet oder ein wesentliches Feature von Trace Monkey abgeschaltet. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, welches von beiden.
Du meinst, das ist noch mal ein Stück schneller?
Der wird noch mal einen ganzen Zacken schneller, wenn er dann wirklich fertig ist. Aber auf jeden Fall eine sehr schön schnelle Engine da drinnen. Mal sehen, wie es da weitergeht. Was ich ein tolles Feature finde von diesem Chrome, ist die Tatsache, eben auch diese Tatsache zu verdanken, dass das alles einzelne Prozesse sind. Man kann sich angucken, wie viel Prozessorlast erzeugt, welcher Tapp genau. Und das ist in der Tat cool. Das ist für die Entwicklung ganz großartig, weil gerade zum Beispiel, wenn man Flash-Applikation entwickelt, kann man sehr, sehr viel falsch machen. Man kann aber auch sehr, sehr viel richtig machen. Und man kann sehr, sehr viel aus einer Flash-Applikation rausholen, wenn man ein bisschen kurz optimiert. Und dass ich jetzt überhaupt mal die Möglichkeit habe, wie viel Prozent habe ich jetzt gespart, das wirklich mal vernünftig rauskriegen kann, ist schon allein eine tolle Sache. Dann kann man nämlich mal sehen, welche Werbebanner da draußen eigentlich die ganze Zeit brauchen.
Aber das eigentliche Feature von Chrome für die Leute da draußen wird ja eher sein, ich muss mal ein Mikro ein bisschen heran machen. Wenn man was sucht, oder in eine, wie nennt man die Bar, Location oder Addressbar eingibt, dass Google das mit eigenen Vorschlägen unterstützen. Ich denke, das ist doch das Hauptfeature für die Leute, oder? Der normale User, dem kann doch egal sein, ob das Threads sind oder wie auch immer, der will, dass es halt funktioniert. Ok, das funktioniert ja durch Google Threads vielleicht ein bisschen besser. Aber die richtig neuen Features, für die sind ja neue Vorschläge, wenn man irgendwie...
Guck mal, das ist Google Suggest.
Das haben sie ja jetzt auch auf ihrer Startseite sozusagen auch drin. Also, dass das jetzt im Browser ist, ist sozusagen nur die Integration. Das hatten sie auch schon vorher, diesen Google Toolbar.
Aber das ist dadurch wesentlich besser...
Ja gut, aber das hast du auch mit dem Google Toolbar in anderen Browsern.
Das macht Firefox genauso. Da gibt es auch diese Suggest. Es funktioniert relativ flott. Mal sehen, wie gut es funktioniert, wenn die History erstmal voll ist und so was. Was ich noch ein ganz hübsches Konzept finde, mal sehen, wie gut es in der Praxis funktionieren wird, ist, wenn man einen neuen Tab aufmacht in Chrome. Jeder, der das benutzt hat, hat es schon mal gesehen. Macht da nicht einfach eine leere Seite auf? Oder man kann natürlich auch die Homepage einstellen. Ich persönlich hab immer eine leere Seite, was eigentlich ja komplette Verschwendung ist. Und weil die machen jetzt Sachen rein, dass man da zum Beispiel Buttons kriegt, große mit den am häufigsten verwendeten Seiten und eine History und die zuletzt geschlossenen Taps nochmal zum öffnen angeboten kriegt und eine Suchmöglichkeit und sowas.
Sehr interessante User-Interface-Optionen, die man an sich eigentlich von Apple erwartet hätte.
Genau, sowas ist eigentlich... Opera bietet da in der Beziehung schon ein bisschen länger was mit diesem Quick-Dial oder wie auch immer es heißt. Die haben das jetzt nochmal ein bisschen weiterentwickelt. Finde ich aber eher ein Detail am Rande. Also ich finde, ich hab das Gefühl, dass dieses Chrome in erster Linie erstmal eine Tech-Demo ist, in welche Richtung die Reise gehen könnte.
Sie haben sich bei den anderen Browsern gut umgeschaut und so das Beste rausgeholt. Ich hab zum Beispiel noch einen Feature entdeckt, was es sonst nur bei OmniWeb gibt. Na, dass sie sozusagen automatisch in Webseiten, wenn du so eine Suche hast, und du tippst da sozusagen was in die Suche und suchst in dieser Seite, dass sie daraus dann so automatisch so einen Suchbutton machen können. Das ist halt bei OmniWeb so ein spezielles Feature, dass du halt einfach auf so eine Webseite gehst und da, wo du es suchst, kannst du das eben sozusagen abkürzen und hast danach...
Das ist ein ganz großartiges Feature bei OmniWeb.
Ja, das ist ganz hervorragend. Das ist das, was ich mir in Launchbar immer von Hand zusammenbaue. So, was weiß ich, etwas in Wikipedia nachschlagen. Dass es halt einfach gleich ein User-Interface dafür hat.
Das funktioniert bei OmniWeb, funktioniert das so. Wenn ich irgendwo einen Suchfeld habe, egal auf welcher Seite, erscheint unten ein zusätzlicher Button, den ich klicken kann und BAM! Habe ich das oben im Suchfeld drin, als erweiterte Suchmöglichkeit. Ohne irgendwelche größeren Umwege. Ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist das bei Chrome sogar noch einen Zacken hübscher. Und zwar, ich brauche nicht mal mehr diesen Button zu klicken. Der ist gar nicht mehr da, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Sondern er merkt sich, alles klar, der hat auf der Seite mal gesucht. Und wenn ich jetzt mal wieder irgendwo suche und anfange, zum Beispiel, wenn ich vorher bei Amazon gesucht habe, ist das Beispiel, was wir da haben. Und er sucht, ich fange jetzt an A zu tippen, dann A, alles klar, der will doch möglicherweise bei Amazon suchen, biete ich ihm mal an. Das klingt für mich auch nach einem ganz großartigen Feature.
Das stimmt. Dann haben sie noch so einen Privacy-Modus, wie bei Safari.
Der Pawn-Mode.
Der aber per Tab ist. Das heißt, du machst dir einen Secure Tab auf. Bei Safari musst du halt generell den ganzen Browser umschalten, wodurch man das relativ...
Und dann vergisst man es immer einzuschalten und vergisst man es wieder auszuschalten.
Das ist richtig blöd.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Also vor allem überhaupt diese Idee, so der Tab ist eine eigene Welt. Sicherheitstechnisch mit dem Prozess, aber auch vom User-Interface her, dadurch, dass sie die Tabs nach oben legen, die stehen einfach heraus. Aber auch, dass sozusagen in diesem Tab ist irgendwie alles und nichts. Auf der einen Seite ist das komplett in sich geschlossen, auf der anderen Seite fügen sie ganz wenig hinzu. Sie sagen ja auch, da in diesem Google Comic und auch in FAQs, ihr Ziel war sozusagen, wie so das Betriebssystem ein Fenster bestückt, nämlich mit ganz wenig Minimal-Elementen. So was macht ein Mac OS X? Es macht so einen roten, gelben, grünen Button und vielleicht noch so den Toolbar-Button und das war's im Wesentlichen. Und der Rest ist einfach nur das Programm. Es gibt auch keine Render mehr. Und genauso geht Google an die Webseite heran. Und das ist natürlich, und auch hier haben sie sich wieder bedient, wie fluid das auf dem Mac schon macht oder Safari 4 hat ja auch die Möglichkeit, Webseiten abzuspeichern als eigenes Programm. Sie fördern die Idee, dass man nicht mehr mit Webseiten arbeitet, sondern dass man mit Web-Applications arbeitet.
Und dieses berühmte, diese Ansage, der Browser wird das Betriebssystem. Ich weiß gar nicht, von wem stoppt diese Idee eigentlich.
Netscape.
Ist bei denen jetzt konsequent weiterentwickelt. Das ist Browser, geh mir aus dem Weg, ich möchte nicht mehr als unbedingt nötig mit dir zu tun haben. Und Webseiten werden behandelt wie Programme im Sinne von kriegen Prozessorleistung, kriegen Arbeitsspeicher, dürfen nicht mit anderen zu sehr sich stören, was ich einen ziemlich spannenden Ansatz finde.
Auf jeden Fall. Was sie auch schick gemacht haben, ist mit Pop-ups. Pop-ups erscheinen sozusagen unten, wie so damals dieses Window-Shade-Feature. Ja, bei System 8, bei Mac OS, konntest du die Fenster nehmen und unten an den Rand ziehen. Dann kleben die Fenster da dran, da gibt es auch eine Erweiterung für Mac OS 10, die das ähnlich macht. Aber die waren dann ein bisschen nervig, hab ich wieder ausgeschaltet, aber so ging das. Da hab ich viel mitgearbeitet damals, hab einfach ein Fenster, was ich nicht brauche, einfach unten ran gedockt. Das ging nur im Final, oder? Das ging nur im Final.
Das ging nur im Final, das war aber ein ganz großartiges Feature, das ich bis heute vermisse. Genau, Spring-Pop-Up-Folders.
Spring-Loaded-Folder ist ja, dass die Folder aufgehen, wenn du drüber dragst.
Genau, nee, das war was anderes.
Das war dieses Window-Shade, das war halt einfach dieses Fenster.
Die Window-Shade war nochmal was anderes. Window-Shade war dieser zusätzliche Button, mit dem das dann auf die Titelseite verklärt wurde.
Das war das externe Ding, aber so wie sie es dann eingebaut haben...
Sie haben beide Varianten eingebaut.
Richtig, stimmt. Na wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, dass du nimmst halt ein Fenster, ziehst es nach unten, dann ist es wie ein Tab am Rande des Bildschirms, du klickst da drauf und dann klappt das halt so hoch. Und so ähnlich haben sie das jetzt mit den Pop-Ups gemacht. Das heißt, wenn du auf so eine Seite gehst, die hat irgendwie Pop-Ups, dann tauchen die unten nur so als so Dinge auf und du kannst sie dann explizit hochholen, wenn du möchtest. In ihrem Beispiel, wenn du da einen Audioplayer hast, der da aufgeht und du willst den halt auch haben. Aber bei default sind sie sozusagen aus dem Weg.
Ein Feature, was ich mir noch wünsche für Chrome, wo sie am nächsten dran sind bisher, dass man für jeden Tab einen eigenen Lautstärke-Regler haben kann. Dass man sagen kann, du Flash-Gedöns, ich mach, mach still, fertig. Ich will nicht, ich möchte nicht nach dem Ausbutton suchen, sondern ich möchte genau in diesem einen Tab Ton weg.
Das sollte ihnen sogar sehr leicht fallen, jetzt wo sie das auf einzelne Prozesse...
Das sollte ihnen eigentlich mittlerweile relativ leicht fallen. Also ich glaube, dass dieser Ansatz, den Google da geht, der, wie gesagt, langsam fällig war, dass der viele schöne neue Anwendungen ermöglichen wird und dass wir jetzt eine ziemlich schnelle Entwicklung im Browser-Markt erleben werden demnächst. Und darauf freue ich mich ganz doll.
Fishing haben sie noch eingebaut. Ach, können sie schneller fischen? Ja, das machen sie auch ganz interessant. Also bei Firefox ist es genauso. Das Teil lädt sich halt jede halbe Stunde von einer Google-URL so eine Liste mit Hash-Werten runter. Und das sind die Hash-Werten böser URLs. Und wenn du eine URL eingibst, dann macht er eben mal schnell einen 32-Bit-Hash von und guckt, ob das in dieser Liste drin ist. Und wenn dem so ist, dann connectet er noch mal zu Google und sagt hier, ich habe unter Umständen eine Phishing-Site, baut dann aber so einen 64-Bit-Hash auf, der also noch mal genauer ist und vergleicht sozusagen online in dem Moment, ob das auch diesem 64-Bit-Hash-Wert entspricht und wenn es dem entspricht, dann ist es wohl böse. Das heißt, die URLs, die du sozusagen prüfst, gehen nicht zu Google. Das ist quasi anonym. Also zumindest wird nicht gezeigt, was du ansurfen möchtest. Und das ist relativ clean gelöst. Also hauptsächlich diese ganze Google-Nummer nicht.
Also gerade bei dem Browser teile ich die wirklich.
Weil Google ja doch evil ist, natürlich hat Google schon längst alle 32-Bit-Hashes, alle ulfs. Klar, die müssen ihre ulfs ja verwalten von mir. Also ich meine, die haben halt.
Also ich meine, wieso gehst du davon?
Das stimmt auch wieder.
Aber es ist doch.
Aber wie willst du es anders machen?
Ich hätte es auch so gemacht, aber ich will nicht sagen, dass es nicht möglich ist, durch den Hash wieder auf die ulfs zu kommen. Wenn jemand das kann, dann Google. Die haben alle ulfs dieser Welt.
Ja, aber 32-Bit, ich bitte dich, das sind 4 Millionen.
Na und?
Na wie viele Webseiten gibt es denn? Wie viele URLs gibt es denn?
32-Bit sind ein bisschen mehr als 4 Millionen.
4 Milliarden sind das.
Ja, aber ich meine, ich glaube nicht, warum, also ich glaube, Wie viele Webseiten meint denn Google, dass sie gerade indiziert hätten? Es gibt bisher, und ich meine, es ist ja heute über der Blogosphäre eingeschlagen, durch Twitter gegangen, oh Google, kann man nicht trauen, kann man nicht trauen. Wieso soll man Google nicht trauen? Es gibt bisher, das Ding, der Browser liegt im Quellcode vor, man kann es sich runterladen, kann noch heute das Ding bilden, kann sich eine eigene Version machen. Es gibt bisher nicht den geringsten Hinweis, dass Google Daten sendet über die Daten, wo sie genau sagen, dass sie die senden. Sorry, dieser Browser ist nicht evil. Mag Google evil sein, dieser Browser ist es schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Ich hab nicht gesagt, dass der Browser evil ist. Und ich wollte nur sagen, dass es nicht heißt, nur weil die Hashes schicken, dass man daraus nicht wieder zurück zur Uhr kommen kann. Weil wenn jemand wieder darauf zurückkommen kann, dann Google. Ich nicht, weil ich hab diese Dictionary an Olds nicht mit schon passenden Hashes dazu. Die haben den wahrscheinlich schon lange.
Jetzt sag ich dir noch mal was total un-eviliges. Also ich hab hier so ein Windows in meiner... in meinem Bootcamp. Da hab ich das mal drauf installiert. Dann hab ich das Teil gestartet.
Nur deswegen, ja?
Nö, eigentlich nur um eine Telefonanlage zu konfigurieren ab und zu mal. Aber wenn dann halt mal so was zum Ausprobieren da ist, dann ist es natürlich ganz praktisch. Da hab ich es also drauf installiert, gestartet. Das Ding kommt hoch und sagt mir, deine aktuell eingestellte Default-Suchmaschine auf dem System ist MSN. Möchtest du das beibehalten?
Das ist, weil er von Internet Explorer importiert hat, die Daten.
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Wenn man Firefox schon am Laufen hat, und ich hab gesagt, importiere die Bookmarks von Firefox, dann macht er, Google ist eingestellt, willst du Google behalten. Exakt der gleiche Dialog, sowohl für Google als auch für MSN.
Aber das fand ich schon mal bemerkenswert. Also es ist nicht so, dass sie sagen hier einfach Google, sondern sogar, wenn du vorher mit MSN immer gesucht hast, dann honorieren sie das und du kannst das auch konfigurieren, was für Suchmaschinen da drin sein sollen. Also es gibt keinerlei nennenswerte Pressure, dass du Google verwendest, außer du hast überhaupt gar keine Presets.
Wobei sie da auch relativ...
Ich finde es auch völlig in Ordnung, dass ein Google Browser sagt, ich suche jetzt noch bei Google. So, aber das ist cool, oder?
Das ist ja auch nicht so, dass Google nicht tolle Sachen hat. Ich will nur sagen, dass von den ganz vielen Pluspunkten, die sie haben, darf man nicht vergessen, dass da auch so ein paar Minuspunkte sind.
Welche denn?
Die sammeln alles über dich, dass sie besser dich als Personen dem Werbe-Firmen verkaufen können. In einer angepassten Suche. Die haben dein Cookie. Die wissen genau, was du wann, wie wo klickst und kriegst angepasste Werbung.
Ist die angepasste Werbung, die ich kriege?
Kannst du auch den Cookie auch ausschalten?
Macht es wer?
Aber dann bist du evil, wenn du dich selber dem Google auslieferst. Also du hast... Guck mal, evil ist, wenn die wirklich jetzt was tun, was nicht koscher ist. Und das tun sie nicht. Sie tun genau das, was du als User sagst. Wenn du sagst, ich will dein Cookie haben und ich reiß dir auch jedes Mal durch, mein Gott, dann ist das halt so. Das wissen wir doch nun schon wirklich.
Wenn ich im Mail einen Account hätte und die meine Mails lesen, damit sie wissen, was sie mir für Werbung vorknallen können, dann finde ich das evil.
Du hattest schon bessere Argumente, finde ich.
Ich nutze Google auch so.
Wir können die Chrome-Geschichte jetzt abschließen, wenn ihr wollt.
Also es kommen ja gerade im Chat noch ein paar Fragen. Man kann die Hashes natürlich auch mal querien, wer alles auf einer bestimmten URL war. Ja, natürlich kann man das machen. Aber wenn man was gegen Phishing machen will, und das macht Google, dann muss man in irgendeiner Form...
Man kann das auch ausschalten. Man wird nicht gezwungen, das zu benutzen.
Das war jetzt auch nicht so ernst gemeint. Ich wollte es nur widerlegen, dass es nicht möglich ist, von Hash auf URL zu kommen. Mehr wollte ich ja gar nicht sagen. Das ist mehr so ein technischer Ausweis.
Also es ist klar, mag das möglich sein, aber ich sehe, dass Lock der Chrome nicht jede Eingabe in der Adressleiste mitlockt, obwohl die Eingabe noch nicht mal abgeschickt ist. Ja, natürlich, weil er macht ja eine Autokompletition. Und die kann man abschalten, wenn man es nicht haben will. Das ist ein Comfort-Feature. Das macht FireFox genauso. Wenn ich da nämlich oben ins Suchfeld eingebe, dann guckt er auch, was könnte ich dem denn vorschlagen. Dafür muss er die Daten natürlich an Google schicken, die ich gerade tippe. Das mag nicht jedem gefallen. Kann man drüber nachdenken. Es ist gut, wenn man darüber nachdenkt. Es ist gut, wenn man da vielleicht sogar ein bisschen paranoid ist. Aber ich sehe bisher nicht, dass Google in irgendeiner Form ebel ist, was diesen Browser angeht. Und es scheint mir gerade ein bisschen hip zu sein. Also ich habe vorhin bei tagesschau.de ein Artikel darüber gelesen, wie unglaublich böse Google doch ist, dass sie einen Ops-Source-Browser rausbringen. Und wenn das ebel ist... Das ist nicht böse. Und wenn das böse ist, dann macht irgendjemand eine schicke Version, in der man komplett privacy-mäßig unterwegs ist.
Also ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, es gibt ja noch Diskussionen, es gibt ja da diese eindeutige Nummer, die da irgendwie für jede Installation generiert wird.
Genau. Wenn man sich das runterlädt, irgendwie den Browser, wird eine eindeutige Nummer, ich weiß nicht, ob die schon von vornherein in die Installationsdatei reingepackt wird, oder ob die dann auf dem eigenen Rechner generiert wird.
Aber was wird mit dieser eindeutigen Nummer gemacht?
Mit der eindeutigen Nummer, die wird beim ersten Start irgendwie aufgerufen. Und sie wird bei Update-Nachfragen mitgeschickt. Also es läuft ein Update-Prozess im Hintergrund, der nachguckt, gibts eine neue Version von Chrome. Und da wird diese Nummer wohl mitgeschickt.
Da freu ich mich aber, wozu das nötig ist.
Weiß ich auch nicht, um ehrlich zu sein.
Jetzt hab ich euch auch angestiftet.
Naja, ich will ja gar nicht ausschließen, dass hier nicht noch irgendwas auftaucht.
Wir sind ja auch nicht so, ich will das halt nur so, dass natürlich viele Daten sammeln, damit sie irgendwie ihren Werbekunden besser zielgruppengerecht Werbeplattformen anbieten können. Das ist alles. So. Und ich denke aber auf lange Sicht könnte es auch ganz schön nach hinten losgehen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, die wissen auch, dass sie da an so einer Sprengfalle sind. Dass sie es nicht übertreiben dürfen.
Und ich glaube, sie haben gerade was, was diesen Browser angeht, haben sie wirklich bisher sehr, sehr strikt darauf geachtet, da echt keinen Fehler zu machen. Hoffen wir, dass es so bleibt.
Wir werden das beobachten.
Tatsache ist, der freiste Browser bisher, auf jeden Fall, von der Lizenz her. Du kannst das Ding einfach nehmen und kommerziell verwenden, alles, was da drin ist.
Du brauchst Änderungen nicht zurückzugeben.
Genau. Das ist halt eine BSD-Lizenz. Das ist komplett und vor allem ein komplett neues Security-Modell. Sie fördern damit vor allem die Weiterentwicklung von Standards im Web. Ich glaube, das ist auch das im Wesentlichen, worum es Ihnen geht. Sie haben auch Google Gears eingebaut, natürlich. Das wollen Sie natürlich auch, dass das Verbreitung findet. Von daher geht es auch darum, mit Google Chrome Ihre Technologie unter die Leute zu bekommen. Sie möchten natürlich, dass Ihre Frameworks verwendet werden.
Natürlich.
Wie Google Gears.
Das ist nachvollziehbar.
Natürlich wollen die auch einen Browser machen, weil ich nehme an, Ihr Hauptgrund ist, dass Sie zum Beispiel Google Docs haben und dass Google Docs noch nicht so richtig genutzt wird. Ich kenne Leute, die haben dann Bücher geschrieben, zum Beispiel mit dieser Word-Applikation von Google Docs. Aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass viele Leute sagen, mein Browser stürzt manchmal ab und mein Word-Programm stürzt nicht ganz so häufig ab. Darum vertraue ich lieber nach wie vor der Desktop-Applikation und dass Google dann irgendwie sagt, na Moment mal, da müssen wir uns gegen machen. Natürlich ist das im Interesse Google, dass möglichst viele Leute Google Docs benutzen, aber es ist auch in meinem Interesse, dass mein Browser möglichst stabil läuft und ich möglichst wenig Probleme habe. Insofern, solange sich diese Interessen übereinstimmen, bin ich doch glücklich.
Ich bin gespannt, wie die Mac-Version wird. Dadurch, dass der Kamino Guy daran arbeitet, werden wir hoffen, dass sie im Gegensatz zu Firefox...
Den ist das Pinkerton?
Mike Pinkerton.
Pinkerton ist das nicht auch ein ganz berühmter Detektiv gewesen?
Das war Nick Knatterthorn.
Nee, Pinkerton ist das, was heutzutage die Black... Wie heißen diese Mercenaries im Irak gerade?
Na gut, aber ich glaube, der hat nichts damit zu tun.
Nee.
Und wenn, dann macht das seinen Brauser wahrscheinlich nur besser.
Also Kamino gefällt mir deshalb sehr gut. Im Gegensatz zu Firefox, die Diskussion hat man ja nun auch schon, dass im Gegensatz zu Firefox, die halt versuchen, auf jedem OS möglichst gleich sich zu verhalten, ist Kamino einfach dediziert macOS-affin. Der benutzt die Keychain, der benutzt Standard User Interface, Controls und das zeigt sich halt auch.
Gibt es eigentlich eine Art Kamino für Windows?
Gibt es eigentlich eine Art Kamino fürs Windows? Ja, ohne den ganzen, wie heißt das bei Firefox, diese UXUI oder was ist das, deren Oberfläche? Genau, gibt es da so eine Art Kamino für Windows, dass sie auch Native Widgets von Windows benutzen, um dann schnell in den Browser hinzukriegen?
Ja, gibt es. Ich weiß aber gar nicht, wie er heißt.
Weil der müsste doch dann mal auch rocken, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, was der kann. Also es gibt... Ich weiß jetzt aber nicht, wie er heißt. Es gab irgendwann noch mal den Ansatz, sozusagen Kamino wieder auf Windows zurückzuportieren.
Weil ich finde eigentlich, die Firefox-Jungs sollten auch die Oberfläche und die Engine total voneinander trennen. Wenn man sieht, dass Kamino doch so total schnell ist, dann sollte man das auch auf Windows trennen und dann könnten sie irgendwann die Firefox-Oberfläche eigentlich weglassen, dann brauchen die man dieses XUL.
Ich wäre mir ehrlich gesagt, im Augenblick würde ich mal behaupten, dass Firefox schneller ist als Kamino, weil sie die schnellere Engine hat. Weil die Gecko 1.9.
Engine schneller ist als die 1.2. Engine.
Aber nur, weil die hinterher sind und nicht integriert haben.
Genau, da könnte man das...
Eine neue Version kommt aber raus, hat da gerade geschrieben, der Mike Pick hat einen in seinem Blog, zwei Möbel stehen vor der Tür.
Die wird irgendwann dem... Kommen? Na, er hat nicht gesagt, vor der Tür stehen, er hat gesagt, ich möchte noch keinen Termin sagen. Ach nee, Quatsch, nee, das war was.
Er arbeitet dran auf jeden Fall, read soon now.
Alan Pinkhampton war tatsächlich ein Detektiv. Und insofern, ich würde gern mal... Kamino fühlt sich immer schnell an, wenn man ihn gerade frisch installiert hat und nicht so lange benutzt hat, aber er hat auch seine Macken, wo er dann plötzlich ewig lange hängen bleibt, ähnlich wie Firefox auch.
Liegt vielleicht daran, dass sich Gecko so schwer integrieren lässt. Da ist ja WebKit ganz weit vorne. Also ich meine, wir werden auf jeden Fall ein Google Chrome für den Mac bekommen, der WebKit benutzt, was auf dem Mac zuhause ist. Und mit Camino, einem Camino-Developer im Rücken, denke ich mal, werden sie dafür auch ein Native User Interface machen.
Also gut, dass Sie da jemanden...
Sonst müssten Sie sich was ausdenken. Ich meine, ich denke nicht, dass Sie den Fehler wiederholen werden von Google Earth, wo Sie auf QT gesetzt haben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Google hat ja nun gerade so ein Scheiß, das benutzt niemand. Da ungern zumindest.
Das ist immer eine Katastrophe.
Deswegen bin ich mir relativ sicher, dass Sie mit dem Native UI rauskommen.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Sie... Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wie Native das sein wird. Erstens ist ja Chrome unter Windows auch nicht unbedingt aus wie ein Standard-Windows-Programm. Also ich meine diese Fensterleiste da oben, wenn man das sieht, wie das Babyblau und sowas, das ist ja schon nicht Windows-like. Und zum Zweiten, wenn Sie diese Philosophie haben, wir sind das Betriebssystem der Zukunfts- ein bisschen mit unserem Browser, dann werden Sie wahrscheinlich auch ein Stück weit wollen, dass sich das schon auf allen Plattformen relativ ähnlich sieht.
Nee, das ist denen scheißegal. Die wollen, dass sich das so wenig wie möglich überhaupt hervorhebt. Es geht denen um den Content im Web. Die wollen Web-Applikationen fördern. Die wollen nicht irgendwas drum herum machen. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Wir werden es sehen. Es ist einfach sehr wünschenswert. Wir haben letztes Mal schon drüber geredet und das war jetzt auch wieder ein Beispiel. Viele Leute haben berichtet, sie hätten halt auch ihre Settings aus dem Firefox importiert in Chrome. Hatte alles übernommen. Pokmarks, Einstellungen, Passwörter.
Passwörter.
Man kann aus dem Firefox einfach alle Passwörter raus importieren. Hooray for security. Das geht halt mit der Keychain nicht. Da kann ich einfach in Google Chrome sagen und sagen, ich importiere jetzt mal alle Passwörter, aber dann kommt das Betriebsdemon und sagt, ich würde zumindest gefragt werden, ob ich das will. Genau, ob du das willst. So hat das auch zu sein. Beziehungsweise er könnte ja dann auch die Keychain benutzen, wie alle anderen das auch benutzen und so, wenn er das klug macht. Das wäre eigentlich viel sinnvoller.
Natürlich wäre das viel sinnvoller, sind wir uns doch einig.
Aber wir wollen den Firefox-Streit nicht nochmal aufbringen. Ich denke, jetzt haben wir auch zu Google Chrome alles gesagt, oder? Gibt es noch irgendwelche tollen Fragen?
Ich hab jetzt gerade Google Chrome in den Chat geschaut.
Das Kind ist ja auch nicht immer ein trockener Tücher, oder wie sagt man?
Genau, ist noch nicht in den Brunnen gefallen.
Oh Gott, wir sind schon seit drei Stunden auf Sendung. Blödsinn. Drei Stunden?
Nein.
18.30, nur dann. Wir sind kurz nach 18.30.
Haben wir ja irgendwie live ein bisschen was erzählt, aber meine Aufzeichnung sagt zwei Stunden 30 Minuten.
Na dann haben wir alles.
Ok, Chrome haben wir jetzt hinter uns, dann müssen wir jetzt mal zu den weiteren Themen kommen.
Naja, wir haben, ich hab jetzt hier noch ein bisschen Kleinkram.
Wir können noch mal kurz die Legacy-OS-Geschichte machen. Schnell mal einschieben, bevor wir es vergessen.
Genau, ich hab dir heute ein Paket gegeben, Dennis. Weil du mir mal vor x Jahren gesagt hast, du sammelst alte...
Ich kann es dann nochmal rausholen. Hoffentlich kriegst du dann wieder eingepackt. Max, es ist vorhin nicht gelungen so schnell.
Sag mal, was sammelst du?
Ich sammel alte Betriebssystem-Versionen, also OS X-Versionen.
OS X-Versionen, oder?
Ja, ne, OS 9 brauch ich nun nicht mehr. Weil man auch immer wieder alten Scheiß und Rechner hat. Und ich dachte mir, sowas ist ja auch... Historisch muss man ja mal aufheben. Und viele Leute schmeißen den Scheiß halt weg. Und der Tim hat nämlich mal aufgeräumt und wollte auch wegschmeißen. Und dann fiel ihm ein, dass ich die ja so sammel. Und ich habe hier eine Rhapsody Developer Release für PC-Compatibles 1997. Original-CDs. Dann habe ich hier nochmal Developer Reads, Third Party Demos, Enterprise Objects Framework, auch von 1997, die gehört wohl dazu. Dann hat er hier sogar eine Diskette Rhapsody Developer Release für PC-Compatibles. Auch alles 97. Dann habe ich hier noch eine Rhapsody DR1-Disc. Noch mehr, also es ist alles Rhapsody. Ich habe hier sogar eine Bluebox-CD, eine Yellowbox für Windows NT95, alles sowas. Also wenn Leute noch irgendwie 10.1, 10.0, 10.2 Originale haben und möglichst nicht das, was beim Rechner dabei lag, sondern das, was man kaufen konnte, weil die Rechnerversionen waren immer ziemlich zugeschnitten und nicht allgemein verwendbar, dann her damit. Dann kann man die irgendwie sammeln und zur Not auch mal einsetzen.
Vor allem besonders wertvoll sind die, die später raus kamen und vollwertig waren. Also so 10, 4, 7 komplette...
Genau, damit man nicht alle Updates nochmal durchziehen muss.
Das ist ja mal super beschissen. Ich hab die jetzt reingeschoben, die erscheint nicht auf dem Desktop und ich krieg sie nicht wieder raus.
Na doch, du kriegst sie einfach lange drücken.
Einfach lange drücken, mal gucken.
Ja, siehst du, ein paar Sekunden. Mehrere Stunden.
So schlimmer war ich schon.
Dann ist er noch nicht fertig mit Prüfen.
Dann kann er sie nicht richtig lesen und schmeißt sie vielleicht gleich selber raus. Vielleicht ist er auch kaputt, keine Ahnung. Ich habe es mit den Dingern nicht so gemacht. Du möchtest es auf jeden Fall haben. Wo schickt man das dann hin, Dennis? Wo meldet man sich?
Privatadresse rausdrücken.
Ihr schickt einfach mal an mobilemacs.com.
Und das, wo die Hörer doch so evil sind.
mobilemacs.com Das ist überhaupt das Ding, alle sind evil. Genau, jetzt haben wir es. Dann wollte ich mir auch nicht mehr erklären.
Genau, Dennis ist evil.
Ja, ich sowieso.
So, ja, das habt ihr mir dann mal erwähnt. Wo wir noch bei Browsern sind, vielleicht noch mal abschließend. Von Firefox wird jetzt eine QT-Version entwickelt.
Also die konnte ich schon mal nicht lesen, aber... Von Firefox wird eine QT-Version entwickelt.
Und Firefox, das heißt?
Na, dass sie sozusagen auf QT aufsetzen. Das heißt, dass sie bei KDE irgendwie quasi zu einer Native-Applikation aufsteigen. Und das heißt vor allem...
Dass sie auf Mobiltelefon mit QT...
Dass sie quasi im Interesse von Nokia sind, sozusagen das Firefox da der native Browser sein könnte auch.
Aber Nokia macht da auch WebKit.
Nokia macht WebKit, aber Nokia macht vor allem QT.
Die haben QT aufgekauft, ne? Den Hersteller, oder wie heißt der Hersteller?
Nokia hat Trolltech gekauft. Die waren ja eh im gleichen Land, das lag sehr nah. Oder nee, wir waren sonst in der Schweden, auf jeden Fall Skandinavien, die hatten sicher alle lieb.
Bestimmt dunkelmal über den Weg gerannt.
Ja, und es ist absehbar, dass das Nukias letzte Rettung ist. Nokia sind die einzigen, die so halbwegs so aussehen, als ob sie vielleicht eine Antwort hätten aufs iPhone. Alle anderen, da sehe ich schwarz. Hatten wir ja schon ein paar Mal. Das zeichnet sich aber übrigens schon ab. Motorola geht es ja schon richtig schlecht. Ich glaube, Motorola-Mobile-Fonds gibt es in zwei Jahren nicht mehr.
Das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
So wie Sie man es halt auch abgestoßen hat.
Entweder werden die von irgendeinem Asiaten gekauft oder die gehen einfach komplett pleite. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die es noch lange machen. Zumindest im Smartphone-Bereich sind sie einfach raus.
In Amerika sind sie noch relativ stark. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die noch eine Weile von einer Patriotismuswelle hochgehalten werden.
Wir haben riesige Umsatzeinbrüche. Also das Patriotismus, da kaufen die alle Apple.
Stimmt, das wäre natürlich die spannende Variante.
Ja, das iPhone wird das dominante Smartphone werden, wenn es das nicht schon ist.
Aber im Smartphone-Bereich hat die Motorola noch nie so ein tolles Händchen gehabt, oder? Wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, die haben so ein paar Windows-Mobile-Phones.
Die hatten halt diese Razer-Modelle, die ganz gut weggegangen sind. Die hatten schon ein bisschen smarte Funktionalität, aber nennswert war das ja nicht.
Razer war wohl ein ziemlicher Erfolg immer noch, aber das Nachfolge-Modell war auch schon gleich wieder für'n Arsch, oder?
Es gab ja auch mal iTunes dafür und so.
Das war aber auch wirklich...
Genau, das war alles scheiße und hat Steve Jobs geradezu darin beflügelt, mal selber ein Telefon zu machen. Also Motorola, denke ich, ist raus. Nokia ist in den USA sowieso sehr schlecht aufgestellt und in allen anderen Bereichen aber noch ganz gut. Und das basiert aber alles auf Symbian. Und Symbian werden sie sterben lassen.
Haben sie nicht auch gerade erst gekauft oder irgendwie so?
Ja, Symbian gehört ja Nokia nur zum Teil und da sind halt auch noch Sony und ein paar andere mit drin. Und jetzt haben sie halt angekündigt, dass sie halt ein Buyout machen wollen. Warum sollen sie das tun? Um es sterben lassen zu können. Sie kaufen jetzt Symbian auf, führen das in eine eigene von ihnen geohnte Dings auf, dann haben sie schon gesagt, wir open sourcen das so ein bisschen, das heißt, sie werden das so weit aufblähen und open sourcen, dass die Firmen, die jetzt unbedingt mit Symbian auch weitermachen wollen, das auch gerne tun können. Aber sie werden es selber einfach sterben lassen.
Meinst du, sie stecken da Geld rein, um es sterben zu lassen?
Sie müssen aus den Verträgen raus. Derzeit haben sie halt da alle möglichen Verpflichtungen, Symbian weiterzuentwickeln für die anderen Hersteller. Deswegen kaufen sie das einfach, damit sie das Sagen haben und dann lassen sie es sterben.
Naja, muss ja nicht sterben sein, muss ja durchaus dem eigenen Schicksal überlassen, was ja durchaus auch eine Chance sein könnte für so ein Betrieb.
Symbian, weißt du, das ist Epok. Das ist ein PDA-Betriebssystem aus den early 90s.
Das ist alt.
Ich weiß, die Diskussion hatten wir ja auch noch mal.
Die Grundlage von dem iPhone, ja, die ist noch viel älter.
Das stimmt. Das wollte ich gerade jetzt beispielsweise vor.
Das ist auch die ältere Scheiße.
Ja gut, aber die Unix-Rechner waren damals die riesigen Mainframes. Heutzutage hat halt ein Telefon diese Leistung. Das ist sozusagen schon immer noch im selben Bereich. Aber das Epoch war für Maschinen, die viel weniger können, optimiert. Und da hat einfach für die Maschinen, die heute viel können, nichts mehr übrig.
Das finde ich wirklich ein schönes, eigentlich eine interessante Sache, dass das älteste Betriebssystem, oder jedenfalls die Erben dieses ältesten Betriebssystems, heute als die modernste Plattform gelten. Also gerade ja Mac OS X mit der, oder OS X mit der, mit der Unix, mit dem Unix-Erbe, dass das heute Windows, wie alt ist Windows NT, gerade mal komm 10 Jahre, oder vielleicht 15 Jahre, so die Schau stellen kann.
Na das liegt ja nicht am Unix.
Das liegt unter anderem an der soliden Basis, die da drunter steckt, na klar.
Das würde ich gar nicht mal behaupten.
Also erstmal ist es nicht Unix, sondern Mac. Und das ist schon mal deutlich neuer. Also ihre Kombination Mac... Anfang der 90er ist das alles so in die Reife gekommen. Und das sind halt schon moderne Konzepte. Ich meine, Apple hatte mit Mac OS X von Anfang an Multishredding. Und durch die Trennung mit dem Microkernel und dem Unixkernel haben sie eine gute Modularisierung gehabt. Das ist ja kein richtiger Microkernel, so nach der Reinen Lehre, der so für sich läuft und der Rest ist ein Userprozess, sondern das ist nach wie vor ein großer Körner. Aber es ist halt sehr viel besser getrennt, was die Kernfunktionalität ist und was die sonstige Funktionalität ist. Und da haben sie einfach eine moderne Basis. Und das merkt man heute auch an vielen Stellen. Warum wacht ein Macintosh so schnell auf? Weil einfach auf der niedrigsten Ebene sich alles so weit schon parallelisieren lässt, dass die Treiber schnell aufwachen können. Das ist einer der Hauptgründe, warum das so gut funktioniert an der Stelle.
Ich hab vorhin an einem Windows Vista eine Maus angesteckt, das war ein Erlebnis. Es dauerte ungefähr eine halbe Minute, bis die Maus sich den Cursor bewegen konnte. Treiber suchen. Ah, ich hab den Treiber gefunden.
Hast du ja auf dem Apfel nicht, weil gibts ja nur...
Ja, aber er sollte dann bei der... Und dann hab ich's abgezogen, wieder angesteckt und dann hat er nochmal eine halbe Minute. Hey, Treiber gefunden, yeah, ich bin glücklich.
Es ist definitiv schon eine andere Welt. So, und der andere Grund, dass Mac OS denn modern ist, ist ja nicht, dass da Unix drunter ist, oder auch nicht, dass Macht darunter ist, sondern, ta, wir hatten es schon ein paar Mal, die Frameworks. Das ist Coco, was das Moderne ist. Und das ist ja auch das, was das iPhone-Development so einfach macht. Und das ist halt das Ding. Und da müssen sie jetzt eine Antwort finden. Und das ist halt Nokia schon bewusst und deswegen sind sie auf die einzige nennenswerte Alternative gegangen, die es halt gibt, und das ist QT. QT hat halt einen ähnlichen Ansatz wie Coco. Basiert zwar alles auf C++ und nicht auf Objective-C, aber auch da haben sie halt Frameworks und viel Vererbung und so ein grundsätzlich objektorientiertes modulares Konzept. Naja, man wird halt sehen, ob sie da Lösungen bieten können. Ich hab da mal eine Zweifel. So, 9. September. Nächste Woche.
Da brauchen wir noch ein bisschen die Glaskugel zu sehen.
Ach, jetzt gibt es schon richtige Spyshots hier von dem nächsten Nano?
Ich glaube, das ist kein Spyshot, sondern das dürfte ein 3D sein, das aber relativ nahe hinkommt.
Auf was blicken wir? Wir blicken jetzt auf ein Foto, also etwas, was aussieht wie ein Foto von dem neuen iPod Nano mit dem großen Bildschirm.
Mit dem großen Hochkant-Bildschirm?
Ja, wird kommen.
Also, dass er so aussieht, dass es relativ sicher ist, weil von Hama sind ja auf der IFA schon Cases für den neuen iPod Nano aufgetaucht. Mit Verpackung, mit iPod Nano. Und die passen perfekt zu dem Bild. Was ich an dem Bild ganz interessant finde, das Display ist gebogen. Sieht so aus. Die gesamte Frontseite ist gebogen und damit eigentlich auch das Display. Und wenn ich hier so diese Effekte sehe, diese Lichteffekte, das sieht so aus, als ob da ein gebogenes Display drauf sein sollte.
Das Display wohl nicht, aber das Glas...
Für den Hörer ist das vorne so rund, wie das iPhone hinten rund ist.
Genau.
Das Ding vorne auch so rund ist.
Das sieht so aus, als ob man Papier rollen würde.
Vielleicht ist das eine Lupe und der Display ist eigentlich kleiner. Ja, also gut. Haupt mich jetzt nicht so um, der nächste Nano, mich interessiert mehr, was da drauf läuft. Welches OS? Ob das noch das alte ist? Ich vermute mal schon. Die Frage ist, was passiert mit dem Touch?
Da gibt es ja Gerüchte, dass er billiger wird. Dass er billiger wird, dass er ein bisschen dicker ist, warum auch immer.
Das ist auf jeden Fall auch meine Prediktion.
Die Maße von dem Ding sind auch schon mal aufgetaucht. Offensichtlich.
Auf iLounge, guck an.
Und vom neuen iPod Touch. Ansonsten wird er wahrscheinlich...
Aber das ist auch nicht so anders, oder? Der ist halt so jetzt wie iPod Touch 3G so ungefähr.
Das kriegt man aus den Gehäusen wahrscheinlich noch relativ schwer raus.
Kann man dir wirklich gleich ein Telefon leisten?
Ja, ich habe ja gesagt, meiner Meinung nach diese Ankündigung, dass sie ein Produkt rausbringen, was sie mit niedriger Ramage verkaufen, als sie das normalerweise tun, um da kompetitiv zu sein.
Das ist jetzt das, was nächste Woche kommt, meinst du?
Ich könnte mir einfach gut vorstellen, dass das auf den iPod Touch verweist. Das kann natürlich auch die neue Generation von MacBooks sein. Ich bleib erstmal bei meiner Aussage.
Also langsam sollte auf jeden Fall mal auch im MacBook-Bereich wieder was kommen. Es ist bald Weihnachten und wir wollen alle neue MacBooks sehen und selbstverständlich uns nicht gleich kaufen, sondern wir wollen einfach ich möchte wieder was haben, worauf ich hoffen kann und nicht hier so höhöhöhöhö, ein bisschen schneller als das alte MacBook Pro. Das brauch ich grad nicht. Ich möchte gerne ein neues MacBook.
Aber eigentlich bin ich trotzdem immer noch voll zufrieden mit meinem Rechner, auch wenn er jetzt bald zwei Jahre alt ist.
Zufrieden bin ich damit auch, aber das soll ja nicht ewig so bleiben.
Ich hätte gerne ein MacBook, was nicht so viel Lüfteraktivität hat.
Das ist beim MacBook wirklich relativ nervig, oder? Da ist das MacBook Pro deutlich besser.
Und ich wär irgendwie SATA-Anschluss. Ich mag diese USB-Schnupsies nicht mehr, die irgendwie mir SATA machen, die performen nicht, die kacken ab, wenn man dazu viel GB drüber schickt.
Aber das muss man so dabei haben. Aber das ist in dem Zusammengang zu tun. Es gibt einen Hinweis darauf, dass das kommen könnte. Weil Apple hat nämlich gerade einen neuen Patent eingereicht, wie sie Target-Modus über eSATA hinbekommen.
Target-Modus ist sowieso cooler Shit.
Target-Modus ist ja dieser Modus, mit dem man das MacBook als externe Festplatte für einen anderen Rechner nutzen kann, um zum Beispiel Backups zu machen und Ähnliches und da drüber zu kriegen.
Das machen die auch schon seit solange ich einen Mac habe, können die das auch mit Scassi damals schon.
Das ist eigentlich ein ganz großartiges Feature. Geht das eigentlich über USB 2 oder geht das nur über Firewire?
Das geht auch über USB.
Target-Modus geht über USB?
Na klar. Wie? Was?
Da steckste ran geht.
Hast du das schonmal gemacht?
Definitiv.
Was für Kabel?
Also ich hab auch immer gedacht, das geht nicht, weil ich so einen billigen USB-Gehäuse hatte, so USB-Firewire von vor riesigen, nicht 5, 6, 7 Jahren. Und das hatten USB 1. Und da kam aber nichts, dachte ja, das geht nicht. Aber ich hatte dann halt hier so einen 7-Euro-USB-Schnuffi für SATA und Pata und so weiter, 2,5 Zoll, 3,5 Zoll. Und da hatte ich mal so eine Platte dran. Und da hab ich mal gebootet mit alt und zack kam die Platte da. Achso, nee, nee.
Ich boot meine ich nicht, deine Target-Modus. Also dass du zwei MacBooks zusammenhängst. Also wir könnten jetzt ein Firewire-Kabel nehmen, von da nach da und du würdest das T beim Start gedrückt halten, dann würde ich deine Platte als extra eine Platte finden. Ich hab das mit dem Ruf verwechselt.
Ja, Booten von USB geht nicht über USB.
Target-Modus dürfte nicht gehen, oder?
Target-Modus weiß ich nicht, glaub nicht, aber Booten schon.
Es gibt ja nicht mal die passende Kabel für USB.
Was meinst du jetzt Booten, dass man von der USB-Platte bootet, die angeschlossen ist? Das ist ja nicht Target-Modus.
Da hab ich verwechselt.
Also funktioniert meines Wissens nicht. So, jetzt geht's.
Würde ja auch von den Steckern nicht gehen, weil USB hat ja auf der anderen Seite immer irgendwie anders den Stecker.
Und das hat ja auch einen guten Grund, weil es ja nicht zwei Hosts geben kann. Also es dürfte wahrscheinlich relativ ausgeschlossen sein.
Es geht wahrscheinlich auch nicht, weil Firewire kann man ja so daisy-chainen. Bei USB ist es ja irgendwie anders.
Da geht es ja muss es sein.
Aber da kommt ja bald USB 3 und vielleicht haben sie es ja diesmal hinbekommen.
Oder über... Also offensichtlich hat Apple vor, das über Esata zu machen.
Zumindest haben sie damit experimentiert. Und da ist noch eine Frage, was mit Firewire 3200 passieren wird. Sollte Stecker wie Firewire 800 haben?
Hatten wir letztes Mal alle schon durchgekaut.
USB 3, neues Firewire, alles möglich zu bekommen.
Jetzt steht hier nur noch eine furchtbar geheime Ankündigung eines neuen, alten Projektes.
Willst du jetzt über Blinken Dings erzählen?
Habe ich geblockt.
Blinken Dings. Ich will ihn nicht abkürzen, wir haben jetzt irgendwie 2 Stunden 45 auf der Uhr. Wir müssen langsam mal zum Ende kommen. Das ist das einzige Thema, was ich in dem Blog-Eintrag heute noch angekündigt habe.
Was die User hören wollten, ist, die wollen unsere persönlichen Setups haben. So wie wir es schon mal von unseren Programmen erzählt haben, wollen wir die von unserer Hardware wissen.
Stimmt, wir haben die Kommentare noch gar nicht durchgegangen. Bist du das hier schon durchgelesen, alle?
Na ein bisschen. Das ist der eine, der mir jetzt noch größer einfällt, aber da war noch irgendwas.
Dann machen wir das noch schnell.
Also mein Setup, kann ich ja mal ganz schnell erzählen, ihr könnt mich halt anstoppen, wenn es zu tief wird. Also als mein, ich trag immer ihn mit mir rum, ist halt so ein MacBook Pro, Core 2 Duo, Tra-la-la, 2,3 Gigahertz. Und den hab ich eigentlich auch immer bei in meinem Rucksack, wo es nicht auffällt, dass es ein Laptop drin ist, sonst kriegt man ja in Berlin auf die Schnauze. Und dann ist er weg. Also es ist keine gute Idee mehr mit Computer-Laptop-Taschen hier durch die Gegend zu rennen. Also hab ich schon öfter gehört. Ich hab's einfach im normalen Rucksack. Und zu Hause hab ich ein 23 Zoll Cinema Display. Da schließ ich das Ding halt an, dann hab ich alles in groß. Das ist auch eine extra Tastatur. Und der Laptop wird komplett zur Seite gestellt und ist auch zugeklappt. Und jetzt hab ich gleich noch eine höhere Frage. Und zwar, wenn ich da mein Display an meinen Rechner ranmache, dann hätte ich gerne, dass mein Display halt, das Cinema Display, der Hauptbildschirm wird, und mein Rechner sozusagen das Display abschaltet. Dazu muss ich aber immer das Ding in den Schlafmodus versetzen und dann irgendwie über das externe Keyboard das Ding wieder aufwachen lassen, damit dann nur noch das Cinema Display mein Display hat. Wie kriege ich das hin, ohne meinen Rechner in den Schlaf zu legen? Weil das nervt.
Habt ihr nicht Erfahrung mit externen Bildschirmen? Habt ihr keine gute Antwort drauf?
Aber wenn da irgendjemand was weiß, das hätte ich gerne. Weil ich immer jedes Mal Schlaf und legen, dann wieder aufwachen, nur damit der irgendwie den Bildschirm von dem Laptop auf den externen wechselt. Das ist ganz schön blöd.
Also die Menüzeile, dass die rüber wandert, sozusagen.
Nee, und dass das Ding hier ausgeht. Das ist ja so, wenn du eine externe Tastatur und ein externes Display und eine Mouse an deinem Laptop hast, dann kannst du das Display auch zumachen, was man ja sonst nicht geht. Und der Rechner bleibt an, weil da ein Display dran ist. Und ich will es aber gerne haben, weil ich mach's nämlich immer wieder auf, weil kühlt auch besser und so, weil es wird schon ganz schön heiß, dass ich einfach irgendein Problemchen drücken kann.
Aber meine blöde Frage, warum nutzt du das einfach nicht? Nicht einfach mit das nächste Display?
Weil ich hab ein 23 Zoll Display, da brauch ich nicht noch mit hin und her.
Dann hast du da irgendwelche Dinge, die da rumliegen, da weißt nicht wo es ist und so, das nervt schon.
Ja, ich hätte einen Bildschirm, ich hab Spaces, das ist viel geiler mit Spaces umzuschalten, als da rüber zu gucken. Muss ja meinen Kopf bewegen. Bist du verrückt?
Um Himmel zu reden.
Und das ist alles, du hast eigentlich nur den Rechner?
Ich hab noch einen G4 Dual 500 Mhz, hab auch noch einen Leopard draufgeknallt, was ja eigentlich nicht mehr geht, hab aber mit Platten und so geschummelt. Läuft auch ganz okay, aber das Ding ist halt so lahm und ich brauch halt keinen zweiten Rechner, nicht wirklich. Früher hatte ich das halt immer so, weil da so ein Bildschirm dran war, 22 Zoll, irgendwie so ein riesen Monster-Teil und das war halt angenehmer zum Arbeiten, aber seitdem ich jetzt mein Cinema-Display-Update hab, da brauch ich nix anderes mehr. Komm nach Hause, schließt dir da an, das ist alles super. Und sonst, für mein Netzwerk zu Hause, hab ich so eine IBM Dual 700-Kiste, da ist FreeBSD drauf, der macht mein PPoE-DSL, Subversion Repository, File Server, MTDA, PD und wat weiß ich nicht alles, da ist so mein ganzer Shit drauf. Der ist auch immer an und läuft und steht in der Küche und macht warme Luft.
Sonstige Apple-Produkte?
Ich hab ne AirPod Express, die macht Musik. Die Alte ist jetzt erschossen durch diesen Standardfehler. Anfang des Jahres die neue raus, hab ich mir gleich geschoppt. Das ist voll toll. Endlich wieder digital Musik hinschicken, ohne dass meine ganze Anlage rauscht, weil Kabel 10 Meter lang waren. Total schlimm. Jetzt ist wieder alles klasse. Und ich hab noch einen Ufo, ist aber nicht mehr in Benutzung. Denn Eyesight-Kamera ist auch nicht mehr in Benutzung. Hab ich mal ein bisschen mit Streaming rumgespielt.
Kannst du noch super günstig auf Ebay verscheuern?
Weil es gibt keine mehr, oder?
Genau, die gibt es nicht mehr zu kaufen. Und du kriegst jetzt noch einen ordentlichen Preis dafür.
Echt? Was ich noch hab...
Weil die Bildqualität ist deutlich besser als von den internen Dingern.
Ja, und das kann halt Autofokusieren. Also Autofokus. Was ich noch hab, sind zwei... Ich hab noch zwei Airportkarten.
Ich hab noch eine.
Also die Originale.
Die Originale, ja.
Und die gibt es halt irgendwie nicht. Wo die haben jetzt glaube ich schon von Sony oder so so ein Produkt gefunden, was kompatibel ist. Aber es weiß keiner Scheiße. Das schneiden wir raus und dann kann man die auch noch teuer verkaufen.
Na mach mal. Was?
Es gibt von Sony eine, die kompatibel ist?
Ja, irgendwie so. Ist wohl der gleiche Scheiß drin. Weil Sony hat natürlich auch nur irgendwie... Wie ist die Firma damals? Lucent irgendwie aufgekauft und irgendwie Sony auch oder irgendwie so. Und am Ende ist das doch alles das gleiche.
Also da ist noch zwei Airportkarten. Also ich zähle jetzt nicht jede Festplatte auf, die ich noch zuhause...
Ich hab keine Festplatten aufgezählt.
Eine könnt ihr noch gebrauchen.
Das muss ich übrigens sagen, so Storage-mäßig bin ja Hacker und Hacker sind mit dem Storage immer ganz hinterher. Ich glaub, also meine Festplatten zuhause, es ist keine größer als 300GB und davon hab ich auch nur eine und die ist sogar kaputt. Also ich hab ganz wenig Storage. Das wird sich aber mit ZFS ändern, wenn es erstmal fein herauskommt, ich sag's euch. Dann wird zurückgeschlagen.
Ihr schreibt doch echt alle Irre, was ihr das ZFS angeht.
Das ist toll, du wirst es noch sehen.
Das ist bestimmt toll und ich werd's sehen, jeder wette. Ich hab eigentlich nur, ich hab meinen MacBook Pro. Ich hab jetzt gerade nochmal extra nachgeguckt, mit 2,2 Gigahertz. Ich bin schneller als du. Mit Intel Core 2 Duo. Hab mir irgendwann mal, das Einzige, was davon von der Standard-Konfiguration abweicht, ist, dass ich 4 statt den üblichen 2 Gigabyte habe. Also ich hab den Speicher irgendwann mal verdoppelt.
Ah, dein Ding ist langsamer als meins. Du hast die kleinere Version, aber aktueller als meins. Weil ich hab nämlich noch auch keinen LED-Bildschirm.
Den hast du nämlich nicht, ne? Ich hab einen LED-Bildschirm. Ich hab mir damals, als das letztes Jahr kam, im August...
Du hast von der LED-Version die kleine, ich hab von dem vorigen die große.
Ich kauf mir eigentlich immer die kleinere Version.
Ab jetzt kann man das auch machen, die Dinger sind so flott.
Und ich hab externe Bildschirme und so, hab ich überhaupt nicht. Ich nutze mittlerweile nicht mal mehr externe Mäuse. Also ich nehm nur noch das Trackpad. Ich hab so immer noch so eine Mighty Mouse Bluetooth.
Meine Maus ist an meinem Display dran. Ich steck das Display ran, das hat ja auch USB und Firewire. Das ist dann alles am Display. Und da hängt die Maus und die Tastatur schon dran.
Ich hab hier eigentlich, wo ist er jetzt? Ah, da ist er. Ich hab hier eine Mighty Mouse dabei, die ich eigentlich immer mit mir rumschleppe. Ich hol die einfach nie raus. Mittlerweile sind leider auch die Batterien leer. Ich bin ein totaler Trackpad-Freund geworden. Gerade wenn man zwischendurch beim Tippen hin und wieder mal zwischen Maus und Tastatur wechseln muss.
Ich hab zu Hause auch eine Mighty Mouse, aber mit Kabel. Und die ist total toll.
Ich mag die Mighty Mouse ganz gerne. Aber ich bin sehr glücklich mit dem Trackpad. Und ansonsten hab ich eigentlich so... Also klar, ich hab mein iPhone. Zu Hause hab ich ein... Was ist das? Ein Pentium 4 oder irgendeine alte Möhre. Als Home-Server, so ähnlich wie du. Noch irgendwo eine Xbox rumstehen, die als Media-Server, also als Media-Client für zu Hause dient, was ganz großartig geht. Aber an Apple-Produkten hab ich sonst eigentlich gar nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viel. Und keine Air-Pod-Karten mehr rumliegen, die ich noch verklippen könnte.
Verräter!
Was?
Du hast nicht genug gekauft.
Ich habe gekauft Apple-Produkte. Ich sag ja, bringt neue MacBook-Pos raus und ich hab wieder was, worauf ich mich freuen kann.
Ey, was ist denn bitte Präferenz Sync-CI für einen Prozess? Was? Der frisst gerade auf meinem Computer 89% der CPU.
Na, kein Wunder ist der Lüfter anders. Vielleicht solltest du einfach mal...
Drück mal X.
Vorher hat Safari so viel gefressen.
Kannst X drücken.
Ich beende mal diesen Prozess. So, das war's schon. Soll ich mal erzählen?
Das war bei mir im Wesentlichen alles, ja.
Also ich hab einen Macbook, ein schwarzes.
Jetzt haben wir ja noch eine Stunde, oder?
Ich glaub 2,16 oder so.
Du hast ein kleines schwarzes.
Ich hab ein kleines schwarzes. Jetzt weiß ich gerade gar nicht mehr, welche Geschwindigkeitsklasse das war, aber ich glaub 2,16, genau. Mit 3 GB drin, was auch nicht viel hilft und find, das ist irgendwie immer zu langsam, aber ich fahr auch immer zu viele Applikationen.
Das ist noch eins, wo nicht mehr als 3 GB gehen, oder?
Wo überhaupt erst mal 3 GB gingen. Ich hab mir das gekauft.
Auch im Macbook.
Ich glaube ja. Ja, und ich habe sonst noch ein Mac Mini, der derzeit noch an meinem alten Fernseher dran klemmt, den benutze ich eigentlich viel zu wenig, und ich denke, ich werde den demnächst hier mal auf meinen Desktop promoten. Wollte mir dazu noch so ein Cinema-Display kaufen, aber die sind mir dann immer, wenn ich drüber nachdenke, eigentlich zu teuer. Und die anderen Billigteile sind mir immer alle ein bisschen zu billig. Also die, finde ich, sind nicht so, haben einfach nicht so das Bild, was ich erwarte von so einem Bildschirm.
Displays gibt es auch schon ewig, da wäre auch mal eine neue Generation für mich. Also die müssen USB 2.0 kriegen, weil die haben glatt nur USB 1.0, glaube ich. Bin mir nicht so sicher, aber es ist so.
1.1, aber trotzdem.
1.1, ja, aber ich glaube, die haben nur das. Und Firewire haben sie auch nur 400. Da könnten sie mal ein bisschen dran drehen.
Was, die Cinema Displays haben Firewire?
Na, die tun ja das durch.
Die haben doch so einen Hub drin.
Einen Kabel mit gleich drei Ausgängen und die schließt du an dein Rechen an, so pop, pop, pop. Und dann hast du an deinem Display Firewire und USB.
Das ist voll toll.
Dann kannst du da schon alles anschließen und dranlassen. Und wenn du dann dein Display ranmachst, dann kommen die gleich alle hoch.
Okay. Aber ich weiß nicht, preislich könnten die mir noch ein bisschen entgegenkommen.
Sollten sie auch mal langsam sinken. Und dann holt ihr gleich einen 30 Zoll. Das ist einfach so shit.
Ja, und dann hast du dann wirklich eine gute Auge.
Ja, ich glaub bei den aktuellen schon.
Das werden wir mal nachschlauen. Auf jeden Fall hab ich sonst noch eine Time Machine. Damit bin ich eigentlich so weit ganz zufrieden. Zumindest hab ich immer Backups.
Also du meinst diese... Heißt die Time Machine? Ich dachte so heißt die Software, die Time Machine.
Ach, Time Capsule, Entschuldigung. Ja, natürlich. Ich hab eine Time Capsule... Der Podcast dauert schon viel zu lange. Ich hab eine Time Capsule, die alte Extreme liegt hier noch rum, die wollte ich eigentlich mal verschäbeln. Und für mein Mac Mini habe ich auch noch dieses Wireless Keyboard und Bluetooth Mouse. Das Wireless Keyboard ist schick, ne? Ist schick, hat aber ein paar Probleme. Problem ist, also der Vorteil ist, dass es klein ist und der Nachteil ist, dass es klein ist, denn sie haben es so sehr reduziert und es gibt eine Tastatur, die ich mir von Apple schon immer wünsche, die ich wirklich wirklich wirklich gerne mal hätte, nämlich eine, die so ist wie die Unterseite von meinem Laptop, nämlich mit einem Trackpad und mit einer Tastatur und mit einer Handablage. Bei dieser Wireless-Tastatur gibt es halt keine Handablage und das ist, wenn du so auf dem Sofa sitzt, total fummelig zu benutzen.
Als Sofagerät ist das nicht geeignet, ne?
Du kannst sie nicht benutzen, aber das ist die Tastatur, die will man auf dem Sofa haben.
Also die Wireless-Variante jetzt.
Die Wireless-Tastatur. Hast du einen Mac Mini da irgendwie am Fernseher oder was sonst für ein Display? Willst du das halt ab und zu mal fernsteuern? Und ich hätte halt einfach gerne eine Bluetooth-Tastatur mit einer Handablage und mit einem Trackpad. Dann bräuchte ich erstmal keine Maus. Weil Maus ist einfach so 90er Jahre. Also ich benutze keine Maus mehr. Ich benutze ein Trackpad. Und ich hätte einfach ganz gerne das so, wie das hier auf meinem MacBook angeordnet ist, einfach als einzelnes Device. Einfach Maus und Tastatur in einem mit Bluetooth. Und dann wäre das auch eine geile Fernsteuerung für ein Laptop.
Du könntest ja, also ein Trackpad hast du jetzt ja quasi billig in der Tasche rumliegen, dein iPhone. Gibt es nicht auch irgendeine Software fürs iPhone, mit der man einfach...
Ja, das ist was anderes. Dann habe ich das iPhone. Das wird hier sich sicherlich irgendwie schön noch integrieren. Und das ist eigentlich so mein Setup. Der Haushalt hat auch noch einen MacBook Air, aber das ist nicht meins.
Der Sohnemann bekommt bald My First Mac wahrscheinlich. Sobald es das dann gibt.
So, weitere Fragen? Dieser Podcast zieht sich in die Länge.
Dieser Podcast zieht sich in die Länge.
Na warte mal, hast du hier schon durchgeguckt?
Ich hab noch nicht durchgeguckt.
Du, wenn wir nach sowas sagen, wir beantworten Fragen, dann müssen wir das auch tun. Hörer first.
Und wir labern jetzt...
Das geht ja dann wieder nur um die Live-Hörer.
Nein, Leute haben hier vorher vor der Aufnahme gesagt, geht doch mal da drauf ein. Das hören sie sich natürlich auch im Podcast an. Meine Güte.
Okay, da ist jemand, der will wissen, wo die Hibernation-Datei gespeichert wird. Also wenn man seinen Rechner in Schlafmodus legt, dann wird ja auch der RAM abgespeichert.
wird auch irgendwo unten beantwortet, das ist ein VAR-VM, wo auch die ganzen anderen... Weißt du eigentlich, warum sich da immer so viele VAR-Dateien stauen und die Platte belegen? Es werden immer irgendwie immer mehr Swap-Dateien, die da rumliegen und die werden jedes Mal doppelt so groß wie die davor.
Na, damit er klein anfangen kann und dann immer größer weiterlegt. Weiter zulegt und das er dann auch wieder löschen kann.
Ja, aber macht er ja nicht.
Na ja, beim Neustart.
Also was immer hilft, ist ausloggen.
Ausloggen?
Ja, weil dann wird ziemlich viel Programme sozusagen gekillt, also auch der Finder und die lassen dann ihren Speicher los und dann wird auch mal freigegeben.
Ausloggen und Einloggen ist der kleine Neustart.
Also ich hab hier so viel Swap-Files, wie ich RAM hab, sozusagen. Echt?
Ich hab 64 MB, 64 MB, 130, 250. Also ich komm hier auf ein bisschen mehr über 1 GB und ich hab zwei.
Aber mit dieser Halbernet-Datei, das ist doch, die kann man doch verschlüsseln, oder?
Ne, die nicht, den Swap kannst du verschlüsseln.
Die Halbernet-Datei nicht? Das ist ja doof.
Oh ja, das ist ja ein echtes Problem.
Da gibt's zwei schöne Tools, die man erwähnen sollte. Das eine ist dieses Smart Sleep. Da kann man einstellen, ab welcher Akkuladung er wirklich dieses Image schreiben soll. Das heißt, kannst du es so einstellen, dass wenn dein Akku voll ist, du klappst zu, dass er es nicht macht, damit es schnell geht. Aber wenn der Akku halt im kritischen Bereich ist, dass er das schon mal macht, nicht dass er dann in der Tasche leer wird und seinen Ramp vergisst.
Also ehrlich gesagt ist mir das egal. Ich klapp zu und ob der noch schreibt oder nicht, ist mir inzwischen auch schon geil. Ich kloppte in meinen Rucksack rein, der kann von mir aus weiterschreiben.
Also ich nutze, es gibt so ein kleines Prev-Pain. Das ist nicht ganz so gut wie dieses Smart Sleep, oder nicht ganz so clever, aber das heißt einfach Hibernate. Und da kann ich einstellen, welche Variante er wählt. Standardmäßig ist ja Sleep plus Hibernate, also dass er zuerst diese Hibernate-Datei anlegt und danach sich ganz normal schlafen legt, sodass er wenigstens schnell aufwacht. Und ich hab das einfach umgeschaltet auf reinen Sleep-Modus. Und mein Rechner ist nie lang genug im Schlaf-Modus, als dass er dann nicht mehr aufwachen würde. Und wenn, dann wär's mir auch nicht so wichtig, ehrlich zu sein. Aber es wäre wirklich noch nie passiert, dass im Schlaf-Modus der Akku leer war und dass ich deswegen da anfälle hätte.
Warte mal, du hast in diesem Hibernate eingestellt, dass er nur sleept? Und dann sollte dieses Image nicht angelegt werden?
Dann wird das nicht angelegt.
Ich hab das auch installiert, und bei mir wird das Sleep-Image angelegt.
Dann wird die nicht angelegt, sondern hast du es einfach nicht gelöscht. Du kannst es dann löschen, wenn du den Modus gewechselt hast.
Da brauchen wir keine Extratools, das ist ein Commandline-Tool und heißt, glaub ich, PM-Set oder sowas.
Das kann man auch über die Kommandozeile machen.
Ich glaub, das...
Du müsstest mal PM-Set in einer Commandline ausführen, das ist ziemlich ausgiebig und hat viele Optionen. Muss man aber auch ein bisschen aufpassen, dass man da keinen Scheiß macht.
Ich glaub, die beiden Pref-Pains kommen sich hier gegenseitig in die Querer.
Deswegen ignoriert er das. Ich weiß nicht, welche Variante du hast. Das müsstest du eigentlich mitkriegen daran, wie lange dein Rechner braucht, bis er eingeschlafen ist. Aber man kann die Datei dann löschen. Gefahrlos, wenn man in den Sleep-Modus umgeschaltet ist. Das macht er nicht automatisch.
So, jetzt gucken wir nochmal. Was gibt es hier noch für Fragen? Programme deinstallieren, bla bla bla. Fand er toll, dass man das nur mit Deinstaller auf dem Mac, ich glaube, da haben wir schon mal drüber geredet, das ist wirklich grauenhaft.
Das muss Apple irgendwann mal liefern.
Das ist nicht so einfach, aber das muss irgendwann mal kommen. Man muss einfach in der Lage sein, Programme komplett zu deinstallieren, auch wenn sie was außerhalb ihres eigenen Bundles installiert haben.
Und das ist halt derzeit nicht möglich.
Es gibt einen Haufen Programme, die dabei helfen sollen, zum Beispiel Zap It und Clean Delete oder wie auch immer die alle heißen. Aber es wäre schon schön, wenn es da irgendwas von Apple für gäbe. Darf gerne genauso toll funktionieren, wie das einfach in den Papierkorb schmeißt, nämlich dass der Rest einfach hinterhergeschmissen wird oder sowas.
Das will man aber manchmal auch nicht, weil man sich ja eventuell eine alte Version wegschmeißt und eine neue holt und dann will man nicht gleich alle Daten verlieren. Sollte schon auch unterscheiden.
Dann sollten sie sich was Cleveres ausdenken. Mir wurscht.
Sollten wir unsere Ausgehfrisuren aufhaben, ein Foto von der Aufnahmesituation der Sendung haben? Sollen wir das jetzt machen? Wenn ich jetzt hier ein Foto mache, dann bin ich ja nicht drauf.
Machen wir beim nächsten Mal. Ich hab meine Ausgehfrisur nicht an. Außer mich gibt es eh schon.
Du hast deine Angehfrisur aus.
Das stimmt, ich habe das schonmal fotografiert.
Aber du hast deine Angehfrisur aus.
Es ist viel zu dunkel hier, um mit dem iPhone etwas zu fotografieren.
Die ist nur Pseudo.
So, Chrome, Chrome, Chrome. Haben wir uns irgendwie drunterhalten. Dann wird hier irgendwie AFP oder SMB in einem reinen MEC-Netzwerk. Da möchte ich auch nochmal einen kurzen Teaser einwerfen für die letzte Chaos Radio Express Folge. Wo ein alter Kumpel von mir aufgekreuzt ist, der sehr viel Erfahrung hat mit File-Sharing, insbesondere mit dem Macintosh File-Sharing, weil er nämlich der Main Programmer von Ethershare war.
Hans-Uwe Merger.
Ethershare ist eine Linux-Öse, eine kommerzielle Linux-Lösung, das AFP macht unter Unix.
Genau, das ist für Unix im Allgemeinen. Es läuft mittlerweile auch auf Linux, aber das lief schon auf Unix. Da gab es Linux noch gar nicht. Das ist auf jeden Fall etwas, was sehr gut funktioniert hat. Tatsache ist, dass er in diesem Podcast sehr ausführlich mal auf die Unterschiede und Gemeinsamkeiten von AFP, SMB und NFS eingegangen ist. Wen das interessiert, der möchte da vielleicht mal reinhören. KAUSRADIO EXPRESS 097.
So, Hifa Highlights?
Das gleiche Produkt heißt übrigens Netatalk, oder zumindest Kompatibel. Damit kann man sich einen AFP-Share einrichten, wenn man irgendwie ein FreeBSD Linux oder sonstiges hat.
Ich hab das lange nicht mehr benutzt. Ich hab mal Netatalk auf BSD benutzt, das war ein großer Fehler.
Also ich hab mal mitgebracht.
Also es gab immer die Versionen 1, 3, 4, 5 und 6, also bis 1.6. Und das 1.6 ging dann einigermaßen. Und jetzt gibt es eine 2.0.3 und die tut eigentlich ziemlich gut. Und das Rock'n'Roll.
Also ich hab mit Netatalk mit irgendeiner 1.3. Also es war noch nicht 2.0, die war damals noch nicht so weit. Ganz, ganz furchtbar schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht. Und zwar war das nämlich so, dass wenn man, da gab es ja diese File Reference Numbers damals noch, die es heute theoretisch auch noch gibt. Also dass jeder Dateien hat, das Dateisystem eine eigene Nummer hat. Die gibt es immer noch. Genau, aber ich glaube, sie wird nicht mehr so tief verwendet. Und die hat Nettetalk auch emuliert. Aber nur bis maximal glaube ich 65.000. Und danach kippt er das einfach wieder um. Oh super. Sodass man eine Datei doppelt geklickt hat, und es ging eine ganz andere Datei auf. Dadurch waren alle Daten korrupt. Und jetzt kommt das eigentlich böse an dieser ganzen Nummer. Das ist natürlich erstmal nach einer ganzen Weile passiert, war nicht reproduzierbar. Und dadurch, dass das Net-a-Talk seine Daten, diesen Resource-Fork und den Data-Fork, auf eine ganz eigene Art und Weise abgespeichert hat. War das damals Punkt-Apple-Double? Ich weiß es nicht. Also in irgendeiner Variante. Punkt-Apple-Double kommt gut hin, genau. Abgespeichert hat. Und man das damals nicht anders zurückbekommen hatte, konnte man die Daten nur damals per Net-a-Talk zurückholen. Und ich hab damals in einer mehreren Nächte dauernden Hin- und Herkopieraktion die Daten dann immer Gigabyteweise auf einen G5 kopiert, in der Hoffnung, dass die dabei nicht korrupt sind, dann am nächsten Tag die ganzen Daten überprüft. Also Net-a-Talk hab ich wirklich gefressen mittlerweile.
Also die Daten waren weg?
Die Daten waren nicht weg, wir haben sie noch gerettet gekriegt. Aber es hat mich ungefähr anderthalb Wochen gekostet.
Stabilität ist das Problem, hatte ich auch. Und das bei einem Server ist komplett nicht fassbar.
Mittlerweile haben sie es hoffentlich im Griff.
Apple Double ist ein Apple-Standard. Also das ist eine Spezifik. Es gab Apple Single und Apple Double. Das waren zwei Varianten, wie man auf einem Unix-Fallsystem Macintosh-Dateien ablegt.
Dann bin ich mir nicht mehr sicher, ob es damals schon Apple Double war.
Apple Double gibt es schon richtig lange. Über Apple Double und Apple Single haben wir in der Tat nicht geredet, aber über die grundsätzliche Problematik, wie man Macintosh-Fallsystemen und einen AFP ist ja sozusagen ein Blickwinkel auf HFS. Die Problematik, wie man das macht, darauf wird auch eingegangen.
Oder habe ich die damals auf dem Server dann in eine Apple Single-Datei konvertiert und die dann rüber kopiert und dann auf Mac wieder ausgeprägt?
Wir werden es nicht mehr rauskriegen. Es war das Grauen.
Finger weg von Let The Talk.
Was waren eure IFA-Highlights? Wart ihr überhaupt da? Du warst da.
Ich war auch da. Ich war leider nur relativ kurz da und war komplett übermüdet. Ich hab so einen kleinen, wie heißt dieser Dino? Dieser Roboter Dino. Das war glaube ich mein persönliches Highlight.
Roboter Dino?
Es gibt so einen Roboter Dino. Wie heißt denn der? Sieht so ein relativ, sieht ganz niedlich aus. Kann man so am Kopf streichen und bewegt deinen Kopf in die eigene Richtung.
Ich glaube, das war jetzt nicht, wohin die Frage zielte.
Das war nicht die. Bist du sicher, dass das die IFA war? Das war 100% die IFA.
Ich werde meine Mama wieder am Kindergarten abgeben von der IFA. Weil da sind die.
Ja, jetzt sind wir drei Stunden durch, jetzt wird's spitz, finde ich.
Und ich bin nicht mehr schlagfertig, das ist dämlich.
Sag doch mal, hast du in IFA Highlight ein richtiges?
Ich hab keine tollen Sachen gesehen. Was ich gesehen habe...
Okay, ich hab was tolles gesehen, soll ich sagen?
Also was ich gesehen habe war... Hey, ein Fernseher hab ich nicht gesehen. Ich weiß nicht mehr auf welchen Stadt das war. Das war ein MP3-Streaming-WLAN-Radio, was aber nebenbei noch ein Kassettendeck hatte. Und das fand ich so unglaublich anachronistisch, dass sie einfach in ihren WLAN-Highlight-Bla-Bla-Bla-Empfänger immer noch ein Kassettendeck reingebautzt hatten. Das war mir ein Foto wert. Aber ansonsten hab ich nichts gesehen, was mich wirklich vom Hocker gehauen hätte, wobei ich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht genau hingeguckt habe. Was war denn dein Highlight, Tim?
Mein Highlight war ein längeres Gespräch mit einem Vertreter von TomTom.
Und es war das erste Mal, dass sich der Vertreter von TomTom direkt danach erschossen hat, oder? Nein!
Das war hervorragend. Also, muss sagen, die Jungs da auf dem Standen waren wirklich extrem auskunftsfreudig. Hab schon lange nicht mehr so einen Messestand gesehen, wo ich so viel Informationen in so kurzer Zeit auf freundliche Art und Weise dargeboten bekommen habe. Und ich hab mich einfach mal erstmal schlau gemacht. Ich hatte ja hier schon mal geklagt, dass ich das Produktportfolio von TomTom nicht verstehe. Und vor allem ihre Features nicht verstehe. Zumindest nicht auf Basis der Schilderung ihrer Webseite. Das hab ich dann auch gleich beklagt. Das haben sie einfach zur Kenntnis genommen. Und naja, dann war ich noch ein zweites Mal da, hatte noch ein paar weitere Fragen. Und dann kam auch tatsächlich noch einer von TomTom aus Holland. So ein Holländer, der natürlich wie alle Holländer gut Englisch sprach.
Und ganz furchtbar freundlich war.
Und auch sehr freundlich war. Aber jetzt nicht so aufgesetzt freundlich, sondern einfach so freundlich freundlich.
So freundlich freundlich.
Und der auch wirklich tiefe Einblicke in wie sie so arbeiten mir gegeben hat. Das krieg ich jetzt sicherlich nicht alles zusammengefasst, aber ich hab mir vor allem ihr neues Feature mal erklären lassen. Nee, das ist nicht neu. Neu ist jetzt ihr angekündigtes TomTom Go 740.
Mit schon eingebautem Fest-GSM, wo man sich nicht mehr kümmern muss.
Was? Richtig.
Sie haben eine SIM-Karte mit drin von Vodafone. Und das Ding funkt selber und bezieht live Verkehrsdaten. Und sie machen das ja schon eine Weile, dass sie, also dieses sogenannte IQ-Routesystem bei TomTom, dass sie Straßen nicht nur danach, also es geht ja immer darum, den besten Weg zu finden. Und sie haben verschiedene Strategien. Da hat sie auch mal ein bisschen geschildert, dass sie da wirklich coole Algorithmen gehabt haben, über Jahre hinweg so viele kleine Details, die aneinander gereiht eine Menge Sinn machen. So was wie, wenn ich rechts abbiege, bin ich schneller als wenn ich links abbiege. Und natürlich haben sie immer so die erlaubten Geschwindigkeiten auf den Straßen genommen, aber wir wissen alle, die erlaubte Geschwindigkeit sagt nichts darüber, wie schnell man wirklich auf einer Straße rankommt. Es gibt Straßen, die sind einfach voll, es gibt Straßen, die sind nicht so voll. Und sie haben jetzt eine umfangreiche Kooperation mit Vodafone gestartet, vor einiger Zeit schon. Und was sie machen ist, sie nehmen, also Vodafone beobachtet alle Mobilgeräte auf allen Stationen und wertet die anonymisiert aus. Sie tracken alle sich bewegenden Mobiltelefone auf allen Straßen, überall, alles.
Also nicht nur die, die in Tom-Toms eingebaut sind, sondern wirklich alle?
Alle. Alle in ihrem List.
Wer ist jetzt evil, ne?
Na gut, ich meine, das ist jetzt wirklich die Frage. Und darüber habe ich mich auch sehr lange mit dem Tom-Tom-Vertreter unterhalten. Das war sehr interessant. Aber erstmal, was sie machen. Also sie tracken tatsächlich und triangulieren alle Mobiltelefone und weisen Orten, auch meine Konzentration lässt nach. Sie haben halt sozusagen das ganze Straßennetz und mapen das auf die Straße. Also sie sehen wirklich, da ist ein Mobiltelefon und das bewegt sich.
Sie kriegen Live-Stau-Informationen.
Ja, nicht nur Stau-Informationen, sondern es geht erstmal darum, die durchschnittliche, zu erzielende Geschwindigkeit auf Straßensegmenten herauszufinden. Darum geht es. Das heißt, sie machen ein Tracking von einem Mobiltelefon, von einem Mobiltelefon, was sie ja immer erkennen. E-Mail ist immer die gleiche und so. Das muss auch nicht telefonieren, das reicht ja, wenn das irgendwie eingebucht ist. Und verfolgen das über die Straßensegmente und bilden darüber eine Statistik, wie die durchschnittliche Geschwindigkeit von Autos ist auf bestimmten Straßensegmenten, an bestimmten Tagen und Uhrzeiten.
Das ist schon verdammt geil.
Das heißt, sie bauen eine Datenbank auf für jede Straße, und zwar nicht nur Hauptstraßen, sondern jede Straße, wie der Verkehr dort tatsächlich fließt, real an bestimmten Tagen und an bestimmten Zeitpunkten des Tages. Und das fließt ein in diese IQ-Routes-Geschichte.
Die könnten ja theoretisch auch feststellen, wenn irgendwo eine neue Straße aufgemacht hat.
Klar, wenn die Leute da plötzlich alle langfahren.
Die können alles Mögliche machen. Und das machen sie auch. Und das bedeutet natürlich, dass die Qualität ihres Routings extrem aktuell ist. Und das war für sie übrigens nach zehn Jahren, nachdem sie sozusagen ihre hochoptimierte Routenfindung auf Basis der alten Algorithmen, nachdem sie das sozusagen so weit entwickelt hatten, war es für sie ein echter Test, ob sie sich das trauen, von heut auf morgen auf dieses IQ-Rout umzuschwenken, was eine ganz andere Grundlage hat. Und das haben sie sehr, sehr lange getestet, bis sie sich sicher waren, dass sie dort mindestens die gleiche Qualität, wenn nicht sogar noch bessere, erzielen. Das erzielen sie eigentlich, weil es ja klar ist, sie haben richtige Daten. Das heißt, sie wissen, diese Hauptstraße ist Montagmorgen von neun bis zwölf nicht zu gebrauchen, weil und so weiter. Und dementsprechend passen sie natürlich das Routing an. Habe ich schon so gescherzt, naja, hier irgendwie, das heißt, das nächste Businessmodell für TomTom sieht dann so aus, dass sie sich von Gemeinden bezahlen lassen, damit sie sozusagen die Autos nicht durch ihre Straßen durchrauten.
Das finde ich ja sowieso ein ganz spannendes Phänomen.
Ja, da musste er ein bisschen kichern und meinte, es gab halt tatsächlich solche Beschwerden. Bloß sie hätten sich das halt auch sehr genau angeschaut, wie sie wirklich, welche Ergebnisse erzielen. Und ihrer Meinung nach ist, dass sie dazu beitragen, dass die Straßen halt gleichmäßiger und damit auch klar fairer genutzt werden.
Ich hab mich ja schon immer mal gefragt, wenn ich bei so einem Hersteller von Navigationssystemen arbeiten würde als Entwickler, und ich könnte irgendjemand auf den Tod nicht leiden, ich würde doch die gesamte Autobahn an einem Tag im Jahr durch das Vorgarten leiten. Bei mir ist super leise. Warten wir mal bis nächsten Mittwoch.
Na ja, interessiert euch das noch weiter?
Ich hab ja so einen TomTom Rider, und in welcher Software ist denn dieses EQ-Routing drin?
Das kann ich dir jetzt nicht genau sagen. Da musst du schon selber schauen, ob das da irgendwie mit drin ist. Also wenn du keine Online-Verbindungen hast, dann kriegst du das halt durch deine Updates irgendwie über deine Software, wenn du da dich connectest.
Na, mein TomTom Rider hat halt selber kein Telefon drin, kann aber per Bluetooth mit meinem nicht iPhone sprechen, wenn ich noch meinen Nokia nutzen würde. Wann kommt die bei Apple eigentlich mal klar? Das geht ja mal gar nicht.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist dann in den Karten drin. Also diese IQ-Rats-Geschichte, diese Information ist Teil des Kartenmaterials.
Was dann ein Jahr lang hält, dann ist aber nichts mehr adaptiv.
Naja, das ändert sich jetzt auch nicht so sehr, aber das ist ja dann eben die Verheißung ihrer neuen Live-Services, die das eben live machen. Und du kriegst sechs Monate das kostenlos, das heißt, du weißt die SIM-Karte.
Ich will natürlich ganz stark in diesen Abo-Bereich gehen, weil sonst verdienen sie ja nichts.
Da sind sie eh schon.
Ne, ich hab noch kein Abo. Ich hab mein TomTom mit Fester, Europa-Karte, und die ist halt drauf.
Jaja, du gibst kein Geld für Software-Auslöser.
Ja gut, aber das machen schon viele Leute. Aber das kannst du ja auch ohne diesen Live-Service haben. Du connectest halt einfach dein Gerät an diese Software, die es ja für Mac genauso gibt wie für Windows. Dazu hab ich ihn auch gefragt. Für sie sind die Plattformen gleich.
Ja, es gibt zum Beispiel TomTom Home 2.0.
Feature complete und das sehen sie auch so. Beide Plattformen werden auf gleicher Augenhöhe unterstützt. Also das hast du auch jetzt schon. Du musst das Gerät halt gar nicht erst aus dem Auto rausnehmen und du kriegst es halt mehr oder weniger sofort. Du kriegst halt auch Staumeldungen, sehr detailliert usw. Sie können halt, indem sie diese Vodafone-Daten auch mehr oder weniger in zunehmendem Maße in Echtzeit auswerten, auch Staus erkennen.
Na das wird noch Spaß, wenn Google damit anfängt.
Google macht das schon. Google hat auch schon Traffic-Informationen.
Ja, aber woher nehmen sie die?
Das kann ich dir nicht sicher sagen, das weiß ich nicht.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie die ganz klassisch dazu kaufen, da sie die vor allen Dingen in Europa noch nicht haben.
Genau, dazu habe ich nämlich auch befragt, wo eigentlich diese Staudaten herkommen. Also wo kommen die Verkehrsmeldungen her, die im Radio durchgesagt werden? Und das ist so, es gibt halt amtlicher, es gibt ja diese ganzen Schleifen in der Straße, diese Schlagerschleifen da, die in den Boden eingelassen sind.
In der Pionschleife.
Genau. Darüber machen die tatsächlich so eine Staumessung. Das heißt, eine Staubahnung, die du so im Radio hörst, irgendwie auf der A3, der Stau ist 10 Kilometer lang, das kriegen die aus sowas raus. Und das wird eben auch in so einer ganz abstrakten Form, zumindest für Autobahnen, mit diesem TMC-Dienst über UKW übertragen. Also wenn du deinen TomTom da mit TMC-Support hast, dann lauscht er halt irgendwie auf Deutschlandfunk und zieht sich halt das. Gegen Abo kannst du halt noch TMC Pro kaufen und das sind irgendwie von irgendeinem privaten, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, wie die Daten zusammengestellt werden, aber das ist noch mal ein bisschen detaillierter und aktueller. Aber ob es das wirklich so bringt, ich glaube, das ist wirklich was für Leute, die vor allem auf Autobahnen unterwegs sind, weil das erfasst den Rest nicht. Diese Live-Services von TomTom...
Erfassen alles.
Erfassen im Prinzip alles.
Und das eigentlich ohne echten Mehraufwand, ohne größeren. Also man braucht keine Pummschleifen zu verlegen. Wow, das klingt nach einem...
Achso, sie nehmen übrigens nicht nur die Vodafone-Daten, sondern sie nehmen auch die Daten von den Usern, die bereit sind, ihre Routen, die sie gefahren sind, zu share.
Das ist jetzt ein Mapshare, das gibt's ja seit der Version 7.0, glaube ich.
Genau. Da hab ich gefragt, was man denn davon hat, und naja, meinten sie, davon hat man nur, dass man das Gefühl hat, dass man sich selbst auch seine eigenen Karten damit verbessert. Und dann hab ich die Preise...
Ich dachte, die verlosen mittlerweile auch was dafür.
Ja, tun sie das? Das haben sie mir nicht gesagt.
Ich hab neulich so ein Werbevideo gesehen, das so...
Also ich hab ihnen vorgeschlagen, sie sollten einem dafür kostenlose Abos für Daten, wo man sonst was bezahlen müsste. So was weiß ich. Ich krieg die Blitzer, wenn ich meine Daten liefere. Irgendwie würde sie sich wahrscheinlich gleich sehr positiv auswirken.
Immer so pro Änderung, die man macht, gibt's ein, zwei, drei Tage Abo-Verlängerung. Das summiert sich ja dann auf Dauer. Wenn das Ganze ja mal schick eingibst, bist du ja auch ein ordentlicher Provider.
Find ich auch, aber tun sie nicht, keine Ahnung. Business-Entscheidungen müssen sie selber wissen. Aber ich hab halt diese Datenschutzproblematik angesprochen. Was das Übermitteln von Routen betrifft und generell natürlich auch diese grundsätzliche Problematik, dass so ein Navigationssystem sehr bald Begehrlichkeiten wecken wird. Ohne Frage. Beim Fahrer-Start. Weil irgendwann musst du nachweisen, dass du nicht zu schnell gefahren bist. Und so ein Scheiß. Was natürlich ein bisschen fishy ist, weil dann haben wir alle schön unsere Mods in unserer Software und die liefern natürlich immer schön brav. Ich war und so weiter.
Wie sollen sie das denn tun? Wenn das beim Provider steht? Wenn das der misst? Wenn der misst, wo mein Handy sich wann aufgehalten hat?
Ach so, ja. Das ist nochmal ein anderes Problem. Genau, das ist natürlich, wenn man im Prinzip weiß, welches Handy du hast, das ist einfach, weil sie kennen deine Telefonnummer und dann kennen sie deine E-Mail und dann wissen sie auch, wo du gerade lang fährst und dann können sie auch gleich messen, ob du zu schnell fährst.
Da hat ja der gefatter Staat sowieso schon Zugriff darauf, wo ich mich gerade aufhalte.
Genau. Andererseits hat der Staat aber keine zuverlässige Datenbank im Angebot, wo drin steht, auf welchem Straßensegment man wie schnell fahren darf. Da steht nur so auf so Schildern. Aber digital liegt das nicht vor. Da ist nicht so, dass wenn die irgendwo eine Baustelle aufmachen, dass sie dann irgendwie in der zentralen Geschwindigkeitsdatei für dieses Straßensegment das auch eintragen. Zumindest, wenn sie es machen, dann gibt es diese Daten nicht. Weil das war halt so ein Feature, was ich ganz gerne hätte in der Navigationssoftware. Ich hätte gerne die Information... Also ich möchte, dass das Ding immer Alarm sagt, wenn ich schneller bin als das, was eigentlich dort angesagt ist.
Das könnte man ja eigentlich... Da gibt es ja andere Ansätze, die dann darüber funktionieren, dass du quasi eine Kamera am Auto drinne hast, die einfach die Straße mitfilmt und Verkehrszeichen erkennt.
Ja, gut.
Und wenn man diesen Ansatz kombiniert, dein TomTom, der die Daten überträgt, mit einigen wenigen haben sie eine Kamera drinne hängen und bei dir wird dann sozusagen das interpoliert aus den Daten von den anderen. Schöne neue Welt.
Das war mein IFA-Eindruck. Mehr Details kriege ich jetzt auch gerade nicht zusammen. Das war auf jeden Fall sehr interessant.
Ich war auf jeden Fall erstaunt, dass ich letztens zu meiner Mama kam und den LCD-Fernseher zu Hause hatte. Und ich hab noch so eine Röhre zu Hause, die ist sogar kaputt und meine Mama hat einen LCD-Fernseher.
Was für einen?
Sony.
Hast du deinen MacBook angeschlossen?
Nee, hatte ich nicht bei.
Habt ihr meine Problematik mit Macintosh und Fernseher?
Ja, habe ich gelesen.
Ja, ich hab eine ähnliche Problematik hier am Endeffekt. Ich brauch eigentlich nur so, also ich will keinen Tuner haben, aber ich brauch dafür ein paar SCART-Hatschlüsse, weil ich hab noch Legacy-Geräte und ich will digitale Eingänge auch für die Zukunft halbwegs vorbereitet sein.
Was ist ein SCART?
SCART-Kabel?
Ich kenn doch die Kids, die das nicht mehr.
Kenn ich Kids nicht mehr, das ist das, von dem ihr früher euren VHS-Video-Recorder angeschlossen habt, von dem jedes Gerät einfach zu wenig hat. Die haben maximal zwei SCART-Hatschlüsse immer. Und mittlerweile hab ich meinen Park so weit abgespeckt.
Was hast du noch, was SCART bräuchte für dein Fernseher?
Das ist die Xbox. Das ist die alte. Die Xbox 1 noch, die ganz alte. Die kann man bestimmt auch noch anders anschließen, aber ich schließ sie im Augenblick über SCART an. Und im Augenblick hab ich noch die Wii dran. Und die Wii konnte man natürlich dann über Composite, Cable oder wie auch immer anschließen. Die hat auch keinen DVI.
Die Wii möchtest du über Component anschließen?
Ja, Component. Damit ich dann 720p habe, also die kleinste HD-Auflösung, die es so gibt.
Ich find analog muss sterben.
Also wenn ich mir den Scheiß anschaue, den digital derzeit macht, dann hat analog den großen Vorteil, dass es einfach mal klar definiert ist, wie so ein Signal aussieht. Aber mit diesem ganzen DVI-Trabbel hast du wieder genau diese Inkompatibilitätsscheiße an der Backe, wie bei allen anderen digitalen Protokollen auch.
DVI ist doch auch quasi tot, jetzt kommt doch HD, oder ist schon... Ich dachte HDMI.
The NASA Standard, The NASA Standard.
Und auf der IFA war wohl das große Highlight jetzt Funk, irgendwelche Breitband-Funkstandards für Kurzbereich.
Bleiben wir mal bei der Problematik. Computer an Fernseher anschließen. Ich will halt ein Full HD und ich hab diesen Traum gehabt, dass alles digital ist und so. Und das müsste doch alles ganz einfach sein. Das Ergebnis ist, mit meinem MacBook entschließt das an Fernseher, an Full HD, Fernseher an über HDMI. Was er nicht hat, aber HDMI ist ja nichts anderes als DVI plus X. Und der füllt einfach nicht den ganzen Bildschirm aus.
Sondern? Nicht.
Da ist schwarzer Rahmen. Es sind aber alle Pixel da. Also mein Computer kriegt gesagt von dem Fernseher, dass da ein 1920 x 1080 Pixel Bildschirm ist. Naja, ist er ja auch.
Nee, klar.
Aber? Aber, und dann liefert er ihm halt ein entsprechendes Signal. Was soll er sonst tun? Aber das Bild, was wirklich auch so viele Pixel enthält, das habe ich getestet. Nämlich ein Photoshop-Dokument gemacht habe, was so viele Pixel enthält.
Es wird einfach skaliert oder was?
Ja, es wird skaliert. Das Ding ist, Fernseher, das Produkt Fernseher heißt, die Leute schließen da jeden Scheiß an. Und jeden Scheiß, und zwar meistens gucken sie sogar Fernsehen drauf. Das ist das Erste. Also Leute schauen auf Fernseher an, Fernsehen. Fernsehen ist bei Design etwas, wo man die Kanten abschneidet. Grundsätzlich, Fernsehbild ist immer, in Übergröße wird es ausgestrahlt. Und man geht davon aus, dass man 10 bis 20 Prozent der Bildinhalte einfach abschneidet.
Das berühmte Palfeld.
Das berühmte Palfeld und auch so viele Zuspielesysteme bieten ja dann diese Overscan-Möglichkeit. Das gibt es auch auf dem Mac.
und Ausschalten.
Damit du eben explizit größer rüber sendest und das einfach schon mal so die Hälfte der Information weg ist. Wenn ich meinen Macbook halt an Full HD Fernseher anschließe und Overscan mache, dann macht er auch genau das, aber dann ist auch wirklich mehr abgeschnitten. Schalte ich es aus, habe ich schwarze Ränder. Völlig unklar. Dann bin ich zu Löwe gegangen, auf der IFA. Also ich bin zu Panasonic gegangen, zu LG gegangen, überall habe ich irgendwie rumgetestet, ausprobiert, mal mit mehr oder mal weniger Unterstützung. Mit dem Panasonic-Typ mache ich mich total verstritten, weil er irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, wir kamen irgendwie nicht miteinander klar, dann fing er irgendwie noch an, über irgendwie Leute, die MP3 irgendwie kopieren, herzuziehen, war dann bei mir in den Ofen aus. Wie auch immer, wir hatten keine Freunde. Bei Löwe waren sie sehr nett und meinten so, ja sie hätten hier auch Macintoshes an ihren Fernseher. Ich habe mir schon gedacht, so was ist ja unglaublich. Da hatten die tatsächlich einen Mac Mini, der so ein Video abgespielt hat, zwar auf einer niedrigen Auflösung und hochskaliert und lalala, aber er war tatsächlich so freundlich, wirklich so mitten im Präsentationsbereich, da die Büchse aufzumachen, das Kabel von dem Mac Mini abzuziehen und meinen MacBook anzuschließen, das fand ich wirklich cool. Ich hab nicht gedacht, bei LG waren sie alle so komm sie doch mal kurz vor Stores Schluss wieder und so, jetzt können wir das doch nicht machen. Der war cool. Und naja, mein MacBook, schwarzer Rahmen. Der Mac Mini, kein schwarzer Rahmen.
Das ist nämlich, kann das vielleicht... Moment mal, woran liegt das dann?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich verstehe das echt total überhaupt nicht. Es kann durchaus sein, dass mein MacBook sich anders verhält, als andere Macs.
Das ist ja kein echtes DVI-Signal.
Ich meine, alle Computermonitore, die ich anschließe, die sagen auch, welche Auflösung sie haben, sie kriegen das Signal und zeigen es an. Jeder Beamer, wo ich mich... Ich habe mich heute an DVI-Beamer angeschlossen. Das ist alles überhaupt gar kein Problem. Was ich vorhin sagen wollte mit den Fernsehern ist, diese Fernsehgeräte, die haben halt alle so Steine drin, die einfach alles skalieren. Das heißt, da kommt so Input und dann geht das erstmal in so eine Skalierungseinheit. Weil sie in der Lage sein müssen, alles zu skalieren, egal wie es zugespielt wird.
Und egal welches Aspektratio es hat, weil so ein DVD-Player hat ja auch keine quadratischen Pixel, sondern 4 zu 3, 6 zu 9, wie auch immer. Und deswegen müssen jetzt auch alles nochmal gerade biegen.
Genau, also Skalieren ist ja einfach bei Default. Und aus irgendwelchen mir wirklich nicht nachvollziehbaren Gründen interpretiert er das Signal, was mein MacBook liefert, obwohl es halt HDMI ist. Und obwohl die ja sich gegenseitig darüber austauschen, was sie für Aspektratio und Pipapo haben.
Und obwohl es mit dem Mac Mini geht.
Und obwohl es mit dem Mac Mini geht, skalieren alle Fernseher, also alle, ich hab's ausprobiert, mit Toshiba, Panasonic, Löwe, Samsung, mehrere Geräte, mehrere Hersteller, überall dasselbe Ergebnis. Nicht unbedingt immer zentriert, mal auch ein bisschen weiter nach rechts geschoben und so. Also ganz komische Effekte. Irgendwie gibt's da wohl so ein Fleck, vermute ich, wo diese, ich weiß nicht, es gibt ja auch verschiedene Sachen, die man mit diesem Fernseher erstmal ausschalten muss, um überhaupt ein brauchbares Bild zu bekommen. Du musst dann irgendwie diese Schärfe, Nachschärfe ausschalten, du musst dann irgendwie True-Scannen, dass er irgendwie auch wirklich Pixel-to-Pixel macht, einschalten oder ausschalten, je nachdem. Dann musst du diese bekloppte Motion-Compensation, die sie da mit drin haben, also das musst du alles ausschalten, um ein ordentliches Bild zu kriegen. Also, wenn sich jemand von den Hörern da auskennt und wirklich Plan hat, wie so ein Fernseher heutzutage, insbesondere diese Full-HD-Dinger, mit so einem DVI-Signal umgeht, was über HDMI reinkommt, dann wären wir da schon einen Schritt weiter. Das ist noch ein bisschen frustrierend, weil ich würde mir jetzt ganz gerne mal so ein Ding kaufen, weil ich hätte gerne mal eine größere Lampe. Ich werde demnächst noch mal losziehen mit Markmini und noch mal ein paar Tests machen. Naja, das waren so meine IFA-Erlebnisse.
Also meine Computer- und Fernseherlebnisse sind ja 22 Jahre her. Und zwar hatte ich da so einen Amiga 1000 und der hatte einen RGB-Analog-Ausgang. Richtig geiler Shit. Und ich hatte dann Fernseher gekauft vor so einem riesen Sony-Teil. Und siehe da, voll Glück hab, was hat dieses Teil? RGB-Analog-Eingang habe ich meinen Amiga angeschlossen. Das war das beste Bild überhaupt. Ich denke mal, wenn du heute deinen Mac mit irgendwie S-Video an den Fernseher schließt, ist das Bild nicht besser.
S-Video bestimmt nicht, S-Video ist ja schlechter.
S-Video geht ja mittlerweile auch so.
Das ist wie voriges Jahr.
Super Bild.
Wie voriges Jahr.
RGB halt.
RGB-Analog.
Die sagt, ganz schön langer Podcast.
Neuer Rekord, vier Stunden.
Naja, gibt gute Gründe, sich den in mehreren Teilen anzulernen. Dreieinhalb Stunden und wir haben trotzdem noch ein Thema.
Noch ein? Ach, dein Bling. Ach, das Bling. Jetzt mach mal hier. Jetzt blinkt's.
Oder nächste Sendung.
Was soll man denn da einen Spannungsbogen aufbauen, wenn ihr das schon vorher auspetzt?
Ach so, das hat er vorhin schon gesagt.
Jaja, das gilt auch für Dennis.
Ich dachte, das wäre jetzt schon...
Spannungsbogen ist dahin.
Aber Max hat's doch schon gesagt. Finger Zeige.
Also, die News ist, es wird wieder Blinkenlights geben.
Oh mein Gott!
Ja doch, wann denn?
Tut mal ein bisschen überrascht.
Bin ich total überrascht. Wann geht's denn los? Wann blinkt's?
Vierter Oktober.
Wo?
In...
In einem Hochhaus.
In einem Hochhaus?
Dieser Kontinent?
Nein.
Toronto.
Canada. Wir gehen nach Toronto mit Blinkenlights, unsere dritte Installation nach langer, langer, langer Zeit und da waren wir jetzt sehr zurückhaltend in der Hand.
Dann hast du ja schon in nur vier Wochen.
Letzte Woche haben wir die Produktion abgeschlossen. Die Scheiße ist jetzt auf dem Dampfer und schippert ganz ruhig dahin und ich hoffe, es kommt alles an und der Dampfer geht nicht unter. Und irgendwann kommt das da an und wird hoffentlich dann schön durch den Zoll durchgewunken, dass das alles kein Problem ist. Vier Tonnen Equipment. Zehn Paletten voll mit Zeug. Und das Ganze geht dann dahin. In die Toronto.
Ist da so ein Euro-Container drin?
Euro-Container gibt es nicht.
Wie heißt der Standard-Container?
ISO-Container.
ISO-Container, ok. Was kostet einen so einen Container verschippen nach Kanada? Passt doch bestimmt im Kopf.
Hin und zurück zahlst du so 7500.
Und ist es denn komplett dein Container?
Also für einen halben Container. So ein 20-Fuß-Container. Genau, da muss man dann auch nicht so aufs Kilo achten. Das war für uns sehr wichtig, weil wir viele schwere Scheiße verschicken. Wenn du das mit dem Flugzeug machen würdest, machst du dich dumm, machst dich alle.
Und ich hab gehört, du hast aber schon, ich hab ja ein bisschen gelauscht und so, du hast schon ein paar Geräte rausgenommen aus dem Container und die habt ihr so hingeschickt, damit die schneller da sind, damit schon mal geübt werden kann. Stimmt das?
Jaja, wir haben dann noch so eine kleine Crew vor Ort, die testet schon mal. Weil wir haben eine neue Technologie entwickelt, wir haben Wireless-Dimmer gebaut.
In der mein alter EEPC eine nicht ganz komplett unwesentliche Rolle spielt, wenn ich mich...
Stimmt, dein alter EEPC, den ich dir abgekauft habe, ein Gerät, was ja sozusagen für spezielle Anwendungen ganz geeignet ist, für allgemeine finde ich ja nicht so. Also benutzen kann ich das Ding nicht. Also diesen EEPC, da kriege ich keine Taste gedrückt.
Als Urlaubsgerät war es okay?
Meinetwegen. Aber so, ich weiß nicht. Als Desktop finde ich es unpassend. Aber es ist auch egal, ich will nicht über den EEPC reden, aber die EEPC haben wir aber schön zum Einsatz gebracht. Er hat schön beim Flaschen geholfen und Barcode-Scannen und Pipapole. Dafür war das Ding super. Vor allem, weil er so viele schöne USB-Ports hat. Das war echt toll. Wir haben diese Wireless-Dimmer gebaut, das heißt, wir bauen eine komplette Wireless-Blinken-Lights-Installation.
Die ist dann noch nicht in Farbe?
Nein, wir machen keine Farbe.
Aber wireless pro Etage, also bis zur Etage ist Kabel und da steht eine Wireless-Station, die die Fenster einzeln per Wireless ansteuert.
Richtig, so funktioniert das.
Könnte natürlich dahinter auch mit WLAN funktionieren, also bis dahin ist IP und ab da ist dann ein Spezialprotokoll 2,4 GHz.
Wie groß ist euer Display?
Pixel? 960 Fenster verteilt auf zwei Türme, die unterschiedlich breit und unterschiedlich hoch sind, die gekrümmt sind und sich gegenüber stehen. Das ist die Toronto City Hall, kann jeder mal nachschlagen. Gibt es eine schöne Seite in der englischen Wikipedia. Und ist ein außergewöhnlich schönes Gebäude.
Ist das schon bevölkert oder ist es noch leer?
Das ist bevölkert. Das ist die City Hall, das ist das Rathaus. Da sind schon Leute drin?
Sind denn die Lampen direkt bei den Leuten vorm Schreibtisch?
Ja, quasi. Also das Schöne ist, dass das Gebäude beste Voraussetzungen hat. Da ist so ein durchgehender SIMS und man kann das halt da ganz gut installieren. Es ist trotzdem noch eine ganze Menge Arbeit, aber wir haben da einen Weg gefunden. Ich meine, nachts arbeiten die da nicht, von da passt das schon. Die müssen halt nur tagsüber übertragen, dass da so Plane an ihren Fenstern hängen. Die können dann auch so ein bisschen zur Seite machen. Ein schönes System entwickelt.
Und was wird sich darauf abspielen, auf dieser Blinkenleitsituation?
Gute Frage. Also das ist alles noch in Entwicklung. Und es gibt auch einen Grund, warum ich das hier im Mobile-Max-Podcast jetzt das erste Mal überhaupt anspreche.
Wir sind hier in Words First sozusagen.
Das ist die totale Premiere hier. Ich hab bisher richtig schön small gehalten. Und jetzt... Die Webseite ist jetzt noch nicht ganz fertig. Deswegen sag ich jetzt die URL mal noch nicht. Aber real soon now, das geht irgendwie alles diese Woche noch los. Und einer der Gründe, warum ich das hier erwähne, ist, dass wir dieses Mal ganz gut Apple-Technologie zum Einsatz bringen, um den Content zu machen. Und zwar zweierlei. Erstens, es wird ein Real-Time-Simulator geben, wo man sozusagen denselben Datenstrom, den wir an unsere Lampen schicken, übers Internet sich beziehen kann. Das heißt, es gibt einen Simulator, und der wird auf dem Mac laufen, und schön in 3D sein. Eine 3D-Anwendung.
Und dann kann man auch Kamera schwenken und so was?
Nee.
Da kann man ranzoomen, reinzoomen, links nach rechts, das ganze Gebäude drehen und so. Dann sieht man das alles live sozusagen. Kann ich dir hier auch schon mal den Prototypen mal kurz zeigen.
Natürlich geil, dass ich das jetzt sehen kann, und auch sagen mir keiner und ich auch.
Na du darfst halt reagieren, ne?
Genau.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob es jetzt...
Bis jetzt passiert noch gar nichts.
Ey, weißt du, hier ist auch ein Macintosh, der braucht eine Weile, um das zu steigern.
Okay, wir sehen schon mal ein Bild.
So, ich weiß aber jetzt gerade nicht, ob der Daten...
Im Augenblick ist das Licht geradeaus.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob der Datenstrom läuft.
Ne, das ist ein...
Und jetzt ist das hier alles irgendwie in 3D.
Die Häuser schweben im luftleeren Raum.
Genau, das ist jetzt alles noch ein bisschen abstrakt, aber das wird noch. Und diese Anwendung, die du hier auf dem Macintosh siehst, die soll halt auch aufs iPhone. Das heißt, wir werden eine iPhone-Applikation liefern, wo jeder live die Installation sozusagen mitbekommen kann. Und dann hoffen wir, dass wir da auch möglichst weit kommen. Jetzt will ich mal nicht so viel verraten. Es gibt da noch so ein paar nette Details, aber das muss auch alles erst noch mal realisiert werden. Das ist nicht ganz einfach mit dem 3D auf dem iPhone. Wir haben da noch so einige Probleme, das Geschwindigkeit zu optimieren. Aber ich hoffe, dass das was wird. Aber ich bin da sehr zuversichtlich, dass das was wird, weil die Jungs, die das machen, sind die Coding-Monkeys und die wissen, was sie tun.
Sehr schick, das sieht echt nett aus.
Genau. So, und was damit auch noch zusammenhängt?
Kurze Frage.
Ja?
Ich hatte gerade auch eine Ull gepostet, wo ich geklickt habe, das heißt irgendwie StereoScope oder wie das Projekt, ja? Und das ist auch die Nuit Blanche, weil das Arcade in Frankreich war doch auch schon Nuit Blanche.
Richtig.
Das ist wieder so eine Nuit Blanche. Na die Nuit Blanche, dasselbe in grün, also das ist dasselbe Konzept.
Okay, aber es sind nicht die gleichen Macher, die diese Nuit Blanche haben?
Nein, nein. Die erste Nuit Blanche war ja eine Idee der Stadt Paris. Und die Idee hat es halt so gut eingeschlagen, dass die, das Konzept dann auch in Kanada aufgegriffen wurde. Und so gab es eine in Montreal und dann gab es das auch in Toronto. Was machen die jetzt seit zwei, drei Jahren?
Das ist super erfolgreich gewesen.
Das heißt, es ist wieder so eine ganze Nacht, wo Leute durch die Stadt jagen und es gibt halt überall Kunst in ganz vielen Orten. Also wir sind da nicht die Einzigen, sondern wir sind da nur ein Projekt von ganz vielen. Aber sicherlich das sichtbarste, da kann man gar nicht fragen, weil wir halt mitten in der City sind und eben die City-Häube spielen, die halt so ganz nebenbei eben auch das Wahrzeichen der Stadt ist. Abgesehen jetzt von dem, also Wahrzeichen ein bisschen schwer. Das Wahrzeichen ist glaube ich der CN Tower. Ganz klar größte Gebäude nach wie vor, bis jetzt Dubai ablöst, aber das Logo der Stadt ist eben auch die Umrisse der City Hall, weil das so ein schönes Gebäude ist.
Und warum habt ihr die Außenseite von der City Hall nicht bekommen?
Weil die keine Außenseite hat, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Hat eine Außenseite, aber das ist einfach eine Mauer.
Eine Fensterlose.
Echt, die ist zu?
Die hat ihre Fenster nach innen.
Und außen gar keine?
Das ist ein total abgefahrenes Gebäude und es ist eine echte Herausforderung, dafür Content zu machen. Und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht, wie machen wir denn das mit so vielen Pixeln? Und da kommt die zweite Apple Technologie zum Einsatz, nämlich Quartz Composer.
Ihr macht das mit Quartz Composer?
Wir werden ein Toolset realisieren, was komplett Quartz Composer hat. Das heißt, es gibt Plugins für Quartz Composer, mit denen man Blinkenlights, Movies senden und empfangen kann. Das hat auch mit diesem Simulator zusammenarbeitet, sodass man sozusagen in Quartz Composer Animationen machen kann, die man dann live gleich per IP-Strom auf den Simulator schicken kann.
Ich krieg mir mein Quartz Composer-Teil zusammen und mach als Endmodul, oder als Output, mache ich dann so ein Modul von euch da rein. Das heißt, ich könnte jetzt auch schon den Apple RSS-Feed nehmen, das Modul von euch reinklatschen, dann kommt der Apple RSS-Feed auf dem Gebäude.
Genau.
Also, wenn du da live hin streamen könntest, was jetzt nochmal nicht Sinn der Sache ist, sondern hier geht es darum, dass man dann eben solche Animationen aufnimmt. Das heißt, du kannst mit dem Modul, da kannst du es ja live auf dem Simulator, also wenn der Mac-Simulator draußen ist, kannst du es dann halt damit anschauen, gleich in 3D, wie es aussieht, damit du auch so gleich sehen kannst, ah, so könnte es irgendwie sein. Das ist ja unser Hauptproblem, bevor das nicht gebaut ist, weißt du einfach nicht, wie es rüber kommt. Deswegen eben der Simulator. Und wir wollen aber auch, da es so eine große Fläche ist, und BlinkNight kommt ja nun wirklich von ganz woanders her, da hatten wir irgendwie 18x8 Pixel in Berlin mit diese minimale 144-Pixel-Auflösung, hat ja eine enorme Kreativität freigesetzt, weil die Leute eben so beschränkt waren. Aber wir haben schon gemerkt, in Paris mit 520 Fenstern war einfach eine Grenze überschritten, wo man eben aufhört, so eine Grafik Pixel zu optimieren.
Also wo man wirklich noch Pixel für Pixel malt.
Genau, das ist einfach schon zu viel. Und das ist natürlich jetzt mit den 960 Fenstern da kein Deut besser. Und dadurch, dass es auch noch so gekrümmt ist und so lädt das einfach zu einer ganz anderen Ästhetik ein. Und wie diese Ästhetik letztlich sein wird, das werden wir dann sehen. Aber worauf wir halt setzen, sind eben computergenerierte Animationen, die flächig arbeiten, die sich quasi wie so ein Zylinder mitten in dieses Haus stellen und alles irgendwie überwabern. Und wir haben eine neue Software geschrieben, die so eine Art Videomixer ist, sodass man eben mit diesen Animationen quasi so einen Background macht. Und die Fassade ist ja in so vier Teile aufgeteilt. Also es gibt vier Screens. Und wir adressieren diese Screens einzeln dann halt noch mit unserem klassischen Kram. Das heißt, du kannst halt Bong spielen auf dem einen Screen und Tetris auf dem anderen Screen. Und alles, wo nicht gerade irgendwas läuft, läuft halt diese Animation. Sodass es die ganze Zeit gruselig aussah. Das kann man irgendwie mixen und überblenden und so weiter.
Mit Quartz Composer könnt ihr doch garantiert auch wunderbar die größte iTunes-Visualisierung der Welt machen, oder? Da unten schöne Soundanlage hinstellen und richtig schön reinknallen.
Ja, da haben wir auch noch was ganz anderes im Petto. Ich werd jetzt mal noch nicht alles verraten. Die Webseite wird jetzt fertiggestellt und wird die Tage announced werden. Da muss noch ein bisschen Energie reinfließen. Auf jeden Fall könnt ihr euch alle schon mal ein bisschen darauf einstellen, dass es da demnächst ein paar schöne McIntosh-Downloads gibt und man eben den Mac benutzen kann, um für diese Installation Zeug zu machen. Natürlich wollen wir da auch einiges sehen, weil bei Blinknads geht's eben um Participation. Wir wollen das nicht alles selber machen. Wir bauen die Plattform, damit Leute eben damit Spaß haben können.
Und wie lange ist die Installation?
Die wird nicht lange laufen.
Das heißt, die Leute müssten sich ihre Animationen schon vorher ein bisschen zusammenschustern, weil sie nicht so ewig Zeit haben, das vor Ort zu machen.
Ja klar, also im Idealfall läuft das System als simuliertes Ding noch weiter im Netz, sodass man mit Simulator und so weiter auch weiterhin arbeiten kann. Da wollen wir auch die alten Installationen noch mal zum Leben bringen. Aber es ist natürlich viel cooler, wenn man weiß, dass es eben auch wirklich auf dem Haus läuft.
Und die Tools kommen aber jetzt schon demnächst, damit die vorher alles schön loslegen.
Die Tools sind jetzt weitgehend fertig und jetzt sind wir gerade noch dabei, das alles auf der Webseite zusammenzufummeln. Eigentlich wollte ich jetzt schon so hier los posauen, machen wir jetzt aber noch nicht. Und die Findigen unter euch werden das sowieso rausfinden. Und die Tage gibt es dann halt nochmal ein richtiges Official Announcement und dann geht es irgendwie los. Aber ich wollte das mal hier losbringen, weil ich werde halt auch bald aufbrechen in zwei Wochen. Verlasse ich sozusagen Deutschland, fahre nach Kala. Müssen wir mal gucken, ob wir vorher noch einen hinkriegen. Ist ein bisschen knapp. Müssen wir mal ein bisschen vorziehen. Ja, na ja, man könnte immer mehr Zeit haben. Aber so ist das halt.
Das ist doch aber jetzt eine gute Gelegenheit, wo ich jetzt gerade schon fast einschlafe. Nicht weil es so ein spektakulär wäre, sondern weil ich fertig bin.
Ja, wir haben auf jeden Fall alles erzählt. Und am Ende gab es noch Überraschungen. Und jetzt haben wir 3 Stunden und 45 Minuten gequatscht.
Das ist das mit One More Thing anzunehmen, das fällt mir gerade auf.
Leute, die sich das komplett anhören.
Darum verraten wir jetzt die Lottozahlen für nächste Woche.
Die Außendienstmitarbeiter sagen jetzt wieder, dass sie zweimal hin und her fahren mussten, um sich das anzuhören.
Oder viermal. Oder mehr. Es gibt auch Leute, die sagen, wenn man nicht so lange hören will, hört man halt nicht so lange. Man hört halt nur bis Kurzfolgen Great News.
Ich würde Chapter Marx.
Ich weiß. Chapter Marx hat aber eine Menge Arbeit. Dafür müsste es mal ordentliche Tools geben.
Da musst du mitten in der Sendung sagen, zack, neues Thema.
Ja, kann man irgendwie mit Überkasta machen, aber dann müsste ich mal mit Überkasta aufnehmen, müsste ich Überkasta kaufen.
Da sprechen wir nächstes Mal drüber.
Genau.
Aber es ist eigentlich toll.